learn how to use react and Firebase to
create an Instagram clone barock will
teach you how to build a sophisticated
social media application from scratch
you'll explore the powerful combination
of react for front-end development and
Firebase for backend Services learning
to create an Instagram like platform
with features such as user
authentication profile customization
post creation real-time interactions and
more hey everyone and welcome back so in
the next couple of hours we're going to
be building a full stack Instagram
colone with react and Firebase and at
the end we're going to deploy it so that
you can put that link on your resume I
want this tutorial to be as beginner
friendly as possible so we are not going
to be using any react Frameworks such as
njs but instead we're going to be using
a tool called vit to initialize a react
app which is absolutely fine besides
react and Firebase we're going to be
using chakra UI for styling Z Library
for State Management and a couple of
more useful packages that will help us
build this application faster in the
first 3ish hours we're going to build
the UI design and in the remaining part
we're going to add all of the full stack
features one thing that I want to
mention is that recording these
tutorials are taking a lot of time and
effort and currently I am studying
computer science so in theory I don't
really have time to record these
tutorials but in practice I somehow
managed to do it so I don't really want
to sound any dramatic but all I want
from you is to subscribe to channel and
like this video so that it can reach to
more people and without any further Ado
let's take a look at the demo and then
we're going to start coding okay so now
I am in the oath page where I can log in
or I can sign up so I already have an
account and I'll just go ahead and sign
in but you can log in or sign up with
your Google account as well so let me
just go ahead and log
in so if I just put the wrong password
it is just going to say invalid
credentials but if I just put the
correct one it is just going to log me
in now we are in the homepage where we
can see the posts of the users that we
follow and currently we are following
this user as well as Heisenberg so we
could like these posts or unlike that so
it's going to update depending on that
we can see all of the comments by
clicking that and we can even comment
from here nice pick guys let's say and
if you just post that it's going to have
loading State and there we go it is just
has been posted and here on the homepage
we have the suggested users component
where we can follow those users and it's
going to immediately update our feed
depending on that and we could just like
those post as well or we could unfollow
these users from here and again it's
going to update our feed so we could
create a post but more on that later so
we could search users so I'll just say
Jane do if we search that there we go
this is the user that we have we could
follow or unfollow from here as well so
let's go to a profile page of a user
we're going to see their posts followers
and following counts as well as all of
the posts so if we just click to one of
them we're going to get to see this
caption uh comments number of likes and
when this has been posted we could even
comment from here
and we could follow or unfollow this
user so let's go to our own profile and
here we could edit our profile where we
have the username bio as well as the
full name so I'll just change my profile
picture so I will just select an image
from my machine and I'll just select
this one and if I submit that it is
going to have the loading State and
there we go profile updated successfully
and this is our new profile picture that
we can can see and we could go and
delete a post so if I collected this
since this is my post I can see this
delete icon and I could just delete that
if I say cancel it is not going to
delete but if I say actually delete this
post it is going to say that post
deleted successfully and it is going to
update this number of posts so we could
go ahead and try to create a post if you
just put a caption but not the image it
is not going to allow us because uh an
image is required so even if we don't
put the caption we going to still get
the same error so I'll just select an
image maybe I'll just say this is
Bob and if I post that it is going to
have a loading state for a second and
then post created successfully we see
that number of posts has been
incremented by one and this is the post
that we just got so it says posted 9
seconds ago and we could just comment
like unlike and it is going to be
updated depending on that and lastly
this application is completely
responsive so if we go to here and let's
take a look so this is on the larger
screens let's close that and as we
shrink the sidebar will shrink as well
and the post will be in the vertical
direction that we can see and it is
going to work up until 300 pixels which
is one of the smaller uh smallest
devices and we can go into the homepage
there we go it is going to still work
uh almost in every page so in the
homepage o page and the profile page and
our models are also working fine so this
is the create post model as well as the
search user model that we can see from
here and basically we could just log out
from this account so by clicking that
icon so there we can see now everything
works fine in the larger screens we have
this image but on mobile devices we
don't and we're going to be storing
everything in our Firebase account there
we can see see we have the fire store
database storage and authentication
system so here in the database we are
having the posts as well as the users
that we just store and in the storage
bucket we are having our posts as well
as profile pictures so these are the
images that we have in our application
as well as the authentication system
there we can see these are the users
that have signed up to our application
and these are the providers so this user
signed up with Google account and these
others signed up with email and password
credentials so that's pretty much it now
let's get started so the first thing
that we need is to create an empty
folder I created it in my desktop and I
called it insta clone and then I just
open it up in vs code now we're going to
go into the view and terminal so here we
we are going to just create an empty uh
react application so we could say mpm
create so that should be create vat at
latest and then press enter is going to
ask us some questions so the project
name is just going to be dot so that it
will initialize it uh under this folder
so press enter and we're going to choose
react with JavaScript and now it says
run mpm install and then mpm runev so
let's say mpm install to get the note
modules folder and once it is done I'll
be right back okay so it has been
completed now we're just going to say
mpm run Dev and press enter it's going
to uh start our application in this 51
uh 73 Port it should be in your case but
in my case it is
5174 it is because the de demo
application is running in this port and
if I just say a local host
5174 I should get this empty uh react
application so this is the borderer
plate that we have now we're just going
to clear this a bit so I will open up
this shrink the terminal we're going to
go into the source and app jsx we could
literally just delete everything here um
so let's say I here we're going to
delete the logo react logo um also app
CSS file so we could just uh delete this
as well as the import we could remove
this use
State okay and then we're going to go
let's delete this assets as well and
then what are we going to have inside
the main jsx we are going to only only
going to have the index CSS but we can
just clear this file as well so I'll
just delete everything and save this
file um now let's see what do we have so
we have this High text in our homepage
so in this application we're going to
use multiple images and I will provide
all of them for you which you can grab
from the GitHub so go inside the public
F uh public folder and just maybe delete
it okay we're going to create another
one with empty content and then just
copy all of them and paste it into this
fold folder so we have the oath PNG
which we're going to use in our uh the
authentication page we're going to have
our Fab icon uh Google icon image 1 2 3
and four for our posts and we're going
to have this logo that we're going to
use as well as um Microsoft icon Play
Store and the profile picture which you
can uh replace it with your own so now
that we have handled our images we are
going to go and install the chakra so
let's say chakra
d.com so if you never heard of it it is
a simple modular and accessible
component library that gives you the uh
kind of like already components
components that you don't need to create
so if you want to use a button just
simply search for it and it's going to
give you different um kinds of button
that you can use so the solid outline
and so what is this so variant is Ghost
and maybe the link so let's say you want
to create a model but you don't want to
write the code from scratch and there
you go they just give you the code you
just uh open the model close it and copy
copy the code and paste it and it's just
going to work fine and in this video
we're just going to learn everything
about chakra so first let's go into the
getting started page so we're going to
get started with v so let's see say um
is this for V I'm not sure that says
index jsx so here let's just scroll to
the very bottom we have this V and
select it now we're going to copy this
installation script and then open up a
new terminal so maybe we could just
suppl this one and paste it press enter
and then while it uh installs let's see
so it says provider setup which we are
just going to wrap our application with
this um chakra provider thing that we
can see here and then we're going to
just import it so I will just copy this
line and then go to
main.js okay we are just going to
install this okay and then say chakra
provider and trap our application with
it and what this is going to allow us is
that now our application can use any
kind of component that is coming from
Chakra so the buttons models the avatars
so everything and what is an avatar
let's see
so it is this thing this profile avatars
that we can use so let's see if it has
been installed um okay it is beenin but
we have an error that says chakra UI or
maybe we could just refresh this here
again okay so now it works fine we can
go to the inside app jsx and instead of
uh instead of saying hi we'll just say
uh maybe
button that is coming from Chakra let's
import this and not from the disc but it
should be just chakra and we'll say
hello world if we just save this now
let's see and we got this light button
and now we want to use a dark mode in
our application so what we have here is
only dark mode and this is what
Instagram uses so let's search for it it
will say color mode and now let's see it
gives you this extend theme okay we're
going to copy this and we're going to go
into the main jsx so let's shrink our
console or terminal and we're going to
paste this extend uh extend theme as
import and then we're going to get this
config as well as the theme so I'm going
to copy this and paste this and this
theme is going to be passed to this
chakra provider so I'll say theme is
going to be go here okay so it's going
to be going to here and we want to
change this initial color mode from
light to dark and yeah so our
application is only going to have the
dark mode because this is what Instagram
has and we're are passing this config
into this extend theme and that theme is
going to be used uh in our entire
application so now our application has
the dark mode by default and also we
want to change the background color when
we are in the dark mode it is because
the chakra uses this um this background
color for the dark mode and we just want
to have this completely black color for
this we need to change something and
that thing is just going to be inside an
object so let's just write it down and
then I'll explain so con Styles this is
how are we this is how we're going to be
um customizing our theme so this going
to be an object which takes the global
which is also going to be a function
that takes the props and here this props
oops is going to return an object so
here let's open up our parentheses as
well as the curly braces and the thing
that we would like to change is going to
be the body okay background of the body
as well as the color so for the
background we'll just say um mode
function that is coming from Chakra so
it doesn't give us so let's just import
it manually import mode from Chakra UI
and from the theme tools and we'll just
say mode and the first thing that it
takes the uh back color for the light
mode and we can just put anything here
but let's just put gray uh 100 and for
the dark mode we would like to have
completely black black background so
we'll just put three zeros and then call
this function again with props and this
is going to handle the background color
for us for the body and then we're going
to have the color that says mode and
again the light mode uh the light color
first and then the dark and dark color
so we could just say grade 800 and then
for the background we could just say I
mean for the dark mode we could just say
white Alpha 900 and call it with the
props and then we're going to take this
Styles extend the theme with it with it
and this theme is being passed to our
chakra provider which uh provides it to
our entire application so if we just
save this now we're going to see our
background has has been changed to the
black color and it didn't because now we
are in the light mode if you go to our
if you open up our terminal or console
we're going to go into the application
the local storage here it should be
let's see okay local storage if you just
delete this and refresh our page it is
going to be in the dark mode and as you
can see the background is um the black
so let's quickly summarize what we did
so here we just create a Styles uh
object with the global function or the
global key and it just changes the body
uh field the body selector and we're
changing the background as well as the
color and in the light mode we're going
to use this uh background color and in
the dark mode we're going to use this
background color and for the light mode
we're going to use this color and for
the dark mode we're going to use this
color and then we're passing this into
this extend theme so that it will
overwrite the color that chakra provider
gives us and then we're just passing it
into into our app okay so yeah this is
going to be our chakra uh set up so in
our application we're going to use
different icons as well as we're going
to have different pages so for this we
need to install a couple of packages or
actually just two so let's say mpm
install and maybe I should just kill
this terminal and open up a new one so
that we don't give we don't get any any
weird highlighting so I'll just say mpm
install react Das icons as well as um
react
router down so and just press enter this
is going to allow us to uh just for the
navigation and this will gives us
different icons so let's just take a
look at the icons that we're going to be
using so we could just say react icons
and here let's go to this GitHub pages
and then so if we just search for any
icon here let's say home we can just
copy and paste it and it's just going to
work so the other thing was react r d
and for this we are going to go first
into the main jsx okay we already have
it open so we're going to wrap our
application with something called
browser router and then just wrap entire
application with it and this is going to
allow us to use any component that is
coming from um the react router down
Library so we're going to save this file
here and then inside the app jsx we're
going to put our routes so maybe we
could just have this empty fragment and
just delete this uh we're going to have
routes okay that that is wrong so let's
just delete and then try again okay this
is our fragment and then here we just
have
routes that is coming from react rou D
and we're going to have route component
which is going to be just self closing
and then let's see import this and if
you are in the homepage so let's say
path is slash that just indicates the
homepage we're going to show an element
and this is going to be our homepage
component which we're just going to
create so now we're getting this uh red
underline it's because we don't have
this page it is not defined so for this
we're going to go and create a Pages
folder and another folder called let's
say home um that should be homepage and
then inside this we're going to have
homepage. jsx and we're going to use RFC
to get this boiler plate and it is
coming from my extension let's see it
was react um Snippets I
believe so it should be let's say react
okay it is this one so es uh 7 plus
react Redux react native Snippets if you
install this you can now use this so say
rafc which gives you this boiler PL and
then here um you could save this let's
go here import the homepage from the
pages folder and then homepage folder
and then homepage. jsx so we can delete
this button because we're not going to
be using this in this component now
let's save and if you go to the homepage
we see this homepage text that we can
see now we're also going to add a page
when we go to the oath page for now we
don't have this page so let's just
created we are going to just duplicate
this route it is going to be slash oath
and then we'll just show the oath page
and now let's create this under the
pages folder let's say another folder
it's going to be oath page and then oath
page. jsx and get the boiler plate that
says this is the oath page and let's
import this when we go to/ oath now um
we cannot see anything refresh again so
it is not working let's see from o page
um I don't know why but let's delete
this H from out page that should be
already working I'm not sure delete all
these um so let's try this again okay so
even if we just say even if it didn't
change change here so even if it was
like this if we had this import react
statements up here up here it should
still be working so okay it just it just
working now but the reason that I
deleted it deleted it is because we're
not using this react anywhere we're not
using this one so yeah it it wasn't
related to that import react statement
okay so with this quick explanation now
let's move on with the oath page so the
first thing that we're going to have
let's take a look so everything now is
in the center that you can see on the
left we have our image and on the right
we have this oath form so just to take
everything to this Center what we're
going to use in Chakra something called
container and what it does it just uh to
contain any piece of content wrap it in
the container component and it takes um
okay so we don't have any description
for this but I'll just explain it just
takes everything into the center of the
parent container okay so here our parent
container is the body so it just put
puts everything into theer Center so now
let's go to the oath page and we're just
going to code it from scratch okay here
we could just delete everything just
return maybe a flex and then just coming
from
Chakra and okay here we're going to have
a container so let's say container which
is also coming from Chakra react and
that shouldn't be this I don't know why
it gives us so maybe it it is still
working in this we're going to see and
this container we can just say Max width
is just going to be container. MD and we
could say it is not going to have any
petting so petting is going to be zero
and just to put this container to the
center we'll say minimum height of 100
pH and then this Flex is just going to
be justify content to be Center as well
as align items to be Center and petting
X could be four and here let's say this
is some content now if we just take a
look at this in the O page so okay it
shouldn't be coming from this we could
just delete this it should be chakra /ui
and then I mean chakra - ui/ react so
here uh okay the our content is
literally in the center in the middle of
the screen and we're going to put a
image on the left and then on the right
we're going to put that authentication
form so this is going to be let's put
our commments
left hand side and then we're going to
also have the right hand side but for
now let's say box which is just a basic
div so here we'll say
display okay it's going to have some
Styles and on the mobile so here let's
take a look on the mobile we're not
going to show this image we're only
going to have this form so that's why
we're going to come here and say display
in the mobile if you want to make
something responsive we put another
object into here and we just say on the
base which is smaller screens and above
it's going to be none but the medium
screens and above it is just going to be
block so medium screens and above is
going to be the tablet Dimensions so
here we'll just put a image that is
coming from Chakra but not this I'm not
sure why it gives us this maybe we
should just reload this uh uh reload
this vs code I'll say control shift p
and then developer uh reload window so
maybe that would fix it for us okay so
inside the image now we're going to say
Source the image is going to be this one
oath. PNG inside the public folder and
in order to get into the public folder
we just say slash now we are inside the
public and we'll say oath. PNG and this
is going to have height of let's say 650
pixels and then alt could be P image
okay we could save this and now we're
going to have something on the right as
well so let's say okay right hand side
and then here on the right hand side we
can use something called vertical stack
that is coming from Chakra so let's say
vertical stack and just import it from
Chakra UI react and let's just put this
into here again so put a
comma Okay so so what is vertical stack
it is just like a flex but instead of
putting items next to each other it just
puts them uh under like on top of each
other so here let's take a look now this
is inside the vertical stack we can see
the logo above and then this input above
I mean I mean like in the vertical
Direction so we're using vertical stack
now we're going to have this o form at
the top and then this text as well as
this um logos at the bottom so let's go
here inside the vertical stack we can
use this spacing which is going to give
us for spacing and then align um maybe
it should be stretch and we're going to
see why so here we're going to have our
oath form component that we need to just
create now so it should be self closing
tag and let's go inside the source
components we're going to have Oath form
but that should be a folder so we could
just say oath form slash oath form. jsx
so it's going to put put it under this o
form uh folder and then we'll just say
RFC and save this delete this react and
import this and after this o form we're
going to have a box that says um get the
app and then we could just say say text
align should be Center and below this
we're going to have one Flex with two
images so it is just going to put them
side by side that's why we're using Flex
we'll say gap of five and then justify
content to be Center so to Center them
in horizontal uh I mean horizontally and
then here we'll just put two images so
let's say one image it is going to have
this Source called slash we're in the
public folder and then play
store.png and then we could just say
height is going to be 10 as well as the
alt is going to be Play Store logo and
just duplicate this the second image is
going to be the Microsoft so we could
just say
microsoft. PNG height is going to be 10
and the alt could be Microsoft logo and
we're just going to save this now and
let's see what are we what are we going
to get here okay so we have our image as
well as our oath form but they are not
in the uh they're not next next to each
other so the reason might be this Flex
is not working properly I mean not this
flex but another one that should be
inside the container so here we need to
have a flex that that the first child is
going to be this box the left hand side
and then another child which is going to
be this right hand side so if we just
cut this and paste it here and we'll
just say justify content Center and then
align items also should be Center and
just to give some Gap we could say Gap
is going to be 10 so let's just save and
let's take a look okay so the problem
was this container had two children but
it wasn't grabed within a flx so now we
just give a flex and it's going to put
the children side by side first we have
this left hand side and then we have
this right hand side and we just say
align items to be Center so that they
are vertically aligned and now
everything is working fine but the only
thing that we need to add is going to be
this oath form so I'll just save this
file and now inside the oath form we're
going to change this content so let's
get started with this I will delete this
at diff and I'll just create a box that
is a simple diff that is coming from
Chakra so here this box is just going to
have this border one pixel solid gray
and then here we'll just have border
radius of four and then padding it just
going to be five and then we're just
going to have vertical stack again and
you're going to see y so let's say
vertical
stack and we're going to import this
we're we're using vertical stack it's
because we want to put this logo um logo
input and this button on top of each
other so everything here you see is just
on top of each other that's why we're
going to be using it so inside this
vertical stack we'll just say spacing
should be four and then we're going to
have one image which is going to be our
logo Instagram logo so image let's
import this from Chakra it's going to
have a source to public folder
logo.png and height I use 24 but you can
change it and then cursor could be
pointer as well as alt say
Instagram okay it should just say
Instagram and then below this image
we're going to have an input for email
so let's say input which is coming from
Chakra and also if there is anything
that you don't understand simply just go
to chakra and just search for it so here
we have input and you're going to see
like different usages so it has this
input component it has this placeholder
and you can even just change it and it
is interactive so you can use uh the
font size so which you can see here or
the size in general you have this HTML
size with in the variant is going to be
outline filled flashed unstyled and
maybe for left left and right uh okay it
is addin I was going to say icons and
then it has this element inside an input
so just any kind of thing that you can
imagine so yeah that would be my
recommendation but now let's go to here
and thens go so we're going to import
this input from Chakra and it's going to
have a couple of props so the
placeholder let's say it's just going to
be email and then it is going to have
the on change in value but we're going
to add add it uh later in this once we
completed the UI okay so we could just
say font size should be maybe 14
pixels and that shouldn't be inside a
string okay and let's see and below this
input we're going to have another one so
I'll just copy and paste it so it is
going to be for the
password and the type of this guy is
going to be password so let's say
password and maybe for this we could
also say the type should be email and
phone size is going to be b14 yes that's
it and also in the sign up page so let's
take a look here in the sign up form
we're going to have another one so that
says confirm password but if we're in
the login we're not going to see that
for this we can use something called
state in react so const we could just
say um what should we say let's say is
login so set is login and initially it's
just going to be true and here let's
take a look I'm just taking look looking
at my notes So Below this password we'll
say if we are in the if we are not in
the login page okay if if it is the sign
up then we're just going to render this
portion else will just not return
anything which can which we can just put
null and then here we're going to have
another input I'll just copy this paste
it that says placeholder confirm
password and type is going to be
password font size of 14 and that's just
it okay so we can save this and we're
going to be changing this when we click
to that sign up button and below this
we're going to have another button let's
say button not but but button so it is
going to say if you're in the login page
it's going to be a login but if we're in
the sign up page it's just going to say
sign up and maybe that should be like
this and this button is going to have
the width of full and the color scheme
is just going to be blue
Also let's say size of small on size of
14 pixels as well as on click function
but we're going to add that later and
actually let's just add it so let's say
on click okay let's just add this later
and then below this button what are we
going to see let's just first take a
look now here we see email password and
this login button and then below this we
would like to have this or uh field okay
and for this we're going to use a flex
so that all of them are going to be next
to each other we're going to give some
spacing here and we'll just say align
items to be Center so that they are
vertically aligned so let's go here
below this button we're just going to
use a flex import from the chakra that
is just going to have align items to be
Center and then let's say justify
content to be Center as well margin y of
four gap of maybe we could say one and
then width is is just going to be full
so that it is just going to take the
full width of the parent component so
we're going to have a box uh we already
imported it so it is not going to have
any content so that could be a self
closing box and we're using box for this
thing that you can see here and this box
is just going to have flights of two and
it's going to say height of maybe one
pixels also background um let's say gray
400 maybe and below the this we're going
to have our text that says uh or okay
we'll say text imported from Chakra that
is going to say or um that should be
uppercase and then margin X of one as
well as color is just going to be white
and below this we're going to have
another this box I'll just copy and
paste it so this is going to be our or
text or text or maybe we could just say
it like
this
okay this is what we see in the
UI and we have an error okay it's just a
warning so let's see now in our original
app we see this or text as well and
below this we are going to add this
login with Google button okay we're
going to have again a flex on the left
image on the right the text itself so
let's go here and then we're going to go
into the vs code so build below this
Flex we'll just create another Flex
let's say um on the left we're going to
have our image so that should be a self
closing tag it's going to have the
source to be public folder
google.png and then with we could say
it's going to be five and ALT let's say
Google logo and on the right hand side
we'll just have a text that says log in
with Google and then this is just going
to have margin X of two let's say and
the color should be blue 500 and this
Flex is going to have some let's say
align
items of Center and then justify content
of Center as well and maybe you could
just say cursor is going to be pointer
so that it looks like a button when you
hover over this so now let's go here and
we see this login uh with Google and
what happens if you don't use align
items in this here so in this orex I'll
just delete this for a second and do you
see like it is not vertically aligned so
these um these lines should be come to
here so that they are vertical aligned
or this ortex should go to up so that's
why we're using it and then we just say
margin Y and just give a gap between
this text this box and this box but
anyways after this login with Google
text so after this box I believe we're
going to have another box that is just
going to say um do you have an account
or don't you have an account in that
case just sign up or log in so we're
just going to say box and this box again
is going to have border one pixel solid
and gray and then border so let's say
border radius of four
as well as the pading of five and let me
just scroll a bit so we're going to have
one Flex so that um they are next to
each other so we say flex and then align
items should be Center as always and
then justify content should be Center as
well and now we're going to have one box
on the left and then another box on the
right so this box the first one let me
just save so that we get this formatting
and then then we're going to go here and
we'll say is login now if we login we
could just show uh
don't have an account and if you already
have an account that that could just say
already have an account and then this
box is going to have some Styles let's
say margin X of two and then font size
is just going to be
14 and below this box okay in this one
in this one I mean we're going to go
inside it is just going to be if we are
in the login we are going to return a
text that says sign up otherwise it just
going to be a login so when we clict to
this we would like to call a on click
function I mean yeah Anonymous function
so on click to this we're going to call
this Anonymous function that just says
set is login whatever the value just um
negate it so false is login if it was
true it's going going to be false if it
was false now it's going to be true and
after this on click we're just going to
say color should be blue 500 and cursor
is just going to be let's say pointer
okay now we're going to save this and
hopefully it should work so let's just
zoom out a bit okay now we're in the
login page that's why it says don't have
an account then just sign up so let's
see here it says now we're in the log
page it says don't have an account
you're in the login page it says sign up
okay I'm going to save this and if I
click to this the login State now will
be false so that we are going to see
this confirm password and this button
says sign up and if we're in the login
page it says login and now if we just
shrink our screen we should be we
shouldn't be seeing this image on the
left and it is because we added this
display property up here so on the base
which means in the smaller screens we're
not going to see that but on the tablets
and above we're going to see this image
which is in the left hand side so
believe it or not this is the entire
code for our oath page uh design now we
can work with the homepage and even
before we get into the homepage let's
add this functionality where when we
just put our email and password when we
click to this login it should take us to
the homepage so let's add that
functionality so we're going to open up
our application and then vs code so it
is going to be this button where so
let's see it is going to be this one so
when we click to this it is going to
call handle o function let's create it
it's going to be up here con handle o
and arrow function and for now it's not
going to do anything and let's have our
states so let's say con inputs and set
inputs we're going to have
um like this and we're going to have the
email password as well as the confirm
password now we need to bind this inputs
with these uh input Fields so we're just
going to say for the email the value is
just going to be inputs. email and for
the onchange so let's say onchange it is
going to take the event or maybe um okay
let's just take the event we'll say set
inputs and we're just going to destroy
structure all of the inputs and we're
only going to change the one which is
the email at this point and we can
change uh this password as well we'll
say value as well as the on change when
we type into this password field we're
only going to update the password State
and also for the confirm password we'll
just say value it's going to be confirm
password and on change only update this
field and we could save this and we we
handle and when we call this function
let's say console. log the inputs so
let's see now I'll just put my email and
my password open up the console when I
click to this um okay let's just clear
this we got the email as well as the
password the confirm password is empty
because we didn't type anything in so
let's just put something here as well if
we just click that uh we get we got all
these states and what we want to do is
just uh take this user to the O I mean
the homepage for this we're going to use
react router Dom so we'll say const
navigate there is something called
navigate which handles the navigation it
is coming from this use navigate hook
and here we could now delete here and
we'll say if the
inputs that email is empty or if the
inputs
that password is empty or the confirm
password is empty so let's just get this
and then if this is the case we'll just
alert and we'll say please feel all the
fields and then return out of this
function and below this if everything is
correct I mean every input is filled
then we'll just say navigate this user
to the homepage which is just slash and
now let's test it out and before that
this should be if not okay if the input
email is empty or the password is empty
and we could actually just delete this
for now because this is only the design
part I don't really want to write any if
else checks again and this should be
okay so let's test it out I'll say uh
something here something for my password
if I don't put anything so let's just
delete it is going to say please all the
fields if I don't put anything here it's
going to say again feel all the fields
but if I just put something is just
going to take me to the homepage now we
can get started with the homepage but
before that we need to just realize that
every single page has the sidebar so we
have in the homepage we have uh in the
user page we have the sidebar but in the
oath page we don't have it right so
we're going to design our remaining
Pages depending on this so we can create
a layout component for this and instead
of adding the sidebar to each page we
can just only created once and use it
inside the page layout so it sounds
complicated so let me just show that so
inside the source you're just going to
have layout um so let's say layouts and
then it's going to have a page layout
let's
say and inside this we're going to have
a file called page layout. jsx so we're
going to get the boiler plate and now
here we're going to uh render the
sidebar as well as the content but we're
not going to show the sidebar on the out
page okay so here I'll just say one flex
and import it from Chakra and this Flex
is going to have something on the left
which is going to be the
sidebar on the left and the content on
the right let's
say the
page content on the right so for the
sidebar we're we going to create a
component and here for the page content
we're just going to get the children as
props so let's say children if I can
type we're just going to copy it and put
it inside a box so let's import the box
from Chakra and wrap this with curly
braces and then this box is going to
have couple of uh props but before that
um let's create our sidebar it is going
to be inside a box again we are just
have the sidebar component let's say and
now let's get into the
components um that should be let's say
sidebar and then sidebar.
jsx okay now we can import this sidebar
and then this box is going to have
couple of uh actually only one the width
is just going to be uh on the smaller
screens it's just going to be 70 pixels
and in the medium screens and above so
let's say MD it's going to be 240 pixels
but we are only going to show this
sidebar uh other than the off page so we
can check it by so I just cut this now
we will just say const give me the path
name from this hook that is going to
give you the path name so we'll say if
the path name is equal to the O actually
if it is not equal to the O page then
we're going to render the sidebar but
else we're not going to so we say null
so if we are not in the off page we're
going to show the sidebar and so now
this box is going to take some props
let's say this Flex is just going to be
one which means that it is going to take
the remaining part and withd we could
say uh on the base and above is just
going to be cul function with 100% minus
70 pixels and for the medium we'll just
say um exactly the same function so I'll
just copy and paste it but the pixels is
is going to be 240 pixels and now what
we can do is to just go into the app jsx
and wrap our entire application with
this page layout and um okay so let's
say page layout now all of our pages is
going to be within this page layout
component and whatever we pass is going
to be this children so if we are in the
homepage this children is going to be
the homepage content so we're going to
put it uh put the homepage content on
the on the right and the Side Bar on the
left and if we're in the oath page we're
just uh ignore this part as if there is
only the O page content and here we have
some uh warnings let's get rid of this
we're going to go inside the ASN uh ASN
RC so it is a prop types uh error so
before I mean after this uh first rule
object okay inside that we're just going
to paste it this uh this line it says
react prop types off and we added this
to uh avoid prop types error okay we're
going to save this now we're not going
to get any warnings and now if we go to
the let's say we are in in the O page we
don't okay that's this is not our
application so let's save um so let's
save it
app.jsx so here now in the homepage we
can see the sidebar on the left and the
homepage on the right if we go to the
oath page we're not going to see the
sidebar it's because we're checking for
the path name so it it should be here if
the path name is oath we'll just return
null and this path name is going to be
what whatever you put after this uh port
number if you're in the homepage the
path name is just going to be this slash
so now we are going to go into the
homepage let's say and we're going to
just add this sidebar so let's go to the
sidebar.
jsx we can close this files that we
don't use main jsx maybe app jsx um o
form off page and then here we are just
going to have a box that is coming from
Chakra and then inside this is going to
have a couple of different props so
let's say the height is going to be 100
VH so it should be inside a string and
then it is going to have this border
right let's say one pixel solid and
Border color it's going to have white
Alpha 300 and then padding y of
eight position is going to be sticky
let's
say and then the top is going to be zero
let's say and the left is going to be
zero so it's just going to put it at the
very top and it's going to be sticky
there and on the let's say padding X for
the base it could be two and for the
medium screens and above it's just going
to be four and this box is going to have
one Flex which is going to be holding
that um so to say the icons so the first
icon that we're going to have is going
to be inside the link and it is going to
be that that uh Instagram logo so if we
just take a look look at it here so it's
going to be this logo so we're going to
give this uh icon and on the mobile
screen that we can see it changes to
this mobile icon and we're going to be
adding that as well so first let's add
this uh desk desktop icon so we're going
to go into the link and this Flex is
going to have couple of different props
so let's say direction to be column so
everything is going to be uh vertically
uh aligned or gap of 10 width is just
going to be say full and then height is
also going to be the full and then this
link is going to take us to the homepage
but this links is coming from uh chakra
right actually it's coming from RE R Dam
so let's say let's delete this and
import it from Chakra but we're going to
say import uh link as
router link from react router D so we
just rename it uh to the router link and
we're going to use this link as as if
this is a router link that is coming
from react I mean react router D we're
doing this is because uh this link we
can both add styles to it just like a
normal chakra um normal chakra component
as well as this two functionality that
is coming from react router down so ping
left is just going to be two and we will
say display this uh on base it should be
none and for the medium and above it's
just going to be block so inside here we
are going to say show us the
Instagram logo which is something that I
will provide to you in the GitHub preo
so this is also going to have the
cursor so let's say cursor is going to
be just pointer and now for this icons
we're going to create a assets folder
so's see assets and we'll say
constants jsx and let me just grab all
of them so I just copied all of them and
now I'm going to paste it so here let
let me just shrink all of
them so shrink this one this
this so we have couple of icons and all
of them are just a basic SVG that we can
see here I just copied and pasted these
guys from the Instagram website so now
we're going to import this Instagram
logo that is coming from constants so
now I will just copy this link and then
paste it again so this is going to be
for the desktop and this is going to be
for the mobile mobile so it is going to
have the almost the same props so to
this uh homepage as router link padding
let's say just padding is going to be
two from uh all directions and then
display on the the base it is going to
be block but on the medium screens and
above it's just going to be none so in
the small screens we're going to show
this logo and in the larger screens
we're going to show this one now this
will also get a border radius so let's
say border radius is going to be six and
then um it's going to have a hover state
so let's say so this is how we add hover
state in Chakra so underscore hover and
it's going to take another object and
the properties that you want to change
so you want to change the background to
be white Alpha 200 and the lastly this
is going to have a width let's say width
on the base it is just going to be um 10
I mean 10 and medium screens and above
it is not going to have anything because
it is uh it's displaying on anyways
right so let's delete this and let's
just give it a
10 okay so we could save and let's take
a look now um inside our application we
see this icon and when we go to like the
medium screens it's just going to be
this um logo and now below this logo
we're going to add this uh so to say
search bar items so we have logo and
text on the right when we shrink this
we're going to when we hover over this
we see this tool tip on the right that
says home and it says search
notifications create and uh the profile
now in order to get this tool tip it is
just a component from Chakra let's say
tool tip and as we can see here when you
like hover over this you're going to see
uh this hover over me I mean hover me
tool tip and it has a lot of um so to
say properties and we're going to be
using some of them okay so we're going
to use tool tips for this as well as
this sidebar items or the icons that we
already have in the constants jsx file
so here inside the sidebar I'll just
paste something here um it's going to be
our um so array an array of icons so
some of them will have link and some of
them will not have so now let's import
all of these AI fail home uh that should
be coming from Chakra but the I mean
this should be coming from react icons
but these guys are going to be coming
from our assets so let's import all
these and the Avatar is going to be
something that I will go over as well so
let's say import um AI fill from react
icons Ai and it is going to be this one
so let's say okay it is this one
actually AI fail home when you search
for the home icon is going to be the
first one that you get and now this
Avatar is something that chakra gives
you so let's say
Avatar and it is basically this circle
profile picture that we get this uh down
below so so for this you just put the
source and you can put size to just give
different sizes so 2x small medium small
maybe X small and so on and so forth so
below this logo now we're going to add
our side sidebar items so after this
link I believe we're going to have
another flex and it's going to have this
direction to be column as well so let's
say Direction going to be column gap of
five maybe cursor pointer it should be
and then we're just going to get this
sidebar items we're going to map it get
each item so as well as the index let's
say and we're going to just return some
jsx here so it's going to be tool tip so
this is how we use tool tip you first
wrap the content into this tool tip and
it's going to have a couple of different
props so we want to has this Arrow when
we hover over this the label is just
going to be item. text so either it
should be search notifications create
profile or let's say home so this going
to be the label and then the placement
so let's say placement is just going to
be right okay so when you hover over
that it's going to be on the right hand
side so we need to give a key to get rid
of any uh react errors so we'll just say
the index and so what should we have so
margin left is going to be one and there
is something called open delay when you
hover over this it just open uh delays
so you could put zero 1,000 anything
else so we're going to put uh 500
milliseconds so healthc so we'll say
also display on base only show it when
we are in the smaller screens and medium
and above we don't want to see that
because we already have the text uh next
to it so that was it inside it is going
to have a link okay so this is the tool
tip that we just WRA it uh with the
element that we would like to put inside
so let's say it's going to have a link
it's going to have a lot of props so
let's go one by one so this going to be
display flex and then two so it is going
to take us to a link if there is any so
say two and we're going to put something
here but for now let just ignore this
we'll say as rer link that we did
previously and then align items not the
content but align items to be Center so
that they are vertically centered and
we'll say gap of four and on the hover
State let's say underscore hover another
object background should be white Alpha
let's say 400 and then below this we're
going to have border
radius of
six and then after this border radius
it's going to have the petting of two
and let's say width should be 10 as well
as the justify content should be on the
base Center and on the okay that should
be string let's say and on the medium
and above it's just going to be Flex
start and I will just cut this for now
and then I'll will add it so that you so
that you can see what's going on here so
we're going to put the icon here which
is going to be item. icon and after this
icon next to each other we're just going
to put the item text which you can put
it into a box because we're going to add
this display props so it is going to be
on the base we're just not going to show
it but on the so to say medium screens
and above we'll just say block and into
this box we're just going to say item.
text and I think I think we can now save
this do we have any errors let's see um
okay so this two is going to take us to
the link so if item has a link it is
going to just take us to there but if
this is not the case it is just going to
be in the mull State um so yeah when you
click to this search button it doesn't
have any links so it is not going to
take you to any page but if you click to
this home icon it is going to take you
to the home or if you click to this one
is going to take you to this uh user
page so we could save and let's take a
look now and here we get okay in this
one it should be so let's
say um map we have a typo here it should
be map and then okay now it works fine
but we cannot see the icon um let's
refresh
again um let's see what's going on here
so we constants it should be right um
assets constants okay let's just rename
this and we imported that somewhere else
I believe um no it wasn't okay it's
going to be the constants but it is not
going to work again so let's see um um
so why is not working let's just put
full for the width maybe that should fix
okay so we're just going to say then on
the base and above it should be 10 but
for the medium and above it's just going
to take the full width of the parent so
here we can see the icons but once we
hit the medium break point which is um
so you can see it from here
768 pixels it's going to be the medium
and the sidebar shinks as well as we see
all of these icons with the tool tip
when we H over this and here do you see
like it is not centered when you hover
over this it is because if you just add
this uh to here justify content on the
base it's going to be Center but on the
medium and above it's just going to be
flag start so I'm going to save this and
that should be working fine now it is
Center and the last thing that we need
to add into this sidebar is just going
to be that uh the log out button at the
very bottom that we can see here so it
is almost going to be identical to these
guys so I'll just go and copy this
entire thing for now and and it is going
to be after this Flex okay um I'm going
to paste it so we don't have any key we
can delete that for the label uh we
could just say log out let say log out
and the placement is going to be right
it's going to have this margin left um
so open delay and display on the base is
going to be block on the medium screens
and above it's just going to be none and
for the tool link it is just going to
take us to the let's say oath page each
and for the icon we are just going to
show this uh let me just copy and paste
it this is another icon that is coming
from uh react icons so we could import
this from let's go up here react icons
bi log out so we're going to go here and
it doesn't have really any texts so we
could just say log
out log
out okay so so I think this is going to
work fine let's save and um okay so it's
here but we just want to have it at the
very bottom so if we just say margin Top
Auto it is going to take it to the very
bottom it's just going to push it so
where should we add it um so it is this
link or even yeah let's just add it to
here let's say margin top is going to be
uh Auto and there we go we just see that
it the very bottom if you just shrink
that and hover over this it is going to
show us this tool tip when we click to
that it's going to take us to the O page
and everything now is working fine also
this o page is responsive that we can
see I forgot to show you guys so this
wraps the sidebar component so let's
just quickly reiterate what we did um
here we created a page layout and the
reason is let me just copy and paste the
thing that I said previously so instead
of creating
so okay I'll just read it so instead of
adding the sidebar component to every
page we only added once to this page
layout component and wrap the children
with it so this way every page that is
in our app jsx that we wrapped with the
page layout is going to see that sidebar
but except the oath page because we're
checking if the path name is equal to
the oath page then we're not going to
show this we're just going to return
null but if it is not the case then
we're going to show the sidebar and on
the smaller screens it is only 70 pixels
wide and in the uh like the large
screens it's going to be a little bit
wider and the sidebar inside the sidebar
we used a couple of items which was the
home search notifications create as well
as the profile and some of them had link
and some of them didn't so the ones that
had link when we click to them it's
going to take us to the link page so to
the homepage or to the user page and we
use we see something called Avatar with
chakra where we just put the source as a
profile picture and with a name field
that is going to be kind of fall back
while this uh image loads okay I just
put my name here and we have this size
which is small and then we Loop through
this uh sidebar items down below here
for each of them we showed something
called tool tip with some uh props so
such as is this uh tool tip is going to
has the arrow it's going to have some
placement on the right open delay and
we're only going to show it in the
smaller screens and yeah so basically
this is what we did so basically I can
just save this file so that you guys
have this comment here and then we're
going to go into the app jsx inside to
the homepage and we're just going to add
our homepage content
which is let's just go to the demo app
to the homepage so on the left we have
the sidebar but on the content we're
going to have our feed posts and on the
right we're going to have our suggested
user component so let's start with the
feed posts and then we're going to get
into this uh suggested users component
and if we think about the HTML structure
for this we have something on the left
and something on the right for this
we're going to use flex and to put
everything in the the center of the
screen we're going to use container so
I'll just go to inside the homepage I
will change this with container okay and
that also should be container and we can
say that this container is just going to
have the max width of um that should be
container. large you can change this if
you want maybe you could make like x
large 2 x large 3 x large uh it doesn't
really matter but the LG should be nice
and then we're going to have a flex as
res said so let's import this something
on the right and something on the left
so let's say this box is going to be for
the suggested users and actually it's
going to be feed posts right so feed
posts and the next one is going to be
the suggested
users because the suggested users going
to be on the right hand side and Feit PO
on the left so this Flex is just going
to have gap of 20 so that these guys
have something in the middle like they
they are separated and this box is going
to have the flex of two adding y of 10
and then this box is going to have the
flex of three and margin right of 10
actually 20 and then we're not going to
show the suggested users below the large
uh break point so we're just going to
say display only in the base and above
so it's I mean don't display so base and
above it's going to be none but on the
larger sus and above we'll just say
block and then the max width is just
going to be 300 pixels and lastly let's
just say the border is going to be one
pixel solid red this is temporary so
that we can see that so this should be
suggested users I'll just save this and
let's give this a border as well I'll
copy this paste this and I'll just say
blue now let's go inside the homepage
something on the left something on the
right which is suggested users they have
a gap of 20 and now that should be
working fine we're going to first build
the feed posts and now if you just
shrink our screen once we hit the large
break point we're not going to see the
suggested user component right do you
see and this is the exact same thing in
our uh demo application when we hit that
break point it just gone just like this
so let's go inside the um so here we'll
just create this comp component let's
say feed posts and we're going to go
inside the components let's say feed
posts and it's going to have the feed
posts. jsx and let's say rafc to get the
boiler plate and then this is going to
return a container as well so you're
going to see why so basically it is just
used to give some spacing so let's say
container this should be and we could
delete the react import and and we could
say that maximum width for this is going
to be just container. small and padding
Y is just going to be 10 as well as
pading X of two and here we'll just
basically return a feed post a couple of
times so which is going to be a
component that we're going to create so
let's say feed post four times and let's
create that component and I'll just put
it into the feed post folder because all
of them are related so feed post jsx and
I will get this so save and let me just
import pet post which is coming from
here and let's save this and also we're
going to get the feed posts here okay so
let's take a look we have feed posts
they are on top of each other and we are
going to change all of them with one of
these posts okay so we could close this
and then let's get into the feed post
and how are we going to structure this
first it's going to have this feed post
header where we hold this button as well
as profile picture username and the
create that date and then we're going to
have the feed I mean the post body which
is going to be this image as well as the
post uh footer which is going to have
this uh icons the username likes and
number of comments as well as this input
and post button okay so let's go into
here I'll will create all of them so
let's say post Putter jsx and
post header.
jsx so see delete
this okay inside the let's close them
for now inside the feed post first we're
going to just handle here so I'll just
give a little bit space for me delete
this one and then let's get into the
work so first of all we'll just have the
post header okay and we should be
importing that uh it doesn't give us so
post
header okay we're going to just import
it manually and then below this we're
going to have the post body which we can
just really put it inside the box which
is going to be that image so let's say
we're going to get a image component and
it doesn't gives us for some reason
let's say uh image from Chakra UI and
then this image is going to have a
source let's say uh Source image so
let's see public we could just give this
image one okay image 1.png and then alt
we could just say user profile pick and
then below this box we're just going to
have the post
footer so post footer I'm not sure why
it doesn't gives us so post footer um
okay let's say import post footer from
here and then post header from here so
if you just say save this now we should
be seeing that and
see okay we got the post image but now
we need to add the post header so let's
delete this borders as well we don't
really need them it was for showing
purposes so I'll just delete this and
now we're going to go into the post
header it's going to be here so as we
said something on the left right so
again let's take a look so this going to
be the left hand side and this going to
be the right hand side so we're going to
have a flex with justify uh space
between so let's get into here and
delete this one so let's start with the
parent Flex which we said that is going
to have the justify content of space
between and then it's also going to have
the Align items Center so that it is uh
centered vertically and then with let's
say width of full and inside this Flex
we're going to have one Flex which is
going to be for the left side and then
we're going to have one box for the
right side for that button that follow
unfollow button and inside this Flex
let's say align items to be Center and
then gap of two so Gap is just going to
be two and this Flex is going to have an
avatar on the left so let's say Avatar
just import
it and then Source could be again the
same picture so image 1
PNG let's say alt um so it should be
user profile pick and then I think that
should be it as well as the size of
small and next to Avatar we're going to
have a vertical stack we could say or we
could basically use a flex because it's
not going to be vertically stacked so
inside this uh what should we say um so
the username is going to be on the left
and then the date is going to be on the
left that we can see here right the
username and then this uh create that
date so inside the flex we could have
the font size as 12 pixels font weight
should be bolt and let's say gap of um
two okay we'll just say gap of two and
we're going to have the username let's
just put the as a programmer and then
below this we're going to have a box
which is coming from Chakra as always
and the color let's say it's going to be
gray
500 and then we'll just have this thing
that I'll just copy and paste okay it's
just going to be one week now if we just
save it like this um it's going to have
one error I believe um okay so maybe we
could just just give some uh spacing at
the bottom so it is going to be this
container we'll just say margin bottom
or margin y of let's say two and that
should be working nice and on the left I
mean on the right we're going to put
that button okay so it is going to be
this box where we'll just say unfollow
and it is going to have a couple of uh
different props so first let's actually
put this into a text so that it's just
going to be semantic so import the text
from Chakra and paste the unfollow of
text into it into it and then this box
is just going to have uh font size of
let's say or maybe we could give it to
the text so this is just going to have
the cursor to be pointer and now this
text is going to have the font size so
let's say font size of 12 and then
color blue 500 and then font
weight
alt and then hover is just going to be
color white so I'll just say color color
should be now
white and we want to have some
transition so I'll just say transition
um so we could say 2 seconds is in and
out so I will just save this now and
let's take a look so we have the button
when we hover over this we got this
transition so as we can see and
everything is working nice we have the
header so what we did was one Flex on I
mean one box on the left and another one
on the right right and justify content
space between and then here we basically
did the same thing we have the avatar on
the left and this guy on the right so
we're going to get into the post footer
now so inside the post uh we could
actually close this and let's see inside
the feed post okay we're going to have
the post footer and we're going to just
put the content now into this component
so let's see how the footer is going to
look like so it has this logos and then
number of likes count and then the
username as well as the description and
then this com the count of comons as
well as this uh input with the button on
the right so let's go step by step just
create all of them from top to bottom so
let's open up here and then we're going
to get into the post footer so I just
want to have a empty fragment here so
that we can return multiple children so
let's say Flex
and this is going to be coming from
Chakra as always it's going to have the
classic align items Center and then
we're going to have the gap of four as
well as the width full let's say width
full we could just say padding top is
going to be zero margin bottom of two
and then margin top of
Auto okay that should be working nice
we're going to go into here first we're
going to have a box that shows the like
or unlike uh logo so for this we can
create a state so let's say const
because we're going to be changing this
dynamically so liked set liked initially
it's going to be false and then also we
could have the number of likes we're
going to use it in a second so let's say
set likes count okay and initially let's
say we're going to have uh maybe 1,000
likes um we can just give it a little
bit space
and then inside this box we just going
to say um if it is not liked okay in
this case we're going to return a logo
and if it is liked we're going to return
another logo and this guy is going to be
the
notification notifications logo I
believe yes so notifications logo which
is coming from our assets and then here
we're just going to have the unlike logo
and if we just now import this when we C
click to this box we would like to
change the state so let's say on click
we're just going to say that um maybe we
should say
handle um so let's say handle
like this is going to be an eror
function so if it is already a liked
we're going to let's say if it is liked
which means that now we're unliking this
so we'll just say set liked to be false
and we're going to just decrement the
number of likes and in the else case
we're just going to do the uh opposite
thing so satellite going to be true and
just increment it by one and now let's
see what are we going to get when I
click to this now it is liked and when I
click to that again now it's unliked and
let's have a cursor of pointer in the
into this box so I'll just give some
props let's say cursor should be point
pointer as well as the font size of 18
um that should be it for this one so it
should be 18 um okay what is the error
okay if you just save it's going to
reformat this and then we're going to
have another box that is going to hold
the comment logo so I will import this
guy from our assets as well and this box
is just going to have the cursor to be
pointer as well as the font size of a 18
and below this I say 18 and then write
17 okay and then below this what are we
going to have after this flag we'll just
have the number of likes so import the
text from Chakra so let's say
likes which is going to be the count
okay it's coming from the states and the
string of likes and this Tex is going to
have the font weight so let me just give
a little bit of space for us font weight
of uh what it should be so 600 as well
as the font size small we could just say
and then below this we're going to have
a couple of text as well so maybe at
this point I could just copy and paste
it because it is not anything different
than this guy so we'll just say for the
username I'll just put my name so as a
programmer underscore so let's see so we
just have one text okay okay we have one
text font size of small that gives the
username and then L bit space and then
another text maybe we could just have it
that one space just like this so
username and then the description of the
post or the caption and then the number
of uh comments so color of gray font
size small and this is uh okay so here
we have a text but it is not a paragraph
instead it is a span because we're using
as span but if you use a text normally
without this as text T it is just going
to be a paragraph now let's save and
let's take a look here okay maybe we
could just give a little bit uh space
for this so it is going to be this uh
icons
container which one is this so margin
top so it's Auto let's say U
maybe
two okay let's say
four now it looks better and then below
this
uh number of Commons we're going to have
an input which is going to be inside the
flags so that we can use align items and
GAP so here I'll go inside the post
footer below the texts I'll just create
another flex and this Flex is just going
to have a couple of props so say align
items to be Center and then gap of two
um justify content let's say space
between and then width of full let's say
and now if you can see here we have
inside an input we have a button for
this we can use something called input
group so let's say input uh maybe only
input we going to see it here uh left
and right elements so as you can see
there is something called input group
and we're going to be using something on
the right so let's search for it if
there is something called right element
yes there is so this is what we're doing
we're creating an input group and inside
we're just putting the left element or
the right element as well as the input
so in our case we're going to be using
the input right element so I'll just go
to here inside the flex I will say
input it should be U input group so I'll
just import this and it's going to have
one input as well as input right element
so I'll just say um so input I'll just
import this input and then variant of
flashed
so we say placeholder that is going to
just say add a comment with three dots
and then let's say font
size of 14 pixels and below this input
we're just going to have an input right
element which I will copy and paste it
and then that should be a not
self-closing tag but rather just like
this okay input right element is going
to take something inside which is going
to be a button so let's say this going
to be the button that says let's import
this from Chakra and import this one the
button is just going to say post and
button is going to have couple of props
and or the Styles to's say so font size
is going to be 14 and then it's going to
have the color of blue 100 I mean blue
500 so let's see blue 500 and then font
weight of 600 so I'll just scroll a bit
font weight we 600 and then below this
we'll just say cursor pointer and on the
hover State we're going to change the
color so let's say hover um we'll just
say color should be white
okay and then below the color we'll just
say background should be transparent so
whatever the uh background of the parent
component and I believe this going to be
it so let's save and let's take a look
now that we have okay we cannot see the
placeholder maybe we should change the
color for this um let's take a look
Place content no it's just going to be a
placeholder okay it's working nice now
we're just going to give a little bit of
margin bottom so that we have some space
so maybe that should be margin
y h okay it's it is going to be for this
so let say margin bottom or margin top
it was and we could just say that maybe
inside the a feat post um let's say
margin y of
2 now that we have some spacing and
below the post footer we're going to
have it so we could just say box margin
y of let's say four and now that should
be working nice we have this um margin
below each post and since we are uh
rendering this four times that's why we
are just seeing the exact same post but
we're going to change it so let's say if
the margin btom was 10 how it's going to
look like okay now it's better let's say
margin bottom of 10 so let's quickly
rrate what we did we create the post uh
header in the post body itself which is
this image and then we have created this
post footer with the input group element
where we have something inside the input
and we use the right element and now we
can like this it's going to update the
number of Lights as well as changing the
icon and if we unlike that it's going to
just decrement it and change the like
icon and there is one thing that we're
missing is that this image should have
some border radius that we can see from
our demo so it just has this border
radius and for this we can go inside the
feed post where we have this image this
box is just going to have let's say
border radius of four but if you just do
this I think it's not going to work it's
because now it's overflow the content
and for this we'll just say overflow
should be hidden so overflow is going to
be hidden so that it doesn't so the
image doesn't overflow this box so now
that should be working fine as we can
see here we have this uh radius corner
so now every post has the same image
same username um so the same Avatar and
for this we could just change this by uh
with props so for this we're going to go
inside the feed post and we're just
going to put the user name okay for each
of them we're just going to do this so
let me just give this cool spacing or
formatting so for the username let's say
for this this is just just going to be
as a programmer and then we're going to
give the uh so let me just take a look
my notes so we're going to give the
image username as well as the Avatar so
I'm going to copy this and paste it and
now I will just copy and paste all of
them so so we're only adding this image
field username as well as the Avatar so
I will cut all of these and paste it so
it is just the exact same thing we have
the image username and then the Avatar
so the image is going to be this content
okay and the Avatar is going to be this
one as well as the username so let's go
inside the feed post and change it so
we're going to take these props which is
the image username and then the Avatar
so we're using the uh Avatar as well as
the username inside the post header so
I'm going to just take this and put it
inside here so let's say username and
it's going to take the
Avatar oops so it should be like this
Avatar and inside the post footer we are
only using the username so I'm going to
copy this and then paste it here so for
the source we are already getting this
for the image we'll just say Source this
is going to be the image and that should
be working nice for the alt we could
just put the username uh let's say uh
username and for the Post header we're
going to take the username and the
Avatar so username avatar for the
username we're just going to put the
prop into
here and then we're going to get the
Avatar um it should be inside this
source and I think that's it for this
component we could save it so we have
some errors okay that should be inside
the Cur Braes right okay we have the
username and then the this box and so
we're going to close this and inside the
post footer we're only getting the
username so let's uh destructure this
username I'm going to copy this and
let's see it should be here I'll just
say username now everything should be
working fine we're going to go to the
homepage okay so this is the first user
if we just refresh and now we're getting
the second one the third one the fourth
one right so the jandoo Jano Josh as
well as the Bak okay so we could see
inside this we're giving this usernames
and avatars which are coming from the
public
folder so these are the pictures that we
can see and I hope now it makes sense
since we are taking this destructuring
it from here and pass it to the post
header as well as the post footer and
then just using it inside uh inside the
source and inside this so let's say
username as well as the Avatar and our
application is still missing some
feature that we have in our demo
application so when we refresh we have
this cool loading skeletons but in our
case we don't have so how are we going
to add this it's going to be inside the
chakra they have this skeleton which you
can just call it give some height or
width so let's say width of
maybe 100 pixels and there you go so
this is the 100 pixels white and so so
say like 20 pixels of height and then
you can just put some uh HTML into that
it's going to be contents wrapped and it
it will not be visible so if I just copy
this paste it multiple times the
skeleton gets bigger and bigger but we
don't see anything inside so this
approach is really cool maybe we would
be using this so now inside the feed
posts we're going to go let's say close
the footer and for each posts okay so
here we just have a state so let say con
is loading and set is loading and
initially it is actually going to be
true so when you first refresh the page
the it's going to try to load the posts
and after two seconds so let's say use
effect I'm just initializing it after
two seconds we'll just say set
timeout 200 milliseconds we'll just say
set loading to be false so first when
you refresh the page it's going to
loading state is going to be true for 2
seconds and then it's going to be false
and while it is loading loading we're
going to show that loading skeletons so
we'll just say if it is loading then
just run this array four times so let's
say zero 1 2 3 so it is going to map
through this uh four times we are just
going to get the item or we could just
say underscore and then the
index so now we're going to see what
we're doing here so we're going to have
our skeleton four times when it's
loading so we'll just say vertical stack
for this let's import
it it should be coming from Chakra okay
it's going to have a key with index so
that we don't get any errors from the
react and this is going to have the gap
of four between each uh children align
items let's say Flex start and then we
give the key margin bottom is just going
to be 10 so we're going to have one flag
with let's import it with the gap of
two and then we're going to have
skeleton Circle so let's see if they
have something like this circle and take
skeleton so we're going to have this
Avatar skeleton which is this one I'm
just going to copy that and paste it
let's import it the size is just going
to be 10 and then we're going to have
another vertical
stack and then this is going to have the
gap of two line items to be Flex start
oops so it should be start and then
inside this we'll just have two uh
skeletons with the width of 200 pixels
and height uh 10 pixels I'll just copy
it paste it and let's import these guys
okay I'll just indent them so like this
and after this vertical stack and flex
we're just going to have one more
skeleton I will copy it and paste it and
so it is just going to be this approach
where we see um so it is this one so we
just put some uh HTML into that and it
just doesn't show us but instead it
makes this more it it gives this
skeleton Al bit height so we are going
to say this is going to be width of full
and height of 500 pixels now we are only
going to show this feed POS if it is not
loading so I'm gonna cut all of these
for a second and I'll say if it is not
loading then just return this react
fragment and put them inside now this
should be working as expected so I'm
going to just refresh as we can see we
have this like let's just make this true
for a
second and then let's say it's going to
be
false okay okay so here we just see four
times of this um so say skeletons first
we have the profile picture as well as
the so is it the same
here okay actually we should only have
one right this doesn't make any sense so
let's go to here um so we could just
delete one of them and okay so that
looks nice but I think Instagram has it
like this so that's why I used it I
believe so we're just going to have it
like that
and we have all of these skeletons and
once it is changes the changes the state
we show the feed posts so let's say
contrl Z and yeah that should be working
nice and it should be responsive as well
if we just test it out I'll just open up
my console and just shrink it now as you
can see it just works nice up until here
and then suggested user components uh
just unmounts and it just works nice up
until let's say
here which is one of the smallest phones
okay so now we are going to add the
suggested users component for this we
are going to go into the homepage let's
see um we're going to delete this and
let's say suggested
users and I will just create this
component inside this components folder
so I'll say suggested users and this is
going to have the suggested users. jsx
as well as the
suggested user. jsx so it's going to be
the same approach we are going to create
this um so the posts so here we just had
feed posts and inside we just return
each uh feed post right so we're going
to have the suggested users component
here and then we'll basically return
multiple suggested user and let's get
this one as well I will delete the react
import save it delete this one save it
and let's import this guy and also we're
going to have something called
suggested header and I'll just explain
in a second let's say
rafc import I mean delete this import
react because we're never going to be
using this and it is not um so to say it
is not required uh anymore in react so
we're going to just delete this and save
it and save here so the suggested user
header is going to be this one where we
see our profile okay we have the logout
button profile picture as well as the
username um so let's do create this one
first and we're going to go into the
let's say the suggested users um I'm
just taking taking a look at my notes so
we're going to just delete here and then
we're going to have a let's say vertical
stack because it's going to be in the
stack format so let's say pading
y of 8 and then we're going to have
petting X of six as well as the gap of
four and and then so that should be a
vertical stack and now we're just going
to have the suggested header first then
we're going to have a couple of
suggested user but before that we're
going to actually have this text which
says suggested for you and see all okay
so let's first create this header and
then we'll just go step by step so I'm
just going to takeing I'll just take a
look at my notes again so inside the
suggested header uh we already imported
this let's save and we're going to
create this content so first we'll just
have a flex okay let's import this it is
going to be the justify content space
between and why is this let's take a
look so we have this should say spacing
between these guys so that's why we're
using justify content space between and
then we're just going to align them
vertically so align items Center and
then let's say with
of full so for the right hand side we'll
just have one Flex which is going to be
taking that Avatar as well as the
username so at this point is pretty
basic I'll just copy and paste it and
just walk you through and this Flex is
going to have the Align items to be
Center as well as the gap of two okay so
what we did here was to just create a
flex and put the left child and the
right child Avatar has this name as well
as this size and the source goes into
the profile picture.png which is this
one and then on the left I mean on the
right we have this box which just holds
our username and maybe that should be a
text so that we'll just get the
paragraph and it will be more semantic
so we could delete this box for now and
that should be working nice so below
this Flex we're just going to have that
link that says log out so I'll just
import this from Chakra and this link is
going to be uh so to say import
link so it's going to be rendered as
router link I was trying to say so we'll
just copy this router link as we did
before so as router link is going to
take us to the oath page so let's say SL
oath and then it's going to have a
couple of styles which I will again copy
and paste because at this point it just
doesn't any make the sense to write the
font size font weight and color so it is
not going to have this text decoration
of none so let's just delete and we're
going to paste in a second so let's say
the content is just going to be log out
if I save this and we're going to go
into here so we see this header and when
I hover over this it has this you know
uh the underlining text and I don't
really like this so I will just contrl +
z which is going to be this style of
text decoration is going to be none
let's say log
out and now when we hover over to this
we're not going to see that uh
underline and that is going to be it for
the suggested header now we are going to
build the next thing which is going to
be that uh that text as suggested for
you and see old so below this we just
have one Flex again let's import this
this Flex is just going to have the
Align items to be Center so that we have
vertical alignment and then justify
content again was going to be so what
should we add here okay I heard that you
said space between so I'll just say oops
I can type so we say
space between okay it is because we
would like to have some space between
this guy and then this guy so we're
going to go here just by cont content
space between and then width should be
full and then on the left hand side I'll
just actually copy and paste again it
doesn't make any sense on the left we
have one box font size of 12 font weight
bolt this color and that should be maybe
a text that would be better so let's
just delete this and this is the left
side and now we're going to add the
right side I'm going to copy and paste
that is going to be a text again um so
maybe we should just okay it says see
all font size of again the same point we
bolt hover we are just changing the
color and cursor is just going to be
pointer so that we have that button
feeling now if we just take a look that
should be looking the exact same and
below this we're just going to add all
of our suggested user components okay
one by one so after this Flex
we'll just say suggested user and we're
just going to be calling this let's say
three or four times okay we have three
times and that should be working nice
and Below all of these we'll just have
this buil by and you can just put your
name it's completely okay and I'll just
put mine and I'll just go here so let's
just give a bit space I'll have a box
let's import this uh I think it's just
going to have a couple of different
props let's say align
self start so that so we set that align
items to be Center um to this so let's
see is it inside this Flex okay let's
just delete this and I don't know why we
added this we're going to see okay bug
um we'll have font size of 12 and then
color of gray 500 and also the margin
top is just going to be five so that we
have that spacing and then inside this
box we're just going to say I'll just
copy and paste one line okay just say
this uh copyright icon built by and just
give a space and then one
link that takes you to your YouTube
account or your GitHub LinkedIn whatever
that is so I will import this from
Chakra let's say and Target blank so
that it's going to open this in a new
tab color as well as defont size and
then you could just put your name now
let's save and let's take a look
um okay that should be working
fine here okay that's why we added the
allign self Center I mean start now it
is centered in the in this container so
if we just say that this box going to be
align self to the
start it is just going to be at the very
left starting from here until the end
and if I click to this it'll take me to
my YouTube page and now we're just going
to get into this suggested user
component so it's going to take a couple
of props it's because as you can see
like the number of followers the
username and the profile picture is
different for each of them and we're
going to be solving this by using props
so let's go here and I will just put a
couple of props and let me just take a
look at my notes so the name for this
guy let's say name prop we're going to
give something like Dan abov okay and
followers count as well as the Avatar
profile picture so I'm just going to say
like this we give the name followers and
avatar for this suggested user which we
can grab it like this so number of
followers name and then the Avatar okay
we're going to just be doing this for
these two guys as well so I'm going to
copy it and paste it you can grab this
from the repo or just type it manually
so we have the Ryan this uh number of
followers with this uh profile picture
and we have Christian with this
followers and this profile picture so
I'm going to save this component and
inside the suggested user we're just
going to be using all of them uh here so
first let's just change it with this
Flex import from Chakra we're going to
have one Flex on the left and one button
on the right so we could just say Flex
so what should we use now so we have
some space between so what are we going
to
use justify content space between and
then here we'll just say align items
Center so that it is vertically centered
let's say width is just going to be full
of the parent and then we are going to
have one Flex on the left and then one
button on the right and this button is
just going to say follow or unfollow
okay so inside this Flags we're going to
have Avatar so let's say Avatar and
maybe we could just delete
this source is going to be the Avatar
that is coming as a prop also we'll just
have the name as name let's say and then
what should we have lastly just going to
be the size of medium and this flag is
going to have align items to be Center
as well as the gap of four or let's say
two and then below this Avatar we're
going to have one vertical stack it is
because let's see uh these two things is
just on top of each other and they have
some Gap so you could use box as well
but I'll just use vertical stack so that
I can use the spacing property okay
let's import the vertical stack I'll
just say maybe spacing of two and on the
top we'll just say
box let's get this so this is just going
to be say font size of 12 and then the
font rate of
Bolt so number of followers I'm sorry
should be the name and then below this
we're just going to have the number of
followers I'll just copy paste this is
going to be font size of 11 and then
color just going to be the gray of 500
and this going to be the number of
followers and we could give the number
of followers and then text that says
followers okay and I think that should
be working fine let's see and in the
button I will just say now let's have a
state for this const is followed and set
is followed initially it's just going to
be false when we clict that we're going
to change this state so let's say um if
it is followed then just say unfollow
but in the else case let's say follow
and this button is going to have a
couple of properties let's say font size
of 13 and then BG transparent it should
be a string let's
see um let's say
transparent and then after this PG we're
going to have petting of zero height of
Max content and then after the height
we'll just have font weight of let's say
medium not the bolt let me just scroll
to give a bit space and then here I'll
just say color of blue 400 I'll get this
time and after the color we'll just have
the cursor to be pointer as well as on
the hover State we'll just change the
color um to be I believe it's going to
be white so let's say white and lastly
on clict this function we're just going
to negate this uh state so inside this
Arrow function say set is followed
whatever the value is just negate it if
it was true it's going to be false and
vice versa now let's test it out to see
if that is working nice and there we go
okay this is the demo let's see here um
so yeah we have this follow buttons and
this should be let's say align self
start so that it is not in the center
but it is on the starting from the very
left
so for this we could use in the vertical
stack let's say align items to be flags
start is this going to work yeah it is
working now when we click to this follow
state is going to be um I think yeah
it's going to be true and the text is
now going to be unfollow and if we click
that again it's going to be follow and
we can just use this for all of them and
it's going to be working nice and if we
just take a look if this is respon
responsive or not and up until here it
is responsive and then it is just uh
disappearing so it is perfectly fine so
yeah it's just looking awesome and this
is going to be it for the homepage now
we can go ahead and work with on the
profile page but before that let's add
our title as well as this Fab icon for
this we can go into the index HTML let's
just shrink everything and close it so
inside the index.htm ml we can change
the title I'll just say Instagram clone
you can just put whatever you want and
for the uh icon we can go inside the
public folder and choose this Fab icon
so I'll just change this with f fav
icon. Ico and now if you just save this
that should be working fine that we can
see here so now let's just go ahead and
try to add this user page so for this as
always we're going to go into the app
jsx and duplicate this route now since
the user page is going to be dynamic
okay we'll just say uh we put this
column and then whatever we want so in
our case it's just going to be username
but you can put user ID and anything
like that but in our case it's just
going to be username and the page is
going to be the profile page which we're
just going to create in a second so the
pages another folder called profile page
and inside we are going to have profile
page.
jsx okay so here I'll just import this
save and there we go we can see the
profile page now what are we going to uh
have here is that we're going to have a
container large that we can see
everything is in the center and we're
going to have this profile uh header
okay this is profile header and then
profile tabs and then the profile posts
so we're going to have two flags one at
the top that is going to hold the header
and then one at the bottom that is going
to hold the tabs as well as the posts so
we're going to go here inside the
profile page and as we said we're just
going to have a container uh we can just
delete this and
complete like this okay so here this is
going to has a max width okay say let's
say Max width if I can type
it's going to be container
large and it's also going to have the
petting y of five and inside this we're
going to have two flexes the one is
going to be holding the profile header
and then the second one is going to have
the profile tabs and dsts so let's say
this Flex is going to be ping y of 10
and then ping X of four let's say and
ping um okay actually ping left is just
going to be
uh base of four and medium and above is
just going to be 10 and I think that
should be okay so the maximum width for
this Flex uh let's say Max width or
let's just say width is just going to be
full and then we'll say margin X of
Auto and also it's just going to be Flex
direction of column so let's say it's
going to be column and then here we'll
just have the profile uh not the page
but let's say profile header which is a
component that we're going to create in
a second and then here we'll just have
the tabs let's say profile tabs and also
the profile
posts let's create these components so
inside the components we can just create
a profile and we're just going to put
every component that is related to
profile into this folder so let's say
profile header. jsx and let's say
profile
tabs. jsx as well as the profile
posts. jsx and the single post profile
post. jsx now let's say RFC to all of
them
okay
now let's import the header and let's
say profile
tabs posts um
okay okay now that should be fine I will
get some prop props into this Flex as
well let's say a ping X of base
two and Med small of four let's say and
Max where WID let's say this is just
going to be full width and then margin X
Auto border top it's going to have one
pixel
solid and then border color just going
to be white Alpha and
300 and then the direction is just going
to be colume let's
say okay now we can save this and we're
going to work with the profile header so
let's just close this for now and if we
just take a look we can see the profile
header with border and it holds the
profile tabs as well as the profile
posts so we're going to go and work with
the header so the profile header is
going to have two two things now on the
left it's going to have this profile
Avatar and then on the right this
content so we can say flex and then on
the left put the avatar on the right put
the content which can be a vertical
stack because everything is in the
vertical um in the vertical Direction so
we're going to go ahead and here we'll
just say this should be a flex and we're
going to have
avatar on the left but this is not going
to be an avatar actually it's just going
to be Avatar group and let's see what
that is from the chakra and we're going
to say Avatar and we have a group here
and it just gives you this kind of
border that we use here if you use
Avatar you're not going to get this
border that's why we're using it and
let's go here uh we're going to import
this and this Avatar group has a couple
of props but before that let's add this
Flex props so the Gap is going to be on
the base four on the small it's just
going to be 10 and now this is going to
have some padding y of 10 and then
direction is going to be uh on the base
it's going to be colume but on the small
and above it's just going to be row
which is the default for the flex and
then Avatar group is going to have some
props let's just put it um size it's
going to have a couple of different
sizes so let's say for the base it's
going to be uh x large and then for the
small uh actually let's say medium and
it's just going to be 2 x large okay so
after this size it's going to be justify
self of Center and then align self Flex
start as well as the margin X is just
going to be
AO okay inside we're going to have our
Avatar and this is going to be where we
put our source so let's say source for
the name I'll just
say as a
programmer and the source is just going
to be uh okay profile picture.png and
now that should be working fine also
let's add an ALT um so what is the
problem okay that should be name
actually not the source and ALT is just
going to be as a programmer logo okay um
after the Avatar group we're going to
have the right hand side which we said
that it could be a vertical stack let's
import it and it's going to have a
couple of different props let's say
align items to be sent actually we start
and then the gap of two margin X is
going to be Auto as well as the flex of
one so it is going to uh just contain
the remaining part after the uh Avatar
group okay so this is going to have one
Flex okay and we're going to add a
couple of different props so let's say
Gap is going to be four direction is
just going to be again on the base
colume and on the other side like small
and above it's just going to be Row And
as far as for the justify content we're
going to be doing the same thing so
we'll just have two different values for
the base this is going to be Center on
the small and above it's going to be
Flex start and after the justify content
we'll say align items to be Center as
well as width of full and now we're
going to hold the username as well as
that edit profile button so let's say
one text okay import it um let's say
let's say as a programmer and underscore
so text is going to be font size of say
it's going to have a couple of different
values for the base it's going to be
small and for the medium and above is
going to be the large font size and that
should be okay now let's save and let's
take a look so we have the profile I
mean the username and then the profile
avatar on the left Okay so we are going
to add this edit profile button so after
the text we can put a flex here and
let's just give a little bit space like
this and this Flex is going to have gap
of four and then align items to be
Center as well as the justify content
Center and then inside this Flex we're
going to have a button that says edit
profile so that should be button from
Chakra okay
edit
profile and for the button properties
this is going to have the background of
white and color of black and on the
hover State we are just going to change
the background so let's say hover it's
going to take another object with BG is
being white Alpha
800 and then after this we going to just
change the size on the base is going to
be X small and for the medium okay let's
say comma medium it is going to be small
size and that should be it that should
be it for the button and after this
button after this flex and after this
Flex we're going to have one more Flex
which is going to be holding the number
of posts followers and following count
so let's say this Flex is just going to
have align okay Flex um
align items to be Center and the Gap is
just going to be on the base two and on
the small it's going to be before let's
just scroll a little bit and then we're
going to have one text that is that says
like posts but we need to show the
number of posts and for this we need to
highlight it and I will use a text and
I'll just say this should be as a span
okay span tag and font weight of Bolt
and let's say margin right of one and it
says let's say four posts and now we can
basically just copy and paste this a
couple of times so this is going to hold
the number of
followers and then this is going to just
hold the um let's say 149 and let's just
duplicate this again I'll copy and paste
it and this is just going to say
following and maybe we could just say a
random number say 175 and now if you
just save this let's take a look so this
is the result that we get and below this
what are we going to have let's see the
username itself as well as the
description or the biography so we're
going to go into our uh vs code and
after the following count okay after the
text after this Flex we're going to have
another Flex that says Al line items to
be Center and then the gap of four below
this what are we going to have one text
that is going to be holding the username
let's say as a programmer and then this
text is is going to have font
size of small and font weight of let's
say bolt and below this uh flx we're
going to have one more text I'll just
duplicate it and take it here um font
size of small we could just delete this
which is going to be the biography and
I'm just going to copy and paste it so
tutorials that are meant to level up
your skills as a programmer now we just
save and that should be working fine as
far as for the um the profile header and
if we just shrink our screen let's see
uh after the small breakpoint okay it is
not working at this point so maybe we
could just make the font a bit smaller
as we have here so for this we're going
to go again back to here and let's see
so for every text we are just going to
make this a little bit smaller font size
so let's say font size and on the base
it could be X small small and on the
medium we'll just say it's going to be
small and I will copy this and paste it
to here as well as here which holds the
following count and followers as well as
the posts so save and let's take a look
again okay now that should be working
properly so at this point it is going to
go okay is each each rings and then here
it it goes again to the very bottom so
now that's that is working up until 300
pixels now we're going to add the
profile tabs and then the posts so let's
work with the profile tabs so the
profile tabs is going to be relatively
basic because if we just take a look at
the demo so we just have these three
guys and they are next to each other so
we could use flex and just give a little
bit gap between them so one Flex with
three children so we'll just say flex
and let's import it we're going to give
a couple of props let's say width is
just going to be full and then the
justify content to be
Center and then the Gap is going to be
on the base four and then on the small
is going to be 10 smaller and above the
Gap is increased and then text transform
so it's going to be uppercase and lastly
the font weight is just going to be bolt
inside the flex we're going to have
three uh children so one flex two Flex
three flexes okay the first one is just
going to have a border top of one pixel
solid white and let's go inside and it's
just going to have um let's say
box let's import the box it's going to
have font size of 20 and then this box
is going to be holding one icon which is
BS grid
3x3 and it is coming from react icons so
let's import it from so let's say import
um BS okay it already gives us this
suggestion and that should be working
fine below this we're just going to have
one text that says posts and import the
text it is going to have the font
size font size of 12 and display of on
the base you're not going to show the um
post uh text so on the base it's just
going to be none on the smaller screens
and above it just could be block and
that should be it but we need to add a
couple of props here as well so let's
say align items Center and then we're
going to have ping
three on all directions on the four
directions and then gap of one the
cursor is just going to be pointer oops
cursor okay so that was the first child
actually we're just going to we can copy
this okay and just delete the these guys
and we're going to just duplicate that
twice so one and then like the second
one and this these are not going to have
border top we could delete that because
if we just take a look at the demo only
this guy uh looks like it's active so we
can that's why we're just deleting
deleting this border tops I cannot talk
clearly and then here we're just going
to change the icons as well as the text
so after the post we had the
saved and then the let's say
likes now you could put uh reals which
Instagram has but in our case just save
should be okay and as far as this uh
icon we'll just say
BS uh bookmark it should be we're going
to just put this and then the last one
is going to be
BS sweet heart and for the size actually
the font weight let's say it's going to
just be
bold and I think now we can save this
and that should be working fine and okay
it is not working let's just
refresh okay so it is almost the same
thing that we have here now we're going
to go and work with the profile posts
which is going to be one of the longest
uh part because um it's going to have
this model when you click to that it
looks pretty complicated on the left we
have the image
so like uh the common section the footer
section as well as when you shrink that
uh it is also responsive so we need to
take care of it and then it's also going
to have this loading
skeletons okay in the first load so
let's go ahead and try to implement this
it is going to be here in the profile
posts and we're going to just have the
exact same behavior or the approach
where we just did in the feed posts so
let me just open that up so here we're
going to have a loading state with the
use effect after 2 seconds we're going
to say is loading should be false and
while it loads we're going to show our
skeletons but if it is not loading then
we're just going to show our posts okay
but it is not going to be the feed post
instead it is going to be the profile
post and I think we have already created
it so let's see here okay it's going to
be this profile post and yeah okay and
it's going to take some s so let's close
maybe everything the profile header tabs
um app and then index HTML so we can
open up the profile post as well then we
can start to working so here um let's
delete everything and then here we'll
just import the profile post maybe four
times and before we import that we just
need to just put a grid here so it's
going to be the grid uh component or the
grid container that is going to hold the
grid items so why are we using grid it
is because like we're just going to have
three of them at the same uh at the same
width so we can use fractions for this
and once we hit the small break point it
is just going to be one fraction so the
entire width so it is okay to use grid
for this and you can check for it from
the documentation as well so here we
have grd and GD item and GD is going to
be the contain the grid item is just
going to be each child so here we can
see they they are using this template
columns which determines how many times
uh it's going to be in the same row if
we just say four times like this it's
going to have four times and then it's
just going to repeat if we just add two
then on the each row it is going to have
two columns and then again and then
again so on and so forth so this is what
we're going to be doing and we can give
a gap column Gap and anything so let's
go here inside this grid we're going to
have this template columns but in our
case it is going to be responsive so
that's why we're just going to put an
object and let's go to bottom on this
small we'll just say repeat and let's
say on the smaller it's just going to
have one okay it's going to just take
the full width and then on the medium
we're just going to repeat three times
so let's say repeat and I'll just Auto
accept this and change it to the three
and the Gap could be one I think this is
going to be the uh row Gap but we want
to also give the column Gap we could say
one as well and we're going to have a
loading state for now maybe we could
ignore this um or actually let's just do
it right now so as always we're going to
say const is loading or maybe you could
just pause the video here and just try
to implement this because we already did
this so set loading initially is going
to be true and now what are we going to
have here yes we're going to have a use
effect let's initialize it on the on
Mount and we're going to have set time
out after 2 seconds we're just going to
update it to be false that should be 200
milliseconds and then we are going to
say inside this grid if it is loading
let's say if it is loading then we just
want to um okay and and so we're going
to have uh let's say six items okay 1 2
3 4 5 6 do map and we're going to get
each item as well as the
index we're going to return some loading
skeletons so I'll just say vertical
stack for this so let me just take it
vertical stack and import it it is going
to have this key as the index and then
inside this vertical stack we're just
going to have one skeleton let's say and
import this we could just put a box with
uh 300 pixels so box height of did I say
width that should be height okay height
300 pixels I will import the box and we
could just say
content
CRA and now what we can do we'll say
this skeleton should be with of full and
for the vertical stack to say align
items to be Flex start and so let's say
Flex start and gap of four now if we
just save this and what are we going to
see okay that's it that's what we see in
the first initial load six loading
skeletons and now we're going to
actually be uh building the profile
posts so I'll just say if it is not
loading and in this case we're going to
so let's say end end
and then we're just going to go
here and with a react fragment then
we're just going to have profile let's
say profile poost component and we're
just going to import it four times and
for each of them they're just going to
actually be taking an image so let's say
image uh we could just say image 1.png
for this and we're just going to take
this so I'll say control alt and the
arrow key down three times or two times
and then I'll just paste it now we can
just add all of them at once so that was
a cool shortcut in vs Cod that you can
use now inside the profile post we're
just going to go inside and since we use
the grid now we're going to use the grid
item in here because this is the child
or the children for that grid item I
mean for the grid container okay that
was the grid container the parent and
this is going to be the child so now if
we just take a look at the demo that
we're going to see something now we only
see the images but when we hover over it
we see this overlay with the number of
uh comments and likes so we're going to
add uh two things which is going to be
the image as well as this overlay so
let's go here we're going to have a grid
item which is coming from Chakra it's a
grid item here as well and it's going to
have a couple of different props so
let's let me just take a look at my
notes okay it is going to be first
cursor of pointer and then below this
border radius of four so that we can get
this uh rounded corners and then
overflow of hidden so that it doesn't
overflow our images and then border say
one pixel solid and then the Border
color that just going to be white Alpha
300 and then the position is going to be
relative because we're going to use
absolute positioning inside uh this
parent component and then aspect ratio
one uh one to one so it's just going to
be a square and on click we're going to
use onop function but we can use it in a
little bit because we're going to add
the model uh at the end okay so we'll
say one Flex this is going to be our so
to say the overlay when we hover over it
so how can we do this so we'll just say
opacity initially going to be zero but
on the hover state it is the opacity is
just going to be one and this will make
it uh visible on the hover state so
position going to be
absolute and top zero left zero so we
could also say right zero and bottom
zero that will make it width of full and
then we'll just say background should be
let's say black alpha maybe 700 and for
the transition we just want to have a
smooth transition you could say all 3
seconds or 0.3 seconds and then e okay
this is going to be uh our transition so
we could say Z index is going to be one
so at the top and then justify content
to be Center and inside this uh we're
going to have the number of likes and
comments so we're going to go inside and
let's say Flex um this is going to have
the Align and justify content as Center
so align item Center justify content
Center and then let's see gap of uh
maybe that should be 50 50 pixels and
then one Flex for the number of uh so to
say likes and another Flex for the
comments so this Flex is just going to
have uh AI fill heart this is the icon
that is coming from react icons you
could just say size of uh maybe 20 so
let's just give it like this and then
we're going to have the
text let's import the
text number of seven and then font
weight of
bolt that should be a lowercase and then
margin left of two now let's import this
icon okay we'll just say import AI f
part from react icon SL Ai and after
this text we're going to have this Flex
I mean this one I believe yes and this
flx is just going to have fa comment so
maybe at this point I could copy and
paste it and it is nothing complex we
just have the icon as we had here we
give a size for it and the text that
says uh seven comments now let's import
the icon so import fa comment from react
icon slf
and now let's save and hopefully that
should be working fine we're going to go
here but we don't have the image so
let's show the image as well um after
this flexes at the very bottom so we
have one two and three okay after this
it should be I believe yes this is our
overlay and then we're just going to put
the image and at this point we could
just say image um source which is coming
from let's import this first the source
is coming as a prop so that was the
image so for the source it is going to
be taking the uh the image and then we
could just say alt um let's say profile
post and then this is just going to have
width of
100% And then height of let's say
100% and lastly we could to say style or
maybe the object fit should be cover so
let's save and let's save it here
um okay we have the loading skeletons
and then the images when we hover over
it we got the overlay for each of them
and that should be working fine when we
click to that now we should uh we should
have a this model so for this we are
just going to go here and let's say
model and how are we going to use this
so a model just has this uh first the
parent and a button that hover I mean
the button triggers the model to be open
so that uh that button for us going to
be this image so when we click to that
it is going to call the open function so
at this point it is onopen let me just
zoom in and on click we're going to add
it so this model is going to has the is
open variable or the state that checks
if if current this model is open or not
and the on close function and it's going
to have a mod model overlay it's going
to have model content close button and
the model body that we can see here also
you could add model footer in our case
we're not going to add it so let's see
how that look like so this is the model
footer and then the body so this is the
header where we see the close button and
this is the overlay when we click to
that on close function runs and model
closes so now now let's implement this
in our application so first of all I
will just copy this three lines okay our
states and functions I'm going to just
paste it after our state and let's get
this use disclosure Hook from Chakra and
for the on open function we're going to
be adding it into here uh okay I just
paste it into the wrong place so I'm
going to cut it delete this one and that
should be inside the profile post okay
for each post when we click to this grid
item we're going to call this onopen
function so I will say import the use
disclosure and on click to this let's
say onclick just call the unopen
function and that will make the model to
be open and now I will go here and I
think I'll just copy all of this and
maybe I should first delete this model
footer because we're never going to use
it and like this I'm going to copy this
and maybe at the very bottom so after
the let's say a maybe not the grid item
okay so here I'm going to put a fragment
uh oops so I'll just delete okay what is
going
on okay I think I messed it up so I'm
just going to delete it and okay this is
the grade item that we have I'm just
going to wrap it with a react fragment
so that we can both return the grid item
and then the model at the end so this is
what we're doing
so we had the grid item we just put a
fragment at the top and we just close it
at the very bottom and after the grid
item we're just going to paste what we
have just copied and this is going to
have the model let's say model overlay
content header uh close Button as well
as the model body or here we could just
say hey this is a model and if we just
save this now let's test it out when we
click to any of these we're going to get
this model and now we're just going to
make it look like this so uh we're going
to go inside and let's start to work on
we're going to be basically changing the
model body content so on the left we're
going to have the image and on the right
we're going to have the comment section
so let's just see again um here on the
left we have the image on the right we
have just everything the comment section
and then the uh post footer so we're
going to get into that so that's why
we're going to use a flex container
on the right one child for the image and
another child for the comment section so
let's open up our application and then
we're going to go inside first let's add
a couple of different props into here
now there is something called is
Centered for the model and if you just
say true for this that is going to be
that's going to take the model to the
center of the screen and we're going to
be changing the size depending on uh
depending on the break points so it's
going to be resp iive so let's say base
3x large and on the medium screens and
above it's just going to be a bit larger
which is 5X large so that should be it
for the model and we're going to go into
the model body and we need to change the
background color to be completely black
and it is going to also have padding
bottom of five so here we're going to
have one Flex container so let's just
indent this properly and this is going
to have two Childs or or two children
and this Flex let's say Gap okay that
should be gap of four if I can type and
then it's going to have the width it's
going to be uh responsive so let me just
copy and paste really quick uh on the
base it's going to be 90% of the parent
on the small and above uh 70% and medium
and above is going to be the full screen
and then we'll just have the margin X to
be Auto so after this we're going to
have the box that is going to be holding
our image so we'll just say box import
the box and it is going to have a couple
of different props so let's say the
Border radius of
four and since it's going to hold the
image let's say overflow hidden it
should be and then the Border one
pixel solid and then the Border color
of uh White Alpha 300 and then we'll
just say Flex of
1.5 and this is going to be taking the
image so that could be a self closing
tag and for the source uh we're just
going to put the prop that we're getting
as this image so source is just going to
be the image itself and for the alt we
could again say maybe the profile post
and then below this image we are going
to have another Flex after the Box
actually and this is going to be holding
the right hand side so let's say flex
and the width of this going to be Flex
one so this is uh a half point is just
bigger than this one or the wider and
then the flex direction is going to be
let's say column and then we could add
padding X of 10 let me just scroll down
a little bit and give a bit space for us
and pading X of 10 display of uh let's
say on the base we not going to see this
the common container and then medium and
above is just going to be flex and now
we're going to have the user profile
picture or the Avatar as well as the
username so I will just create another
flag that says let's say go here align
items to be Center and then the
justify I can type justify content space
between and then this is going to have
the Avatar as well as the the text so
let's say Avatar self closing tag this
is going to take a source as let's say
slash profile pick.
PNG let's say size is just going to be
small and then name could be
just your
name and after the Avatar we're going to
have a text that puts the username I'm
just going to copy and paste it so we
have text component with the text
content font weight of Bolt font size of
uh 12 pixels and after this Flex We are
going to add the delete icon so say
after the flex we could have a box let
me just scroll a little bit and this box
is going to have an icon inside let's
say MD delete
and size of 20 and let's say cursor is
just going to be
pointer and this is coming from the
react icons so let's import it okay that
should be working fine and we're going
to add a couple of props into this box
so we'll just make the color to be red
on Hover state so let's say hover
another object we're going to change the
background to be white Alpha 300
and the color let's
say red 600 and basically it's going to
have a border radius let's say radius
and then it's going to be four pading
let's say one now let's save at this
point and let's take a look how that
looks like so we're going to go here um
when we open up our model okay this is
the model title maybe we could actually
just deleted the content at least so
let's say this is going to be a self
closed model
header like
this okay it is not working properly uh
let me just let me just check really
real quick so what happens if we just
delete this completely now let's take a
look okay we don't have the model header
in this uh component and now this is not
working proper properly we should be
having this next to the um so let's see
it should be looking like this one Flex
on the left and this guy should be on
the right so let's take a look at it
okay so the problem here is that this
Flex has the direction of column so this
is going to be at the top and this
delete icon is going to be at the bottom
that's why we're having this Behavior so
instead so let's just first delete this
this is not related so we're going to
wrap this with another Flex okay so I'm
going to cut this from here and then
paste it here so what we just did is we
created another Flex so this is going to
be our first child on the left and this
going to be our second child on the
right and we're going to say align items
iner justify content space between to
this guy and we are just going to say
that this Flex is going to have align
items to be Center and then let's say
gap of four okay okay that was a bit
complicated but this is what it is uh so
here we have the delete icon on the
right and these guys on the left and let
me just quickly iterate what we did um
we have a flex okay this is our
container and on the left we have the
username as well as the avatar on the
right we have the box so we were missing
one Flex container at this point so
sorry about that so after this Flex We
need to add something called the divider
and it is going to be this thing that we
have let's just refresh okay so this is
called the divider and if we just take a
look okay you just call the component
and you can give orientation you can
give height and just Center it with this
components or you could use absolute
centering um anything like that so we're
going to be using this divider after uh
this component so we are going to go
here after the box after the def Flex
we'll just say divider and import it so
it is going to have the margin y of four
and then background of let's say gray
500 and then below the divider we're
going to have our actual comms which you
can use vertical stack for this because
they're going to be in the vertical uh
Direction so I'll import the vertical
stack and let's say your width of
full and then we're going to have the L
align items if I can type properly align
items to be Center or start it should be
actually and then Max height of 350
pixels and we're going to use overflow y
let's say overflow y should be Auto and
I will show you what this means but
basically when the comments are too
large so let's say if we have multiple
components it is not going to overflow
but instead we're going to have a scroll
bar that we can scroll through it and we
will see how we can how we are going to
use it and then inside the flex we're
actually going to have common components
so in our case let's say we're going to
have three common component so we're
going to create that in a second it's
going to take a couple of props let's
say created that uh we could just say
one day Echo and it's going to have a
username let's say as a programmer and
then below this it's going to have the
profile picture so let's say this is
going to be SL profile pick. PNG as well
as the text uh maybe I'll just copy and
paste it so dummy images from unsplash
and we're going to put two more comments
which I will copy and paste the exact
same thing so let's see uh we have the
created ad username profile pick and
text so these are the comments different
comments that this post has so let's
create it so it should be inside the
maybe let's say com components
comment and we're just going to have
comment.
jsx so we're going to export this and
then import it here um so it should be
this one actually right we can delete
the model header we're not using it and
now let's see it was taking the created
at username profile picture and text so
let's say created at um the username
let's say and then profile pick as well
as the text and now we could save and
let's take a
look okay we have three comments now
we're just going to create one of them
and it's going to work for the others so
let's go here inside the commment
component so it is going to have a
[Music]
flex with the gap of four let's say and
then inside the flex we're going to have
the avatar on the
left and then the comment content on the
right so import the Avatar let's say the
maybe source is just going to be the uh
profile pick and for the name we could
just give the username name that we are
getting as a
prop and then the size is just going to
be
small and after the Avatar we're going
to have one more Flex that says
direction of column because it's going
to have the created that as well as the
column I mean created that as well as
the username uh field so let's say
colume and then one Flex that says gap
of two and this is going to take the
username as well as the comment so let's
say text import the text it is going to
have the user name and font weight
should be
bolt and then font size is just going to
be 12 pixels and after this text we're
going to let's say create another text
that says the text or the comment so
let's close off this text and it's just
going to have the f size as 14 and not
any colors okay after this Flex we're
going to have one more font or one more
text I'm going to copy this paste it it
is going to be having the 12 pixels as
well as the color of let's say gray and
this is going to be the created at date
and that should be fine now we're going
to save and let's
see okay we have all of our uh comments
in the vertical Direction so now we're
going to add this uh post footer at the
very bottom and for this we're going to
add another divider after the comments
and then the post footer which we
already created so we are going to go
here profile post and then after the
vertical stack let's say we want to have
a divider okay let's say divider margin
y of four and then
background okay margin y of four
background GR
let's say
800 and after the divider we'll just
have the post footer component that we
already created so post footer it was
okay this one uh it doesn't give us any
Auto Imports so let's say so let's
import it we'll say import post footer
it's going to be coming from we're going
to go one up it was inside the feed post
slost footer and if we save now that is
going to be working fine
in our case okay it is here but we need
to just push it to the very bottom which
we can uh achieve this by using margin
Top Auto so we're going to go into the
post putter let's say do we have that
margin uh Auto no we don't so let's say
this should have the margin uh
top of Auto let's say and let's
see okay this is what we have but we
don't want to see this view all uh
comments section here we can just delete
it um for this we are going to go into
the post footer and this is going to be
taking a prop called is profile picture
I mean if the profile page if you are in
the profile page and we're looking the
post footer we don't want to see this uh
content here so maybe all of these I'm
going to cut this
actually and then I will say if it is
not the profile page each and then uh
just return this jsx and it should be
inside the fragment and then paste it
and we're going to go here and we'll say
this is the profile page let's say true
and now we are not going to see the
section we're only going to see the
number of likes and the comment section
with the icons so the exact the same
thing that we have here and now let's
check if this is responsive or not I
will just open up my console and if we
just shrink this okay let's see we have
some
errors uh okay let's just refresh to get
rid of those
errors and let's open up this and when
we just shrink that at this point uh
let's say in the medium we're not going
to see this Comon section it's going to
disappear and you only see the image and
it is working fine up until 300 pixels
and even if we close it so up until here
it is looking pretty nice we have all of
our posts and the last thing that I want
to show you is that when we add multiple
commments now instead of three let's say
we're just going to put a couple of more
okay let's say maybe 10 or 15 so when we
get to here let me just uh make this a
bit bigger okay when we have this here
we just see now we have this scroll bar
where once the content overflows we say
that overflow is just going to be Auto
and specifically the Y AIS is going to
be Auto so this allows us to have uh
this scroll bar if you just didn't put
this uh prop if you just delete this
then it's going to overflow the content
did you see and that's why we're adding
this the maximum height is 350 pixels
and then overflow Y is auto so the last
thing that I want to add is going to be
we're just going to change this uh uh so
to say this scroll bar and we're just
going to make it a little bit better for
this we can go into the index.
CSS okay we're going to go here and
we'll just add a couple of styles
basically we're just going to make our
scroll bar in the dark mode and just
make it a bit thinner so this is how we
can change it so we'll just put three I
mean two columns and then slash
webkit uh so it should be webkit Das
scroll bar okay and inside we'll just
say the width should be 10 pixels and
then there is something called track and
uh thumb so for the track we're just
going to have this color uh so # 1 E1
e24 and then for the thumb let's go down
below and then the thumb color is just
going to be uh 3 F 3F and 40 so this is
going to have this kind of uh grayish
color and at the end when we hover over
this we would like to change the
background color and we can just accept
this it's going to be uh 555 and now now
let's save and let's see how this is
going to look like I'll just go here um
let's wait okay this is our new scroll
bar and I think it looks better and even
in the homepage we can see that so this
is our new scroll bar so to say okay so
after a quick and short break let's
continue to the project so this is where
we left we only have the UI design and
nothing else about back end so as you
might know we're going to be using
Firebase which is a backend as a service
that is provided by Google so it allow
allows us to build a web and mobile
applications without having to manage
servers or any databases so it provides
us a lot of useful features such as
authentication real-time database um
cloud storage hosting I mean hosting and
much more and in this tutorial we're
going to be using the most common three
services uh which is which are going to
be the authentication fire store and
storage so first thing that we need is
to create a Firebase project and even
before for that we need to um just
create a Firebase uh account so I
already have one so you need to just uh
go to the console. Firebase google.com
and just uh create an account for free
and then you'll get to this page where
you uh where you're going to have your
Firebase projects so this is the project
that I showed you in the demo so I'll
just uh create another one Let's uh
click to this and uh you could just say
insta colone but I'll just say YouTube
and let's continue with this uh we could
have analytics or you can just uh s of
say disable it but I'll just have it so
let's continue uh select an account so
let's say default account for Firebase
right and we're going to create the
project so while it installs we need to
uh install a couple of packages so let's
go here uh I'll just open up a new
terminal and the first one that we need
is going to be the Firebase so let's say
mpm install Firebase and we're going to
be using something called Z
okay let's say uh Firebase uh and just
press space so zent this is going to be
a uh s to say library that we're going
to be using for the global State
Management and uh you're going to see
how that works and then we need to
install another package called react
Firebase hooks so this is going to allow
us uh with the authentication just to
make uh our code a little bit cleaner
and S to say just like reacti is because
it is going to uh provides us some Hooks
and lastly we need to install another
package so let's say add chakra D
ui/ icons so this is going to give us
some icons that we're going to be using
uh from Chakra so let's press enter and
now while this installs we can go to
here now our project is ready let's say
continue and then it sorry it's going to
take us to here let's uh select the web
and then we could give a name again
let's say
I'll just give the same name insta clone
D yoube so I'll say Register App we
could um so to say just ignore this
hosting for now okay so it gives us some
uh some script that says mpm install
Firebase we already did already did this
now we can just um s to say copy this
thing I'll just copy this which is going
to be our Firebase um so to say
configuration we're going to go into the
vs code and this has been installed as
well let's k this terminal and Shrink
this so we're going to go into Source
let's say
Firebase and we're going to be putting
our Firebase configuration to here so
let's say Firebase JS and now I'll just
copy I mean I already copied so I'll
just paste and now here we need to just
uh explore some uh stuff so first of all
let's just ignore the analytics for now
okay we have this initialization of the
app let's delete all of the comments
okay just delete delete and now we are
going to get the authentication uh
service so I'll just say import get oath
okay from Firebase SL o this is going to
give us the authentication and then
we're going to get the fire store as
well as the storage so just get them
from this Firebase slf fir store and
storage now that we have our application
so what this does is basically we have a
configuration so this tells our code
that this is the Firebase project that
we want to connect so we are passing
this object into this initialize app and
then it returns us the application uh so
the Firebase application that we have on
the cloud so we are going to get the
authentication system let's say con out
and will say get out and then we need to
just pass the application and then we're
going to get the fire store in the exact
same way so you could say cons DB but
I'll just say fire store just to make
code a little bit uh more readable so we
know uh uh which database this is so it
is fire store we say get fire store and
pass the app so now we are we have the
fire store so to say instance as well
and then lastly we will just get the
storage so at this point I'll just Auto
accept this and at the end of our file
we need to just export all of these
because we might want to use them in our
projects and indeed we're going to be
using them so now let's save this and we
can put them into the environment
variable but for now let's just skip
that we could maybe to that uh at the
end of the project so now uh we have
this oath fire store and storage but we
don't really initialize that so let's go
into our uh console so let's see
continue to console and now we need to
add those services so let's add the
authentication we're going to say uh get
started with
it and now it is going to ask us uh
which providers do you want so let's say
email and password you can just enable
that
and then we also want to add a new
provider which is going to be this
Google um let's say enable um okay we
don't really need to okay let's select
our support email and then we could just
say say
save and it's going to initialize it for
us as well let's see and while that is
been uh added in the background let's
take a look at this throwing that we
have so Firebase gives us some services
and there's actually a lot of services
that we can use even for machine
learning stuff but in our project we're
going to be using these uh three okay so
authentication fir store and storage in
the storage we're going to store our
images for the posts and profile
pictures for the fir store we're just
going to be storing our users and posts
and in the authentication it is going to
actually store us the users but the
thing is this users does uh I mean this
users has nothing to do with the users
that we're going to be storing here so
so it is because authentication and Fir
store are separate Services okay so
authentication handles you the uh so to
say authentication so it just checks if
this user is logged in or not and this
fire store uh it is a database that I uh
typed it here so we're going to store
our users and posts so we are storing
our users here it is because we would
like to know how many followers this
user has how many following this user I
mean how many users uh this user follows
how many posts this user has so what is
the full name profile picture biography
email username Etc and then also there's
like create ad and user ready and then
for our post document uh for our post
doc I mean collection I'm sorry so this
is a collection by the way this is also
a collection okay so we're going to have
for each post an ID a caption of the
post and image URL which we are going to
be storing them inside our storage so
we're going to have uh how many likes
this post has and we can store it as an
array of string and each string is going
to be the IDE of the user that like this
post and then we're going to have the
comments and each comment is going to be
this comment document that I put it
right here so each comment is going to
have the comment itself okay maybe it
says hey man this post is really great
and then this post is created by some
user right and then which post this
comment is belonged to
and lastly when this comment has been
posted which is the create that date so
also this post is going to have when
this post has been created and who
posted this post right so these are
going to be our collections so the users
collection and posts collection and each
post uh is going to have this comments
array maybe it's just going to be an
empty array right a post might have zero
comments or maybe it'll have like
multiple and each comment will uh will
be in this format so yeah this is what
we are doing so we just initialized the
authentication let's initialize the fire
store and storage as well we're going to
go here into build let's say uh where is
the fire store okay it is a database
like it is real-time database okay so
whenever something uh changes it just
gives you immediately back so kind of
like a socket so I I'll just say create
the database so database ID is default
let's say Lo
um okay let's see okay let's say next
and then we could start in the test mode
and once we deploy this project we could
uh we're going to go into the production
mode and we'll just put our security
rules here for now don't worry about
that now we can just uh read and write
this database until uh 1 month later so
I'll just say enable Okay it's going to
enable it in the background let's see
okay it's been initialized now we have
an empty fir store database and lastly
we're going to go go into the storage
okay this is going to be for storing
images let's say get started and in the
test mode
again um okay let's say done and let's
wait okay so we got the uh storage as
well uh and it is like there are no
files here yet and we're going to be
adding all of them in the uh incoming
sections so first things first let's go
into our project and we just want to
First handle the authentication so let's
go to here and there is a problem that
we need to fix so let's go to the oath
form okay so here we have the entire
Logic for sign up and login which is not
optimal we would like to just create one
component for login that is going to
handle the login functionality and then
one component for the signup that is
going to handle the signup functionality
okay so let's just delete this for now
and then we are going to delete that uh
let's see so we're going to delete this
on click because you're not going to use
this and then we are going to let's say
delete the navigate and the inputs could
be here for now let's just create our
components so one for login. jsx let's
say rafc give me the boiler plat delete
the react import and save it one for the
let's say sign up. jsx and we'll just
say rafc and then delete this save it
and one for the Google o and it is
because when we click to this button you
would like to log in with Google so
that's why we're going to create a
component for it as well and just put
the logic into there so let's say
Google um o. jsx let's say RFC which is
going to give us the borderer plate we
could delete this line save it and then
let's see what are we going to do now in
the login form we would like to have the
email and password right so we could
actually copy this
and let's say uh I mean we're going to
copy this and then we're going to go
into the login let's just have an empty
fragment and we could paste this let's
import these um so say we imported the
input from Chakra and we're going to get
this inputs so I'm going to copy this
paste it to let's say here okay let's
import the use State and we could delete
the confirm password from the login page
and now that should be working fine and
below this uh inputs we would like to
have a button that says login right for
this we could go let's say which one is
going to be let's say it's going to be
this button I'm going to copy this and
then paste it right here and it is just
going to say login okay we could delete
like this and okay that should be like
this and then let's import the button
okay it's going to have the withd full
color schem blue font size small uh I
mean size small phone size 14 and this
is going to have an onclick function for
that we could uh skip that and it's
going to have a loading uh so to say
state but we're going to add all of them
once we had the login functionality so
let's just save this now and then we're
going to go and let's say we would like
to just delete these inputs and then
what are we going to do so actually
let's copy these inputs and we're going
to paste it into the sign up as well so
let's have an empty fragment okay we are
going to have this email and password as
well because when we sign up we're going
to ask uh those inputs as well so let's
get this inputs which is going to be
holding the let's say email password it
is going to take the full
name as well as the username right
username and it's not going to ask the
confirm password and there is a reason
I'll show you so let's just take the
full name above as well as the username
let's let's import the use State okay so
we have these two inputs and let's just
copy this and paste it again and
actually for now let's just ignore the
password okay we are going to copy the
email and paste it again so we're going
to have we're going to be asking the
email and then let's say we're going to
ask the username so username and then I
will just copy this and paste it again
I'm going to say so to say just ask
default full name so full name so it is
going to be having the type of let's say
text this is going to have the type of
text and this is going to be taking the
value as inputs. username and when we
type in into this input we're going to
be changing the username field so I'll
say change the username when we type in
and for this it's going to be the same
inputs. full name and then for the email
I mean the on change we're not going to
ask the email but the full name so these
are going to be our inputs okay email
username full name and for the password
we're not going to have the confirm
password but instead we're going to just
do something else so I'm going to just
cut I mean cut this for a second we're
going to let's say input group okay we
are going to uh I mean okay yeah we're
going to import this and then inside
I'll just paste this input which is the
password so for the type I'm going to
cut this and before that I'll just
create a state that says
const show password and satual password
initially it is going to be false so the
type is going to be depending on that
state so I'm going to cut this and I'll
say if we are showing the password then
the type is going to be text and if you
are not showing the password the type is
going to be the password so that it is
uh invisible so for the value it is just
going to be inputs. password and when we
uh change it okay on change event fliers
we're going to be changing the password
and lastly let's just say the size is
just going to be small and I will copy
this line and I'll just paste it to each
input because we have multiple inputs so
they should be in the size of small so
that they fit in the screen okay we
could save this and before that now we
have added input group and we put the
input and why did we addit this it is
because we're going to show a button
when we click that it is either going to
show us the password or is going to hide
it okay so we could say input write
element and all of them are coming from
the chakra documentation so if you want
to check that out just ask the input
group and input right element and you're
going to see the exact same thing so I
will just have the height of full for
this and in the right element we're just
going to have a button so let's get the
button it is going to have variant of
ghost uh uh if I can type okay it's
going to be ghost and then size is going
to be small and when we click to this
it's say onclick we are going to call
this Anonymous function which takes the
set show password and just negate the
value okay so let's say show password
and then inside the button um we are
going to just have two different uh
icons so I'll just come to here and I'll
just say if we are showing the password
we are going to say
we icon which is coming from uh from the
chakra icons and then in the other case
we'll just say
VI okay it should be whe off icon okay
so let's uh have it like this and then I
think we can save this and let's see how
that look like so we are going to go
into the all form we could delete this
inputs we are going to delete this
inputs as well because we took them into
their own uh so to say comp components
we're going to delete this as well so
also we forgot to take this button and
put it into the sign up so after the
input group we are going to have this
button that says sign up right so you're
going to see what we're doing now I'm
going to save this and let's delete this
and we're just going to here we'll just
put so if it is login right this state
says initially we are in the login page
if if if so like we'll just say login
show us this login component but if it
is not in the login State then we're
just going to show the signup component
let's import that as well and now let's
save this file and let's take a look so
here I'll
refresh so the login is true now okay so
we see the email and password when we
click to the sign up it changes right we
see email username full name password as
well as the button so if I put some
password here and if I click that now
now the type of this input is text and
if I click that again type of it is
password so that this is kind of like
secret and in the signup form we have
this sign up button and in the login
form we have this login button and these
inputs are bigger than this one so let's
make them smaller so that we are
consistent okay we're going to go into
here into login let's say size should be
small and size of this also should be
small let's save and let's take a look
okay now it's better I think and we
would like to take this uh button okay
this login icon as well as this text
into its own component which we created
so Google o it is going to be so here it
is this one okay I'm going to just cut
this and import the Google out instead
and now let's go into the Google out
we're just going to paste it like this
let's get the flex as well as the image
and the the text um okay there is a
problem let's see we're going to import
the image and then the text okay if we
just save and let's save here now the
output is exactly the same but now it is
uh in its own component which is the
Google off now we can put the Google out
logic into here and login logic into
here and sign up logic into this
component so that this o form is looking
really clean so let's delete this button
and input because we're not using them
so let's see we can save this and now I
think it is time to build the sign up
functionality first and then we're going
to build the login as well as Google off
so I don't really want to put all this
signup logic into here but instead I
just want to create a hook so for this
I'll just go into the source create a
folder called Hooks and then inside the
hooks let's create our first hook which
is going to be used so it has to start
with with the use keyword so that react
knows this is a custom hook so I'll just
say use sign up
with email and
password. JS okay the name is kind of
long but it is self-explanatory so we
could just say rafc to get the boiler
plate but this is not going to return
any HTML it is going to actually be
returning some object with values so
let's say an empty object for now but
now how are we're going to do the uh so
to say authentication so let's say I
don't know how to do this but I know
that I'm going to be using Firebase so
we have this um the package that we
installed do you remember the name so it
was react Firebase hooks let's go into
Google and say react Firebase hooks
authentication okay so we're going to go
into here this is the mpm uh so say
npmjs.com so we're going to go into the
repository and the get GitHub and then
we could close this so there are a
couple of services that it provides so
fire store functions all of them but
we're just going to be using the
authentication so we could click that
and there are almost every every single
example that you can see here now we
would like to create an account with
email and password so I'm going to click
to this and there we go now it it gives
us a full example okay so you just call
this as a hook and put the
authentication object that we created
and it's going to give us the error
State loading State user credentials and
that function that actually creates the
user with email and password so we could
use the Firebase documentation to do
this if we don't use this package at all
we could still can do the authentication
but this makes our code really clean
because it gives us the loading State
error State user State and the function
itself so that's why I prefer to choose
this one but you can um still do this
operation without using this package so
I'm going to just actually copy this and
I go here into this sign up hook and I'm
going to just paste it to here okay so
here let's import this it doesn't gives
us so let's import the O which is coming
from the Firebase that we have created
here right this is the authentication
Service that we're going to be using and
then let's go into the Chrome and copy
this import which is coming from our
package so we could replace it with the
import and now we got the error State
loading in user as well as the function
so now when we want to use this hook we
are going to just come to here let's say
use sign up I mean yeah it was the use
sign up with email and password so this
is going to just return us some values
so let's say const it's going to return
us the loading State the error state if
there is any and then the sign up
function that we're going to be calling
to sign up the user so let's say when we
clict to the sign up button we'll just
say on
click call the signup function with our
inputs now we need to just create this
signup function into this U signup hook
okay so we're going to come to here and
in the return let's say uh just return
the loading State the error State and
then the sign up function that we're
going to create so let's say const sign
up which is going to be an async
function so async it is going to be
looking like this then it's going to
have a TR catch block so for now we
could just ignore the catch and just say
console.log the errors if there is any
but we're going to be handling that soon
okay so let's say before we even try to
sign this user up so this is going to be
taking the inputs by the way right so
we'll just say if any input is empty
then just show some error then then just
return out of this fun function so I'll
just say if
inputs. email is empty which we could
just put a question mark Or if inputs.
password is empty right or inputs.
username is empty or the full name is
empty so
inputs. full name if this is the case
then let's just console The Log please F
all the fields and then just return so
which means that it is is not going to
run this Tri block okay but if this is
not the case then we're just going to go
into the try so I'll just say
con
new it should be like this new user
which is going to be equal to a wait so
let's take a look at the documentation
so when they collected this register
button they are calling the create user
with email and password and they are
passing the email as well as the
password so we're going to be calling
this exact function so I'll just copy
this actually then which is this
function that we're getting from this
hook so we'll say await create user with
email and password and then pass the
email as well as the password so if this
is successful then it is going to return
us the new user okay so inside we'll
just say let's check if there is any
errors so if there is not new user and
if the error we have then we'll just say
console do log the error and just return
out this function again but if this is
not the case if we have this new user
okay if this has been created in the
authentication so this is the diagram
that we need to go so if when we sign up
the user is going to be created in the
authentication Service but we need to
also create it in the fir store service
so that we have something like this
document right so we're going to check
the followers the following counts and
all these thing that you can see in the
screen so that's why we're going to come
back to here and we'll say if this user
has been created in the authentication
system now we would like to create a
user document in the fire store as well
so let's say if this is the case const
let's say user
document and then it is going to be an
object and it is just going to have this
Fields so the user ID we could say new
user
okay dot it has a field called user and
it has the user ID so comma we're going
to have the email which is coming from
our inputs we're going to have the
username which is again coming from the
inputs as well as the full name which is
also coming from the inputs and then
we're going to store the bio so let's
say biography of this user and initially
it could be empty string and then user
can edit it once uh once you logged in
so we'll just say the profile picture
URL is also going to be empty string so
this user doesn't have a profile picture
and then the followers it is going to be
an empty array Following also going to
be an empty array as well as posts so
this user has zero post when they log in
or they sign up uh in the first time so
we say create at field is just going to
be data now so that we can show
something like uh this user is member
since let's say 20 and 23 and then just
put the date so we are going to create
this user document in our Firebase uh I
mean fire store and let's say you don't
know how to do that we're going to go
into Google and we'll just say fir store
add a
document so we could click to this one
and it is going to show us the
documentation which is really really
well structured and easy to read so here
let's see set I mean add a document so
here they actually show us in the first
example how to add a document so I'm
going to just copy this line okay we are
going to go into vs code and then paste
it up here so we're going to get this
set document as well as the document
method from let's see Firebase slf fir
store and this DP is actually going to
be our fire store object that we have it
here okay it is this one we're importing
and then let's see we are going to
create inside this users collection and
the idea of the user is just going to be
let's say new user. user. uid okay it is
this ID that we just created and then
the data is going to be this user
document this object that we are going
to create so if we paste this now the
user has been created in the database
and we would like to set this in our
local storage as well it is because
we're going to be using it uh later okay
so I'll just say local storage. set item
and I will explain once we use it so
this uh local storage first just takes
the key and then the value so we could
put something like user- info or maybe
you could say user Instagram or anything
like that I'll go with the
userinfo so in the right hand side we're
going to have djs. stringify and we're
going to just create this user document
in our local storage so let's save this
okay um I think we could save this file
I don't know why we're getting this I'll
just say okay so in the TR catch we are
handling our authentication or
registration now in the sign up let's go
here we are going to say in the loading
State let's show it in this button so
button takes is loading prop which is
coming from Chakra okay we're going to
say it is going to be loading if this
state is true and for the error we can
show an alert okay uh you will I think
just copy and paste paste it after this
input group and I'll show that so if we
have an error we're just going to show
an alert that shows the actual error
message so what is this alert let's take
a look we're going to go into chakra
documentation and let's take a look at
the
alert and this is in alert okay it has
this alert icon if you delete that we're
not going to see that icon but we could
put alert title description or just the
message as well so this is what we are
using Let's test it out now I think we
can save this file um okay let's go and
try that so we're going to go into the
sign up form and let's say email John
do@ gmail.com
username full
name as well as the password from one to
six we can see it like that and if I
click to that and let's see I think it
has been created so I'll just refresh in
the authentication and there we go we
have this j@ gmail.com it has been
created with this ID which which is
start with one PS okay so we're going to
go into the fir store database we have a
users collection and we have a document
which is this ID one PS which is the J
so we got the bio created at email
followers array so is empty following
array is empty full name posts array is
empty and these uh Fields as well now
let's actually handle the errors for
this we are going to be using something
called toast in Chakra okay when you
click that okay it's going to be
something like this if this is the
success toast that says account created
and let's see an error toast if there is
any so let's
see um let's take a look so you can
customize this as well okay I think they
don't show us but I know how to use it
so actually it's going to be in the
status okay show error show warning
success and info and basically this is
where I took the uh toast so from the
documentation and every time you want to
use a tost you need to let's go here you
need to call this function and it takes
this object so every time using it is
going to be pretty boring okay you need
to just put all these things but instead
we don't want to write that much code
every time so we're going to create
another custom hook so I'll just call it
use show toast. JS and let's say RFC we
are going to return the function let's
say return show toast and this is going
to be the function that we'll have so
let's say con show toast and this
function is going to take the let's say
title the description of the toast okay
description as well as the status so
either it's going to be warning success
error or anything like that so inside
this um we are going to call the toast
function so which we need to import it
as in the documentation so con toast it
is going to be use um toast right it
which is coming from Chakra UI react
okay so inside we are going to call this
function toast with the object so it was
taking the title right it was taking the
description the status as well as kind
of like duration we could say it's going
to be 3 seconds and is closable you
could say true so this is what we have
in the documentation so duration status
description title is closable ETC so if
it was an error let's see lowercase I'll
just zoom in a little bit and if I click
to that we're going to get an error tost
and this is basically we're customizing
it in our hook so we can call this
function now in any component we can
give the title description status and it
is going to call it for us so I will now
save it and let's just format this a
little bit like this we're going to go
into our Hook when we have an error
instead of console logging it we are
going to just call that so let's say con
show toast function which is coming from
this hook that we just
created okay so if we have an error
let's say show toast the title is going
to be error the description is going to
be please fill all the fields and then
the status is just going to be error and
then we're going to return out this out
of this function so now every time we
want to use an error we'll just going to
show this toast so error and for the
error State we could just put the error
whatever that is and then the status of
error now if we haven't created this
show toast um if we have haven't created
this show toast function inside this
hook we all always need to do something
like this we would have so instead of
this we would have something like this
that says the title we would just put
this error okay into here something like
this and then we would be taking this
description and then put it here and
then we would put the status into here
the duration let's say 3 seconds is
closable is going to be true and then we
would be copying this and pasting this
into here and change the let's say the
description with the error so you get
the point we are just uh saving us from
writing much code instead we are just
calling the function with the parameters
and it is handling that for us so I
think we could delete this line and then
in the catch we're going to be using the
exact same thing so show toast if there
is an error with the title the error
message being the description and then
the status of error so now let's try to
do this again okay we could save and
we're not using this user object or the
state we could just uh skip it like this
okay if you just delete that it is not
going to give you any warnings so let's
try to create another account um so
we're going to go here we'll just say
never and then sign up again and now
I'll just put the exact same credentials
j@
gmail.com
jandoo
now it should say us it should give us
an error that says this user already
exists so if I click to sign up let's
see okay we see the error it is because
we have this um alert right we showed up
here so if you have an error show the
alert but we didn't get any toast it is
because here that should be error.
message now let's try to do this and if
we have the exact same uh document in
our database so if the email is same or
the yeah if the email Emil is same we're
going to hit this if check which says
this user has haven't been created and
then we have an error so just show this
tost so let's save this and let's take a
look so if I sign up again it is going
to show the alert as well as the show
toast and if we take a look at in our
database that we're going to see this
user hasn't haven't been created twice
and in our database as
well so now that we have signed up so
when you sign up by the way Firebase
immediately logs you in now let's handle
the log out so that let's go into the
homepage okay when we clict this it
should log out and when we clict to this
it should log out uh log log us out
again so let's first do the inside the
let's say sidebar we're going to go into
here let's just put a comma I mean
comment let's close this we'll just say
log out and then so instead of having
this as a link so we could just delete
this because it is not going to take us
to the authentication page because of we
have it as link but instead we're going
to be using this state so let's say this
is a flex okay so it is going to have a
on click function and when we click to
that it is just going to log out us okay
so we'll say maybe handle log out let's
say and this function is going to be
coming from another hook which is going
to be log out so I'll just say use log
out. JS and in order to Lo in order to
add this functionality we can again go
back to our so say documentation so
let's see we have this use sign out
let's click to that it is going to give
us this line I'm going to copy this and
when you click to this sign out button
it just calls it this Asing function
that AIT the sign out and then it says
your sign do so this is the logic that
we're going to be adding so let's say
rafc and then let's delete this return
statement but instead it is just going
to return the log out function that
we're just going to create so let's say
log out and maybe it should have
something like loading State as well so
logout slash
loading and I don't know if we need any
errors but let's just take it for now
and we're going to paste that line that
gives us the sign out function let's
import it all of these all coming from
our Firebase uh object so I'm just going
to shrink it and then we are getting
this function from this uh hook or the
package so now we're going to have a so
let's say let's say const log out when
we click to that logout button we're
going to be calling this function so
let's actually rename this to be
handle log out okay I'm going to copy
this and just change the name so it is
going to be a try catch and for the
catch we are again show the toast so
let's say c
show toast and then
use show toast which is coming from our
hooks folder and then here we'll just
say show toast which is taking the title
description as well as the status in the
try we're just going to do the exact
same thing in the documentation we're
going to call the sign not method and
then after this once it has been done
we're going to remove the item from the
local storage which was the user info so
that our application know this user has
been logged out so we could actually now
save this file and this is all we need
to do this is our use log out hook that
is handling the log out functionality so
we are going to go here let's shrink
this and we're going to be removing this
in the incoming sections so let's say
use log out hook call it and it is going
to return us three things so let's say
uh con is going to give us the handle
log out and and loading State as well as
the error and now this loading doesn't
make any sense like what is loading it
is not readable right so let's say
instead of loading I'm just going to
call this is logging out so when when is
this load logging out we're just going
to show a spinner and let's save and
let's just rename this as is logging out
and we're going to go into here instead
of having this as a box I think that
could be a button right so I'll just
change this with a
button okay it is let's import the
button from Chakra and then we're just
going to add a couple of different props
so we'll just say variant should be
ghost as well as the on Hover State
underscore hover it is just going to be
background of transparent so let's say
transparent and when it is loading so
when we logging out it's just going to
have this this prop so we we will just
get a spinner for that and the display
of none medium block could be still the
same so let's save and let's see if we
have something so error so maybe we
should show some errors or maybe let's
just delete this and I think there's
almost never going to be an error when
you're logging out so we could delete
that and if you wanted to you can handle
that but in this case I will not so
let's go here um into our application
now when we clicked that we would like
to say user logged out so for now there
is no way to check that so instead I'll
just say
console. log log. okay let's go here
open up the console and then if I click
to that okay user has been logged out
and it is successful but now how are we
going to make sure that user logged out
and take this user to the authentication
page and we're not going to allow the
user to see this homepage so for that
we're going to use the zent okay let's
search for it zo
react so this is the so to say the
documentation let's click to that and it
says that this is a small fast and
scalable Bare Bones State Management
solution using simplified flux
principles so this is something like
react alternative or context API but it
is just much more simple to use so you
can check out the documentation to
understand how that works what that is
but or you could just watch me
explaining it so in our case we are
going to uh go to here and let's Shing
everything inside the source we're going
to create a folder called store and this
store is going to store all of our
Global so to say Global States so first
we could have something like oath store
maybe oath store.js so here we are going
to use the create function let's say
import create from zent let's say zo and
I don't know if this is the correct
pronunciation but um let's just continue
so we're going to have something like a
um so say variable so use oath store and
this is going to call the create
function which is taking the set as the
first argument okay so this is actually
going to be an arrow function okay okay
and it is going to take the setter
function um if I can type correctly so
set close that and then it is going to
have this Arrow function now we are
going to have this state which we could
just say store I mean user and initially
it is going to be null okay so when you
first open up the application no user is
been authenticated so we are going to
have a function that logs the user in
okay we're just going to say log in take
the user whatever the value is so set
call this Setter function and update
this user State and we're going to have
the log out function which is going to
take the user and set it as null so
let's say log out is going to be this
function no arguments needed and it is
called the setter function and then just
uh set the user as null okay and then
what are we going to do is to use the
setter function so we're just going to
say set user and we're going to all
we're going to be using all of them so
if this looks complicated don't worry
I'll just explain all of them so this is
going to be calling the setter function
and just updating the user State
whatever the value that we're getting
and we have a warning let's see um okay
so this actually should be wrapped with
parenthesis so I'll just cut this open
up parenthesis and then return this
object so otherwise it is going to think
as if this is the function body and then
we just say export default the use oath
store so initially no user has been
logged in and when we sign up we are
going to actually update that state with
the user that we are getting okay so
this is the user that we have but we're
going to set this with this user
document that we just created so that
our state has this followers count
following count and basically all these
all these things so after the local
storage we're just going to let's save
file first and we'll just say login user
so how are we going to get this function
so from zent will actually say con uh I
mean equal on the left hand side we
could just say use oath store so use out
store and we are going to and it is
going to be taking this state okay so
this is the first argument and we could
just say state. give us the login
function okay so now we have the log
function and we could just rename it as
login user so if you want to get the log
out function we'll just do the exact
same thing we're going to call the use
out store state. log out okay and then
we could just anything that we want to
put here so you'll just say log out or
log out user in our case so okay this is
how we use the state or the functions
from the zent you call the create
function put the setter uh Setter
function as the call back and then the
state that you have and then any
function that manipulates this state so
in our case we have the login logout as
well as the set user so even though
these two guys are doing the exact same
thing I just created this set user
function so that our code will be just
more readable and you're going to see
once we use this function so let's go
here we are not using this and then
we'll say a login user with the user
document that we just cre created so
user Doc and then we can go to the
application so
app.jsx so here we're just going to say
const oath user we could say and then
we'll just say use oath store okay and
we'll just get the authenticated user
which was just user that we have right
so let's just close these so it should
be here so this is the state that we're
getting
okay so this is the authent
authenticated user and when we visit the
homepage so we're just going to say if
user is authenticated so let's say oath
user then we're just going to show them
the homepage but in the else case we're
just going to navigate the user to the
let's say navigate to the authentication
page SL
o and we're going to be basically doing
the exact same thing for other routes so
if user is not logged in so let's say if
there is not oath user then they can
visit the authentication page but in the
else case you're just going to navigate
them to the homepage so let's put it
like this and now if we save let's see
what are we going to
get okay now we are in the
authentication page because we are not
logged in let's go to here you cannot
see the homepage if you can see like
there's a flickering effect but it just
takes us to the oath page and we're
going to handle that flicker effect as
well so let's try to log in uh we
already have an account but we didn't
handle the login functionality so I'll
just sign up with another user let's say
Jan do
gmail.com okay so I've just put all the
credentials for Jano uh the password
username full name email I will just
sign sign up
and there we go now we're in the
homepage we cannot go to the
authentication page let's try to go okay
it turns out that we can actually visit
this it is because when we refresh the
page our state is null initially right
do you remember so here the user state
is will always be null when you refresh
the page so we need to fix this and this
is why we're using local storage we'll
just say Json
pars from the local storage get this
user info and if there is not it'll just
be null in anyways so let's save this
and now let's take a look in our when we
just try to go to the oath page okay it
is not going to take us to the O page
but instead it'll take us to the
homepage it is because it is checking if
this user has anything in the local
storage and in our case we have actually
because when we sign up we store that in
our local storage so here we have the
user info which is this user the Jano
and when we log out we are going to be
clearing this user info from the local
storage so I'll just click to this
button there we go now we don't have
that user in our local storage so when
we click to that log up button it should
take us to the authentication page so I
will go into here into the use logout
hook instead of console logging the log
out we're going just going to call the
log out function from our oath store so
I'll just say C log out the user and it
is coming from use o store right so
state do give me the log out function
which is going to be this one and it is
setting the user as null so that we can
update our user interface so I'll just
delete this and let's say log out the
user and just call it now we are
removing the user from the storage as
well as navigating them to the homepage
it is because in in the app jsx it says
if there is not authenticated user okay
it should be here I'm sorry if o user is
empty then navigate it to the homepage
so let's save and I have explained a
little bit too much but I just want to
just make it clear so if we refresh this
page there is nothing in the local
storage it takes us to the O page and
there is no way to go into the
homepage okay so there is one small
problem that we have here so if we try
to go to homepage I'll just try to go
there for one Split Second we're going
to see the sidebar here when I click to
enter so let's see there we go we see
that sidebar even though we are not
logged in so we need to fix this and for
that we're going to go into the page
layout and it is wrapping our entire
application so I will go into this
component and here we're checking when
should we uh render the sidebar which is
that if you are not in in the
authentication page but now we need to
actually update this so I will just cut
this okay instead of having it like this
I'll just say can render sidebar okay
and this is going to be a variable so
let's say cons can render the sidebar so
it is going to be equal to this thing
that we just uh cut or we copied and if
we are not in the authentication page
and also if user is is logged in okay if
user is logged in then we can we should
see that uh sidebar and now how are we
going to check if user is logged in or
not so we could do something like this
where we are getting it from our store
in which uh in the background checks in
the local storage but there is actually
even a better way to check it so for
this we're going to go into the Firebase
documentation let's scroll to the very
top and okay so we have this thing
called use o State and let's click to
that it says it is going to retrieve and
monitor the authentication state from
Firebase so there is a full example here
um in the background it checks if this
user is logged in or not so we are going
to copy this and let's go into vs code
and we could paste it up here and import
this uh hook as well as the oath object
so now this is the user that we are
relying from Firebase so it is going to
be null if you are not authenticated and
if you are logged in or if you are
authenticated then this is going to be
holding that user value so now this says
can you render the sidebar and it is
going to be true if the path name is not
equal to the authentication page and if
we have the user that is logged in so
now if we actually save this and let's
take a look here I'll just try to go to
the homepage again uh let's see okay we
don't see that flickering effect now and
it is because we're checking for that so
now even if we go to a page like let's
say the user page or the profile page
we're not going to see the sidebar right
it is because we are checking for that
if user is authenticated then show the
sidebar and in our app jsx we didn't put
any uh s to say Protect protection into
this route because because uh even if
you are not logged in in our application
we should be see um the profile of a
user we are not going to be able to
follow them or unfollow them so we we
will not be able to edit the profile
we're going to check for that in the
incoming sections but we should be able
to see the posts and the comments they
have and let's say the number of likes
and that kind of stuff but in the
profile page if you are not logged in if
you are not authenticated then we
shouldn't be see that sidebar in instead
we can put a nav bar here that says
login or sign up so for this we're going
to go into here into page layout let's
say const can render navbar and we
should be able to render this Navar only
if the user is not authenticated okay
and this is how we check for it and
we'll just say if it is not loading as
well so it is not checking in the
background and we're just going to say
if the path name is not equal to the
authentication page as well so it is
because if we go to let's say slash oath
so here even if I am not authenticated
it I shouldn't see that navbar that says
login or sign up because I already see
that form here right so it just doesn't
make any sense so I will just say if
there's not User it's not loading so it
just basically checks if user is not
authenticated and path name is not um is
not the authentication page so if this
is the case we're going to render the
Navar I have a typo here can render
navbar and I'll just copy this maybe
after this so after the sidebar let's
say
Navar and we'll just say can we render
the Navar if this is the case show the
navbar component which will'll create in
a second otherwise just don't return
anything so we'll just go into the
components let's say
naar and just create it
so at this point this is going to be a
component that only holds um so to say
um something like only styling okay it
doesn't have any logic at all so at this
point I'll will just copy it and paste
it so it's about 30 lines of code and
you can just grab it from the GitHub
repo and it's going to be into this file
and I think we are never going to change
this content at all so it just have a
container with a Max width and then a
container flags that holds the image
which is our logo on the left and on the
right it holds two buttons so the sign
up button and login button and it is
wrapped with a link so when you click
that it'll take you to the
authentication page so let's save and
then we're going to import this from the
components Navar and Navar jsx so let's
save this file and if we go to a page
like let's say
jandoo and okay there we have a problem
which is that they are next to each
other but the thing is we will go into
the page layout we we are going to
change this Flex Direction and we're
going to say the flex direction is going
to be column or row depending on a uh
condition so let's see Flex direction if
we can render the Navar then the uh Flex
direction should be column so that they
are in the uh horizontal uh Direction so
let's a column but if we cannot render
the Navar then it should be in the wrong
direction let's save and I think that
should fix the problem so there we go
now we see the uh Navar at the top and
our content at the bottom so this
content is not centered so for this
we're going to go into here and let's
say the margin X could be just Auto and
if we save now we're going to see that
this is been centered as well and I
think we could delete this with because
we already have this Flex one which
means just contain the remaining part so
if we just save that shouldn't be any
difference if we refresh um actually
there there is uh okay there is not so
let's refresh um okay in the loading
state it doesn't look proper so let's
just put it and let's see how that look
like if we just refresh okay so it is
just better if we have that with so
lastly let's do one more optimization
which is just going to show a loading
spinner while it checks if the user is
authenticated so I'll just say if there
is not
user and it is loading in the background
so when you first uh refresh your page
this loading uh state is going to be
true and this user is going to be null
because it will try to fetch in the
background if this user is authenticated
or not and this is what that really
means and let's make our code a little
bit more readable I'll just cut it and
I'll say const check if let's say
checking user
is authenticated and I'll just paste it
so we'll just say if checking user is
authenticated then we could just return
a loading spinner so I'll just say page
layout spinner okay so this is going to
be our component that we can just have
it at the bottom of our file so let's
say const page layout spinner and this
is is just going to be holding a flex
which in indeed has a spinner inside so
I'll just copy it and paste it which can
grab it from the GitHub again so I'll
just return this thing and let's import
this spinner and let's see what is a
spinner is so let's go
here so basically just a loading spinner
you can give a size a color and anything
like that so let's say size is just
going to be uh x large there we go so
now if the internet connection is really
slow then this will take a long time to
check if user is authenticated and at
that point we would be showing a spinner
to indicate the user that they should
just wait a little bit while we check in
the background and we're not using this
error state so we could just delete that
so this is going to be the page layout
component at this point we could just
save this and let's quickly reiterate
what we did so we are checking when
should we render the sidebar and when
should we render the Navar and depending
on that we are just rendering them in
our template so here we just change the
flex Direction depending on the nav bar
if it's going to be rendered or not and
we are just centering this uh box
content which is going to be the page
content and lastly we have an if check
that checks if this user is
authenticated and while it checks uh we
are just showing a spinner in the screen
so that if the internet connection is
slow our user is know that they should
wait a little bit so this is going to be
our component we could uh close this and
we're going to go into this hook which
we have a problem or let's say we could
do one optimization so here let's say
there is already an account called
Jano
gmail.com so if this is the case another
user try to create an account with this
email this will uh throw an error and it
is not going to create this user do
doent in the database but the thing is
if we have a username let's say j i mean
jandoo and another user come and try to
create an account with this username so
this will not throw any errors so
instead we should check it manually
because this function only checks for
the email if it exists or not so even we
try to take a look at here we're just
going to have a if check here and how
are we going to check if a user already
exists with that username for this we
are going to go into the Firebase
documentation and we're going to see
something like query so I'll just say
query fire store and let's say you don't
know how to use this we're going to go
here and let's take a look at the
examples so they have some simple
queries let's take a look so they are
getting the reference okay passing the
collection database and the let's say
it's going to be users collection for us
and create creating a query with that
and then they are calling a function
called get docs so I'm going to go here
and actually I'll just copy this two
lines okay and then I'll just paste it
here so I'll say this is going to be the
users rep and import the collection from
so let's see from here and then our fire
store so we already have it it is coming
from here and let's say it's going to be
the users collection so now we have a
reference to this collection and we're
going to do a query so let's say query
it's going to be the users rep and then
we CLA so let's get that and we'll just
say where the username is equal to this
inputs. username so this is going to do
a query for us in the background and
we'll just say const query snapchot
and we'll just say await
get docks and passing the query not the
get doc but that should be um so say
plural so we'll say get dogs and just
pass the query and this is what they are
doing in the documentation as well okay
so this is kind of give us a snapshot
which is going to be type of array so we
will just say if this is not empty which
means that this user exists so we'll say
if
query so let say query snapshot. empty
there is a property like this if this is
not empty then we'll just return an
error so let's say show toast it is just
going to say user already exists or
let's say username already exists and
then we'll just return out of this
function so let's save and let's try to
do this we're going to go here let's say
into the sign up okay so I'll just say
sign up with the email we could just put
anything so gmail.com but the username
let's say jendo which we already have in
our database so let's take a look in the
authentication okay we have the Jano and
jando so let's try to for the Jano we'll
just say um okay that was the email let
me show you the so to say
username okay let's see so this is the
jando but we're checking for the Jano
that query is just going to check if
there is a user like this so full name
we could just put anything it doesn't
really matter for the password one to6
if we just try to sign
up okay it says username already exists
and it just doesn't create it in our
database so let's refresh we had two
users and we still have two users and
that was the optimization that we just
uh put it right here and with this this
hook and this function should be
completed now and we have our sign up
with email password logic extracted into
its own hook where we are just calling
that with the function uh with the
loading and error State we're getting
and we are passing our inputs when we
submit that okay when we click to the
sign up button it takes inputs and just
do that for us so this component is
really readable we just see all of our
components HTML CSS and the logic has
been extracted from us so this is the
beauty of using custom hook
so now we can close this sign up and
this hook we're going to just do one
more thing before we get into the login
functionality which is going to be that
we're checking if user authenticated
from the store in which in the
background checks from the local storage
but it is actually better to check it
like this where we're getting it we are
relying to Firebase okay it is a bit
more safe I think so we'll just going to
uh copy that and paste it here so let's
rename this this as oath fuser and let's
import these get the oath object and
we're not going to use the loading State
we could delete that and we're not using
this store so yeah we are just checking
if this user authenticated and we we are
relying to Firebase and not the local
storage so we could just save this and
now let's get into the login function so
we are going to create another hook
called use login. jsx and we could say
RFC delete this delete this return and
let's just get our boiler plate so we'll
just say show toast function to show
some errors so show toast import that
and then now let's take a look how do we
even log in so let's go to the
documentation so we're looking something
like sign in with email and password
let's click to that it is going to give
us this uh so to say one line I'll just
copy that paste it and get this hook the
oath object and this is going to give us
the function the user loading and error
state so let's get into the function so
just say const login is going to be an
asnc function it's going to have a try
catch in the catch we'll just show
toast so let's say um error title and
then error message as being the
description
and then the status which is going to be
error and then in the try now this
function will take the inputs okay again
the email and then the password so
inputs we'll just say if the
inputs. email is empty or the password
is empty we'll just return out this is
function by showing a tost that says
please fail all the fields but let's
just take take this out of the try even
if before we try we'll just uh check
this if check and then we'll just say
const
user credential we could say and this is
what they do in the documentation so
when they sign in they call this
function okay which in turn just returns
us a user credential so we'll just say
const user credential await this
function pass email and then as as well
as the password which is coming from
inputs so if the email and password is
correct this is going to give us the
user credential so just say user cred
and then we'll just get the fetch the
user from our uh collection so let's say
const and let's see so let's say you
don't know how to fetch a document so we
can go to here and let's say get a
document so here I'm just trying to show
you how you can use the documentation
and I'll just zoom in a little bit
so here let's take a look so get a
document if we click to that it first
get the reference and then the document
snap so I'll just copy this let's go
here um paste it so document reference
import this fire store is going to be
our database the user's collection and
then the ID of the user which we could
say user cr. user property. uid this is
going to be the ID of the user that we
are trying to fetch so we'll say get the
dog and pass the reference so this is
going to give us the user that is logged
in so we're just going to try to set
this in the local storage so let's say
local storage. set item and the name was
user- info if you remember and then
we'll just say
json.
stringify which is going to be this
document snap and there is a method
called data that just gives you the data
of this um so say this document so it is
going to be something like this if you
are fetching this user it is going to
give us all this fields and we are
getting this by calling this function
and lastly to update our user interface
we're going to be calling this uh login
function which we have here so it takes
the user and set the state with it so
let's go into the use login by the way
that should be JS not
jsx okay so I'll just say const login
here say const login
user from use o store and it's going to
take this
state and give us the login function so
we'll just say login user it should be a
lowercase we'll just say Doc document
snap. data which is that document it is
going to be and at the end of of this
file we'll just say return an object
with the let's say loading error I mean
loading State error State as well as the
Logan function so we're not using this
we could just skip that by deleting it
let's save and there we go this is going
to be our function that first checks if
the fields are empty then just return an
error but if the if they are not empty
it is going to check if the email and
password is correct if so it is going to
fet the document set the local storage
and log the user in by updating the user
interface so now let's test it out I'll
just uh okay we already saved this so
let's go here um so we had an account
called
Jane So
Jano
gmail.com we just say 1 2 3 4 5 6 we
just log
in and we cannot log in because we
didn't implement it in our component
we're going to go into login component
okay we'll just say oops
um okay let's say con equal use login um
so say hook and then this is going to
return us the loading State error State
as well as the let's see the loogan
function so when we click to this button
that says
login um so here let's say on click just
call the login function with the inputs
which is the email and password
so we could have a is loading State here
as well is loading and we'll just put it
and then we could have something like
the error we had here so I will just
copy this and paste it before this login
um lugin
button okay so if you have an error just
show an alert that shows the error
message so let's save and let's try to
log back in again so
jendo
gmail.com 1 2 3 4 5 6 if so let's say
seven which is the wrong password if you
try to login it's just going to say uh
invalid login credentials if we are
logging with the correct one so from 1
to six and it's load it loads and there
we go now we are in the homepage let's
see in our so application in the local
storage we have this user info and the
value is this state that we have here so
we can also log out from here but we
would like to add that log out
functionality to here as well so for
this we're going to go into this
suggested header okay that was the
component and when we click the logout
uh button that was a link but that
shouldn't be really that was for only
design part now we could delete this
okay and let's see what are we going to
do so let's say this is actually going
to be a button that has so let's say
size of X small small and then
background of transparent maybe I should
just copy and paste it um these two
lines background transparent and on the
hover the background still is going to
be transparent so font size 14 font
weight medium color and it's going to
have actually not going to have this
style because in button it doesn't
really need it so lastly we'll just have
a loading State as well as the on click
so we already had this use log out
function or the hook plus say use log
out which returns us I think three
states so let's say const give me the
log out function and the is loading
State and we could take the error but I
think it is not really needed so we're
going to go here and we'll say on click
to this function just call the handle
log out and is loading is going to be if
we are logging out and we could delete
this as well as this line so now in
instead of just having this um so to say
hardcoded values we could get the
authenticated user so say const o user
so use o
store
state so state. user so state. user this
is going to be our zand store or the
state and now instead of this we'll just
say oath
user. username and then we'll just say
instead of this Source let's say oath
user. profile pick URL so let's save and
we're going to add a bit more thing so
now we see the Jano which is a username
in this profile picture and let's just
remove this name it doesn't really need
it okay now we're just going to see an
empty user profile picture and when we
click to that it should take us to the
page of Jano so we are going to go here
and let's make this Avatar prep it with
a link so I'll just say a link component
which is coming from react ROM and we'll
just say to this URL so back Tex dollar
sign Cur braces oath user. username and
we're going to just do the exact same
thing for this
text okay let's take it like this and
then put it right here now when we
collect this name or the profile picture
just see in the left hand side it just
shows the uh the URL that it'll it'll
take us so if I click that now I am in
the page of Jano so let's go into the
homepage and if I click that it should
log this user out so I'm just going to
click it there we go it is not in the
local storage and now we're in the
authentication page so again this is the
beauty of using a custom hook we didn't
write this logic from scratch and we
just reuse it in this component as well
as that sidebar component so lastly
let's just handle this Google
authentication and then it should be
completed but first let's fix something
so if you are in this sign up I just
want to have this text that says sign up
with Google and if I am the I am in the
login it should say login with Google so
in our case it just has login so we can
change this with a prop so I'll just say
prefix okay and change this with the
prefix okay and when are we calling this
o form inside s form we're just going to
show a prefix that says if it is the
login okay then we'll just say log in
and in the else case which means that
we're in the sign up we'll just say sign
up and if we just save let's take a look
now I am okay let's just refresh this
page okay now now it says login and if I
click the sign up it still says login
and I think I didn't save that so just
say into here if we just save so it says
sign up with Google and if I go to login
it says login with Google and it is
because we are adding that prefix
depending on the state so when I
collected this I would like to log this
user with the Google let's go into the
documentation again let's see how that
works so up here we have something
called um um so you sign in with Google
if we click to that it is going to show
us an example I believe so you sign in
with Google so I'm just going to copy
this entire line and we could create
another custom hook for this but we're
never going to be using it in other
places and if you wanted to you can
still create it but I think I'll just
put that logic into here so I'll just
get this I mean by pasting it import
this hook get the authentication object
and then let's just get the our boiler
plates so const show toast in case if we
have any errors so use show toast and
then we're going to get the login
function so let's say login user so that
we can update our um so to say user
interface so use o store and get the
login
function okay it was like this and then
when we collected this Flex which is
that entire uh container so let say
onclick I'll just maybe put it like this
on
click I'll just say this function
handle Google o and I'll just create it
up here so it is going to be an async
arrow
function it's just going to have a try
catch as always in the catch so this
just save to get this formatting show
toast uh that should be the title so
let's say error description and then the
status so in the try we're just going to
do the exact same thing in the
documentation let's take a look quickly
see full social example so when you
click that button it just calls you sign
in with whatever the provider is so I'll
just copy this and let's go here and
actually it should be this function so I
will just copy and we'll say const new
user it is going to return us a wait if
this is successful so sign in with
Google and if there is not new user
which means um so there is some kind of
error and let's even check for that if
there is error then just show a tost
that shows the error message and then
return out of it so here we'll just
check if this is successful which you
could say if there is new user we're
just going to create a user document as
we did up here so I think I can just
copy this and actually we can even copy
this because we're going to be uh
setting this document into our
collection and we're going to be setting
that into local storage as well as
logging the user in so I'm going to copy
this entire thing and then just paste it
but the thing is now we don't have any
inputs because we are logging
with Google so the email could be new
user.
user. email so let's see if there is in
yes that we can see here the username is
going to be something like this so let's
say if this is the email so jando
gmail.com we're just going to take this
part and make that username so we can
achieve this by using something called
split and I think I'll just copy it and
paste
it okay so it takes the email of the
user split it from here this add symbol
and it just returns you the first part
which is here okay so now this is the
username it is going to be let's say
jandoo and for the full name we could
just take the full name uh from the
Google account we'll just say new user
okay that should be new user. user.
display name so this is coming from
Google as well uh for the profile
picture we could take the profile
picture of this user by doing something
like this from the user object there is
photo URL and the rest is just going to
be the same no biography no followers no
following no posts and the create that
is just going to be uh dat. now so let's
get the set document the document as
well as the fir store object or the
database
instance and also we could just delete
this comment as well as this one and
we're not using this user or the loading
State okay we could just ignore it and
yeah that should be it and even if you
are signing up or you're logging in that
doesn't really matter you could use this
function and it is going to either sign
you up if you don't have an account or
if you have already it'll just uh sign
in okay so we could save and let's test
it out I will go into here um into the
project if I I click to this it is going
to ask me this thing so let's see I'll
just choose it and now I don't have an
account but it'll just sign me up so
there we go this is the user info that
we got and in the console we have an
error so let's see but first let's check
it here so we got this
user okay so this is my account and if
you go into the authentication there we
go we see this is the provider which is
the Google and this is the user that is
just logged in or the signed up so let's
go here and check for the errors so here
we have the cannot read properties of
null so I think the oath user is not
defined so let's see so inside the
suggested header let's go there so just
say
suggested header and so while this is
null it still tries to get the username
or user profile picture and things like
that so we could say if the oath user is
empty then just return null and once
this is available then we just going to
return this content so let's save and
there we go now we got the um so let's
just refresh again okay we got the
username as well as the profile picture
and then this log up button so
everything works fine now so we just had
an error in the console and I just
refreshed the page now it works it shows
me this profile p picture that is coming
from Google and in your case if you
still get that error so here's the
solution I just asked it to uh stack
Overflow and a guy just posted this you
need to just copy this entire line and
then go into the HTML page so it's going
to be index at HTML and just paste that
to here and that should be working fine
okay so now you should be seeing that
Google profile picture so if we click to
that it is going to take us to this user
profile so I don't know if you have
realized but we have one problem with
the Google authentication it is that
when we first sign up it is going to
create this user document in our fir
store users collection but when we sign
in back so when we log in it is again
going to try to this uh user document
and it'll just try to create it in our
database which is not optimal because it
would be overriding that current
document with this one so instead we
should just make our code to realize if
user is logging in or they are just
signing up for the first time so how do
we going to do that is just going to be
we'll just check if this user exists or
not which we can check by getting a
document so I will copy this two lines
and then let's go here I'll just paste
it and I'll just say this is going to be
the user reference and then the user
snapshot okay so let's get the document
function we already have let's get the
get dog and the fire store so it's going
to be the users collection and this is
the user that we're checking so new
user. user. uid so we should pass the ID
as the third argument and then we'll
just say user reference now this is
going to give us a snapshot for that
document and we could just check it by
doing something like this so let's say
users snap. exists which is a method and
in this case we are not going to be
doing this so because this is logging in
oops I didn't mean to do this so we'll
just go here and say log in and then
I'll say const user document give me
that uh user object which we can do with
the data method and then we're going to
set this in our local storage as well as
the oath store um to this state so we'll
just say local storage. set item that
should be user Das info and then it's
going to just take this user document
and then let's say login user with this
user document it's going to update that
Global state so it's going to be this
function and in the else case which
means this user is signing up so let's
just put a comment sign up and then
we'll just paste what we have cut so we
are creating this empty user document
set it in our fire store in the users
collection and set the local storage
with this new user as well as with our
uh Global state so now our code knows
that if this user is signing in with the
Google account or they are signing up
for the first time so let's just save
and maybe we could give a little bit
spacing like this okay it just ignores
that anyways so now you can add other
providers which is like GitHub uh
Facebook Apple Microsoft Twitter any
kinds of these hooks that you want to
implement so I just let that as a
challenge for you but now we are going
to go next and just uh try to fetch this
data for the user profile and after that
maybe we could add this edit profile
functionality so in order to create this
functionality where we just fetch this
data it's going to be pretty simple but
there is one thing that we need to add
which is going to be another store
object or state and it is because we're
just going to store which user profile
we are checking now we are in this
profile and we're going to store that
because we're going to be using it in
multiple components so we're just going
to have that as a global state so we
could just share it into all of our
components with that one hook so let's
go ahead and create that user so say
this store so what can we call this I'll
just say user profile
store.js and press enter now we'll just
get the create function
froment so import create from
zent let's say so let's create this
store I'll just say const use user
profile store it is going to take the
create function call it with this call
back which returns us an object so we're
going to go ahead and then just create
the state I think we need to close that
off okay so the state is just going to
be the user profile initially it could
be null because we not visiting any
profile initially and then we'll just
say set use user profile and it is going
to take the user profile which is a
function so this is kind of like a
Setter function when you are having a
use state so this is the state value and
this is the setter function so we're
just going to say set the user profile
with the given user profile so this is
actually looking like this but we can
just make it a bit short and just delete
it so this is going to have another
function or method which is going to be
the ad post but but we're going to be
adding that later so now I'll just
comment that out so that we know how we
should be adding that and let's at the
end just say export default this use
user profile store so now we can save
this file and maybe close it and then
we're just going to create a hook that
fetches the user profile so that we can
show their data in this user header
component so we're going to go into our
hooks folder and let's say use get user
profile by username so kind of a long
name but again as long as it is
self-explanatory it is okay so let's say
rafc and then we're going to delete this
for now so let's get the boiler plate
since this is going to fetch some data
it should have a loading state is
loading set is loading let's delete this
and import the use State initially it
could be true because it's going to be
running immediately and then let's get
our show toast hook in in case we are
showing some errors so let's get that
and then let's see what do we have so
we're going to have a use
effect let's just initialize it for the
unmount initially and now this is going
to just get the user profile by the
username so what does that mean it means
that we're going to be using a query so
I already showed you how we can use that
which you can check from the
documentation so I'll just go ahead and
type it so let's have a function that
gets the user profile which is going to
be a async function and async function
and then here at the end we're going to
be calling that function and this is
going to have a TR catch in the catch it
will just show the toast with the error
message I mean show the error with the
error message and then before even we
try anything let's just say set is
loading to be true and then in the try
we're going to get I mean we're going to
have a query let's say query and this is
going to be taking a collection as we
show see in the documentation so the
fire store our database and then inside
the users collection because we're
fetching a user where okay a query takes
where Clause so where the username is
equal to the username that this hooks
get okay so
username I think this is going to have a
comma so is equal to and this is
something that we have in the
documentation and I think I just have to
show that so we're going to go here
let's say
query so here there are things like not
equal oops so here equals or not equals
so in not in and I think we're going to
be using a couple of these but um so
just know that there is something called
this equal okay and if you do it like
this then it just means not equal just
like we have in the programming so where
the username is equal to the US username
that this hooks gets as a Prem okay or
the argument so this is going to be our
query now we need to just call it which
we can do by wait get dogs and then pass
the Q or the query this is going to
return us a query snapshot so const
query
snapshot and now we can just check if
this is an empty uh empty snapshot or
not so snapshot so we'll just say let's
save so that we have this formatting if
the query Snapchat is empty which means
that this user is not found so we can
set our user profile State as being null
so let's go here use user profile okay
that wasn't the hook so what was the
name I'll just copy this at this point
let's go here use user profile store
okay now we need to import this let's go
here that was a default export it's
coming from here okay use user profile
store and this is going to give us now
uh the way we were using it up until now
we were getting the state and maybe from
the state the user profile or the set
user profile function and then we were
calling it here but if we just don't
pass anything inside we're going to say
con open up Cur Braes which we are just
destructuring we just get the user
profile and set
user profile okay so this is a new way
of using it that we just see so if we
didn't use it like this the normal way
that we were doing up until now would be
something like this so let me just show
that we would say the user profile okay
let's just delete here and then call
this with the state that gives you the
user profile but instead we can just
call it like this without any arguments
so it is going to give us all of the
values so let's just delete here and
then comment out this so if the query
Snapchat empty which means that user
doesn't exist so just return out of this
function and just say set user profile
to be null but if this user exists then
we're just going to get the data and set
the user profile with it so here is how
we do that so we'll just say let user
document so initially it do just going
to be undefined and we're just going to
go here and let's say query snapshot
which is going to have this for each and
then there's just going to be one
document but we're still using for each
because it is in the format of array so
we just say set user document with this
doc data and then now we need to use it
where we'll just say set user profile
with this user document so yeah
basically this is what we're doing and
here we have some warnings let's just
give a little bit formatting I'll just
save and there we go so maybe like this
it is better so here it says add the set
user profile show toast and username so
that any of these values change this use
effect will run again so if we just
let's just put set user profile username
and show toast now if we just put it
this show toast like this we're going to
get an infinite Loop error it is because
let's go here so this is a function and
on each render this is going to be
stored in a different place in memory so
we need to cach this this is something
related to react and I'm just going to
cut this function and we're just going
to wrap it with something called use
call back so call back call it paste the
function and as the second argument
we're just going to put the toast so
this basically caches so use callback is
used to an infinite Loop that copilot
says I think it listens us so here
infinite Loop and then let's say also it
caches the function so
basically instead of Also let's just say
by caching the
function okay we could save and now
we're not going to get any errors
because this is not going to cause a
infinite Loop and at the end end of this
hook we're just going to return this
state is loading user profile and we
have a warning here let's just delete
the react because we're not using it now
we can basically call this hook in our
profile page so let's go here into the
profile page and then we're just going
to call that hook up here so use get
user profile by username and we're going
to pass the username and how are we
going to get that so let's say const so
there is something called use location
and I think we have used it so far so or
maybe something like use prems I'm sorry
so we're going to use the use prems hook
which is coming from react router D so
it is going to give us the
username so let's go here import that it
doesn't gives us so let's go here okay
so we have the username and this is the
username it is because here in the
profile page we have this as a username
is this is the dynamic value if it was U
ID then we should come to that profile
page and then call this as uid okay so
this is what we are doing let's go into
the app jsx and change it with the
username so let's go into the profile
page okay we are getting the user
profile by the username and it is going
to return us to States so const is
loading and then the I think user
profile itself now if the user profile
is empty then we could show something
like user not found and go back home so
let's say if the is loading is false and
there is no user profile which means
that user is not found so let's just
make our code a little bit more readable
by doing something like this con user
not
found and then paste that so now it just
reads as an English sentence so if user
not found then we could just say return
this user not found
component which we can create at the
bottom of our file so I think at this
point I can just copy and paste that
because it is just 10 lines of HTML and
CSS from Chakra so it has Flex text
component as well as the link which is
coming from Chakra
and let's get the router link so import
link as router link from react router D
so it says user not found and go home
link when you click that it is going to
take you to the homepage and we're going
to be using it once we have no user okay
so this is going to be our component at
least so far so here we are showing the
profile header but we should only be
showing that if the user profile exists
okay so I'll just cut that and I'll say
if it is not loading and if user profile
exists then return okay and return the
user profile header but while it loads
we could put something like a skeleton
so I'll just say is loading and then
again I'll just copy and paste maybe 10
lines of code so it is going to be the
profile header skeleton and I'll just
put it at the bottom of our
page or the file and you can get that
from the GitHub so it is the profile
header skeleton which has Flex component
uh skeleton Circle and then two
skeletons in the vertical Direction so
we're going to go up here and then just
paste it and let's make it a
component okay so if it is loading we're
going to see this uh skeleton and if it
is not loading then we're just going to
show the profile header so let's import
this vertical stack and then the
skeleton now let's save and we're going
to go into the profile
page there we can see um it says cannot
get snapshot maybe we have some typo
let's go here get
snapshot okay so I just refreshed and it
is working now but we have this loading
skeleton for the rest of our lives it is
because we didn't set this loading to be
false in the finally block so either we
success or fail this loading stage
should be false and let's say console.
log the fetched user so let's say user
document and let's save let's refresh
this again we have this loading state
for one second did you see that let's
refresh again okay it shows us that
loading skeleton and then we got the
user document which is this user we are
checking from we are fetching from the
username so we got the profile picture
just basically every information every
field that we have so now let's go into
the user profile header and just render
all these information right and I have
added this followers in the background
so in your case maybe that would be an
empty array okay so if you're seeing why
this user has this follower it's because
I was testing off camera and I just
added that so let's go here and just
delete that sorry for any confusing that
I just made so initially it should be in
this empty format that we have for each
user and we're we're going to be adding
that follower I mean follow
functionality in the incoming sections
so okay enough talk let's go into the
user profile header so profile header I
think it was we're going to go here and
then just render this data so first
let's get the uh user profile state so
just say const maybe Cur Li Braes and
then user profile which is coming from
our store so let's say use user profile
store and just import that so this is
going to give us the user profile now we
can delete this name and as the source
of this image we'll just say user
profile. do profile pick URL and then
we're going to go into let's see this is
going to be the username I'll just
delete that I'll say C Braes user
profile. username so let's see what are
we going to have else so this is the
number of posts we'll just say user
profile. posts. length so since this is
an array we can just get the length and
this is the number of followers so user
profile followers and get the length get
the following and then this is the full
name okay so full name as well as the
biography so user
profile.
bio now I think we could save this and
let's take a look in the browser okay
okay we got the profile picture username
full name and number of followers
following in posts if we just refresh
that should be zero because we just
fixed this in here right so let's go
here and refresh that should be zero
followers there we go now we are going
to show this edit profile if we are
visiting our own profile and if we are
visiting profile of another user this
should be follow or unfollow button so
we are going to go here and if we are
not authenticated then we shouldn't be
seeing this button at all not the follow
button and not the edit profile so let's
have that if checks which we can again
just make our code a little bit easy to
read that we just do here so in the
profile page we're just going to put
this something like this okay it is the
if check into a variable so you're going
to understand now we'll just say const
visiting own
profile and authenticated so let's get
the authenticated user first const oath
user so use oath store and then give us
that user so we'll just say if oath user
exists and so if the user is
authenticated and oath user. username is
equal to the user profile that use do
username so if this is equal to each
other so if this is the true then user
is visiting their own profile and we're
just adding this o user to check if this
user authenticated so I'll just copy
this and we are going to wrap it like
this so C races paste this if user is
visiting their own profile we are just
going to show this button so cut this
paste this and there we go we are going
to copy and paste this thing again and
it is just going to say
follow button okay so that should be
visiting another user
profile another say profile and
authenticated and let's create this
constant or the E check con visiting
another profile and O So if this user is
authenticated in username is not equal
to the user profile. username so let's
go here and check that if that works now
we are there now we are in our own
profile so we see the added profile
button if we just go to the profile of
let's say
jendo there we go now it says follow
button and we are getting the user
profile of the chain if we go to the
profile of John so say
J there we go it is still in the follow
button and then the data of the John now
we could change the color of this button
I believe so we are going to just go
into here in this button and let's see
what is going to be the styling so the
background is actually going to be blue.
500 and then let's see color is going to
be white on the hover State I'll just
copy and paste it the background is
going to be blue 600 and save it there
we go and it didn't work okay so let's
just make the color to be white as well
so color should be white and now that
says follow button with this styling it
has hover effect and let's go into our
own profile so I'll just click to this
it says edit profile with this styling
so now we cannot see bio for this user
and it is because this user doesn't has
any so let's go here and add it manually
so if I just put something here random
okay and if I update that we're going to
go here refresh and we should see that
up here there we go this is the bio of
this user so now let's add this
functionality where when we click this
button we see a model that allows us to
edit the profile so I don't know if we
need to take a look at in the
documentation for the model component
but let me show that again so this is
the model where we just call this three
functions or import it from use
disclosure so I'll just actually copy
this and go here paste it import the use
disclosure okay I already did I think
from here and when we clict this
function or the button it is going to
call the on open so okay I think okay we
have some warnings it's because we're
not using this variables but we're going
to create a model so let's say edit
profile. js6 okay so here let's get the
RFC and then we're going to get to here
at the very bottom of our file we're
just going to say if it is
open if the model is open then just show
this model so
edit profile component import that and
it is going to be taking the is open
function we're going to be using
that and then also the on close
function give it as a prop so we could
save this file and then let's go here
before we just save this let's create
this small model so for this model we
can use something called the chakra UI
templates so let's go here and let's say
chakra UI forms template so you can go
to this link and in the forms
authentication at the very bottom you're
going to see this edit profile uh
component and if you go into the code
you can copy that and paste it into your
component just to have this exact same
behavior that you can see here or this
output so I copied that and I just Chang
this a little bit and make it uh make it
usable for us so I'll just paste it like
this and you can get this in our GitHub
repo so I will even comment this out and
put it at the very bottom of our file so
I'll just say copy and paste it as the
starter
edit profile model let's say okay at
this point you should be copying and
paste it so I will just put it as a
comment and then just paste it up here
so this is just 90 lines of code which
is just basic HTML and CSS that has some
inputs um form controls labels heading
stack and all that kind of thing that
you can take a look it WRA it is wrapped
with a model that is taking the is open
and on close functions or the props that
we're sending so yeah so let's save and
let's see the output so we're going to
go here in our demo uh um okay if we
just refresh I think we shouldn't have
any errors in the console when I click
to this there we go this is our model
that we see now we are going to add the
functionality where we can select an
profile picture from our uh machine and
then update this information and just
submit it so first things first let's go
ahead and add a state so that we can
take care of this inputs so we're going
to go here and let's say const
inputs and set inputs which is going to
be a use state with an object okay let's
initialize it like this import the US
state and give a little bit of space so
this is going to take the full name
username as well as the bio if you
wanted to you can add email and password
here and go just here and take a look at
how you can update the email and update
the password so I don't want to make it
any complicated I'll just go ahead and
update these fields and it should be
enough in our case so we have this now
we're going to go for each input and add
that as a value so we'll just say value
this is the username so inputs. username
and we just skip the full name so let's
go say value inputs. full name and
inputs. bio so now when we type
something in into this inputs we would
like to change that state so for this we
can add the on
change function so let's say handle
input or actually let's just immediately
update it right here so if we are typing
in into this input we are going to be
only updating the full name because this
is the full name input right so now here
the exact same thing but we're just
going to change the username so on
change take the event get the value from
this e. target. value and update the
username so let's go here and update the
so when we clict to this button where it
says submit so let's say onclick and
let's just call handle edit profile
function which we will create in a
second so let's copy this and by the way
when need click this cancel button uh it
should close the model I believe so here
it is we have this on close um so if we
clict this it doesn't close the model so
let's go ahead and add that so let say
on close
I mean on click it is going to call the
onclose function now if we save this
we're going to get an error so let's
just delete this for a second let's save
and test it out if you open the model
close it I mean click that cancel it's
going to close it so let's go here take
the handle edit profile function and for
now it should
only um the console log out the inputs
so let's say console log CLG the
inputs open up here so we have some
errors let's
refresh okay so this is let's say John
or let's just put something so like this
1 2 3 just submit there we go we got all
the inputs as expected bio full name and
username values we can do one
optimization so let's refresh and when
we open that model initially the input
values are empty that we can see here so
what we can do is just take them take
the value from the authenticated user
and just put it here as the initial
value so we're going to go here and
we're going to get the authenticated
user so const oath user and use um so it
was oath store right and get the state.
user so this is going to give us the
authenticated user where we can say for
the inputs the value is going to be the
inputs. username or if this is empty
then we can take the default value which
is from o user object so we're going to
do the same thing for this and for the
full name as well we always skip that so
let's go here now in the initial value
the inputs are empty right so if we just
refresh this there we go it checks and
get the full name from the uh
authenticated user user object get the
username and get the bio since it is
empty we just have this empty field so
let's
refresh so even though we have some bio
it just gives us empty for some reason
let's take a look bio here is empty and
maybe we are setting state in a wrong
way so full name
username and okay we didn't set the bio
or we actually did so let's console log
the bio I don't know why this doesn't
work so console log of user and let's
see so it is coming from
30 okay so bio is empty for some reason
it is because when we log
in okay so when we logged in that was
the state that we set in the local
storage and then we go manually update
it in here so that's why this is a not
really important error so for now we
could just ignore that and just know
that if we had a bio information that
would be here so we just have some kind
of bug because we updated that later so
anyways let's go in at this
functionality when we click this button
we would like to select an image from
our computer and just show it here so
how are we going to do this we can use
an input for this so let's say if we had
something like this input that should be
self
closing and then the type of of file
okay and then okay let's see so we're
going to just save this and let's go
here it shows this choose file button so
there is not enough space so it cannot
show it but if we click that it is going
to show us the pictures from our
computer so I'm just going to click that
okay so this is what I see but this
looks really ugly and I don't want to
see that instead I would like to click
this button and still see this window
okay so for this what we can do is to
just say this is going to be hidden okay
hidden and then this is going to have a
ref so let's say file ref we're going to
go here delete this console
log
const file R it's going to be a
reference okay it could be null and when
we click to this button it should
actually go and click to this input so
we'll say on click to this
button file r. current. click so when
you click to this edit profile button in
the background it is just going to go
and click to this input file and it is
going to open that window for us let's
test it out we don't see that choose
file button now and I'll just click to
this one and there we go this is the
window that we got so now what happen if
we select an image nothing happens right
we need to render that image here for
this we can create another hook and if
you have watched my previous tutorials
then you would see uh you would
understand what we are going to do next
so we are going to create a hook called
use preview image and this is something
uh common in react you would just create
something some hook like this and you
just call it whenever you want to render
an image from your computer so so we are
making this a hook it's because we would
like to make our code readable and
reusable because when we create a post
we are also will be able to select an
image from our computer so we can use
that hook again and again so we're going
to go into that hook and just try to add
the logic so it was the use preview
image right so let's get our
Ace this is going to give us a boiler
plate let's just delete that and this is
is going to have one state which is
going to be the selected file and set
selected file the seter function so
initially it could be null because there
is no selected file so let's say we're
going to get the const show toast which
is going to be for the error
handling and then let's say this image I
mean this hook only allows 2 megabytes
of images so we can just say con Max
file size in bytes so if the image is
larger than 2 megabytes we'll just say
uh maybe size is too large please select
a file less than 2 megabyte or something
like that so this is how we can uh
measure it in bytes so 2 * 1,24 * 1,24
so which is 2 megabytes and then this is
going to have a function so const handle
image change once you select an image
this function will run in the background
and then it is going to let's say const
file so this is going to take the file
that you choose from your machine and
then we're just going to do one check
let's say if there is a file that has
been selected and file.
type. starts
with image slash okay so this is just
going to check if this is an image file
if this is not we could render something
so let's say if and in the else case
we're just going to render a show toast
or we'll just show a toast so show toast
please upload an image file or let's
just say please select an image file and
we'll just say set selected file to be n
but if this is an image file we're just
going to check for the size if file.
size is greater than Max file size in
bytes which is 2 megabytes then we just
have we'll just have another error that
says uh file size must be less than 2
megabytes okay that that is a nice error
message and set the selected file to be
null just return out of this function so
don't run the remaining part which we
will add so we will create a reader okay
const reader by the way you can get this
function from the uh SE overflow or chat
GPD so it is really common function or
hook so con new file reader and we're
just going to add this function so
reader on load and it is going to take
this reader result and set it into the
selected file and reader. read data as
read as data URL and just pass the file
so basically it is going to take the
image file and convert it it into a base
64 string and then just set it into this
input so at the end of our file we're
just going to let's say return
oops so return the selected file the
handle image change function as well as
the let's say set selected file now we
can save this and remove this react
import okay there we go we're just going
to go into edit profile and let's say
here use preview image so this is going
to return us that values so con control
space handle liit change control space
selected file and control space get the
set selected file function now what are
we going to do with this function is
going to be when this input file so
where is it so on change so let's say on
change when you select an image that
function should run which is the handle
image change and if it is successful
then it is going to give us the selected
file as that um Bas 64 string which we
can put it here here so we just say
selected file or we'll just say oath
user. profile pick URL so this is going
to be that default value if user didn't
select any image so let's go here and
save this there we go we're going to go
here edit profile picture now we didn't
choose any so we have this profile
picture of the user if you select let's
go I'll just change I mean select the
John and if I open that up there we go
now this is the profile of John and now
if I clicked this cancel I would like to
remove that selected file but if you now
go here um okay it's already been
removed so maybe we don't need to select
that I mean set that so we're going to
go here I think we're never going to be
using this so let's just delete that
okay there we go and I think the only
thing that we left is going to be this
function that actually it is the profile
now we could put that logic here but
instead let's just create a hook and
maybe you could just take a challenge
post the video and try to add that by
yourself if you do do that now let's
watch my solution so use edit profile.
JJs so this is going to be our hook we
are going to call it into this file and
then it is going to update it for us in
the background so while it edits our
profile it is going to show some
Spinners or maybe maybe something like
that for that reason we would like to
have a state called is updating so you
can call this as loading or yeah like
loading is loading but I'll just say is
updating so it's just preference so
let's import the use State and then
we'll just get the authenticated user
because this is the user that actually
updates their profile so use oath store
and give me the user okay this is not
oath okay not o us but the user and then
let's go we're just going to take the
set off user oops maybe I'll just add
that in a little bit so let's just get
const show
toast use show
toast and then this is going to have
that function cost edit profile that
actually updates the users's profile so
this is going to be a kind of Long
Function but we will make it so this is
going to take the inputs okay as a
argument as an argument and then
selected file to update their profile
picture if they wanted to and let's go
here we'll just first just do the
optimizations or the error handlings so
is
updating or if there is not
authenticated user you'll just return so
when you click to this button okay for
one second it'll update and at that
exact moment if you click to the that
button again it shouldn't call that
update function again so that's why we
are just adding this we'll just say if
it is updating then just return don't
try to edit the profile again but if
this is not the case set up Ting should
be true and then we would like to create
an image in our storage right for the
profile picture and then we would like
to update the profile picture URL in the
users document so how are we going to
update or upload an image to storage
let's go here let say
Firebase storage upload so always just
check documentation so we're going to go
here upload from a string because I
didn't show you I think so let's comment
this out for a second so that we don't
get any errors and here let's say
console. log the selected file okay this
is going to be the file that we
select let's clear the console if I
select an
image so this is that giant string and
this image has been represented by this
long string and when we upload this
image to our storage we're going to be
uploading from a string okay so we'll
just take the string convert it to the
image and upload it to the so the
storage so let's take a look how they do
this so basically they are taking a
storage reference and then they put the
um so what do we call this they say
child but this is going to be the path
and you're going to understand that so
now we will say something like profile
pictures and then the ID of the user and
then the example that we're going to be
looking is going to be this because this
is the data URL string and this is the
image okay represented by that string
we're going to call this upload string
function pass the storage reference the
uh image message and then this data URL
as being the parameter and then just
call it and it's going to upload it for
us in the background so let's go here
this is how we're going to be doing that
um in the use edit profile let's contrl
Z and here we'll just have a TR catch so
now we are only going to be updating the
profile picture if there is a selected
file okay if there is a selected file
then we're just going to upload that in
image to the storage so let's get that
storage reference above the try we let's
give it space and let's say const
storage reference and then ref call that
get the storage let's import it and then
the path could be something like the
profile pics so that we know we are in
the profile pictures so this could be
anything okay but uh we need to make it
readable so that we know what is going
on and let's say o
user. uid so it is going to be in the
path of the user ID and con we're going
to get the user document R so this is
for another thing that we'll see so
let's say con document and get the fire
store
users so this is not the path actually
sorry that should be like this so users
collection and then give the user ID so
this will have that user document
reference for this user and if there is
a selected file a wait upload string
that we see from the documentation pass
the storage reference the selected file
and the data URL as oops as this
argument now once this has been uploaded
we should update a variable let's say
let URL initially it could be an empty
string so let's say this is the initial
value and once this picture has been
uploaded we going to get that so let's
say URL is going to be equal to await if
I can type await get download URL so you
can see that from the documentation it
just gets the URL of the image so ref
storage this is how you call it and then
from the profile pictures give me this
um this pictures URL so so this should
be fine and let's handle the catch we
forgot that show toast show a toast and
if user select the image okay we are
going to um so to say reassign this URL
otherwise it's just going to be empty
and let's create a object called
updated
user which is going to be having the
full
name as inputs. full name or if user is
not updating their full name you'll just
have the default value so again update
the username with the inputs value or if
the user is not updating their username
then we'll just have the username that
the user has and same thing for the bio
get it from the inputs otherwise get the
default value and for the profile
picture
URL if user has just uploaded a new
profile picture get that otherwise if
they are not up updating their profile
picture just get the old one I hope it
is readable and we also need to let's go
here put a comma Three Dots and oath
user now we don't really want to
overwrite the other data out outside of
this so the user had followers following
count created that and if we don't put
this it is going to delete all that
arrays and just put these for values so
that's why we are only updating the
these fours and just keep the other
fields as they are so I hope that makes
sense let's go await now we're going to
update this user document so update
document and how are we doing this let's
go into the
documentation
update document so just ask it basically
click the first
one then this is what we have get the
reference from the users and pass the
user ready from the users collection and
then call this update document function
with the reference and then the data
that it should update with so we're
going to do the exact same thing we got
the user document reference from the
user collection and then call this
update document let's import this and
then we'll say user document R and then
just pass this updated user object and
now we would like to update our local
storage with this user as well so that
everything is in sync with each other
local storage set item user- info and
that should be Json stringify of this
updated user now we would like to also
update the authenticated user State okay
so that's why we had something like this
so This set user does the exact same
thing with the login function but it
just makes it more readable that it says
this actually Updates this state so
we're going to go here and let's get it
I'll just duplicate this and let's say
set oath user and then just call that
set user function so we are going to go
here and let's say set oath user with
this updated user document and then we
would like to update the user profile so
let's say set user
profile and which is coming from use
user profile store right we're going to
get that function and call it with this
updated user so why are we doing this
and then this so we just like to have
every state in sync the user profile
State should be now this updated State
and the oath State also should be this
updated state it is because we are in
the edit page right uh okay so so when
we update this we are in our own profile
so that user profile State should be in
sync I hope it makes sense if not just
pause the video and think about it a
little bit okay and at the end we will
just show a toast that says profile
updated successfully with the status of
success so I think this is everything
that we need for this component right we
got the shos and everything up here
maybe we could just give a space here
save like this and then we're just going
to uh export this edit profile function
so that we can call it as well as the
updating State let's delete this
react and comma so let's save and then
we're going to go here call this um hook
so delete this const it is going to give
us the is updating as well as the edit
profile function so use edit profile
we're going to get that and this should
be let's say an Asing function so when
we click to that button it is going to
run this function we'll just say try
catch and in the try we'll say await
edit profile and pass the inputs as well
as the selected file if there is any and
in the catch let's say show toast but we
need to get that first so say con show
toast use show toast we're going to get
this with the error message show the
toast and then set selected
file to be null okay I think we should
get that from here and lastly we'll just
call that on close function so that it
close the model and and hopefully that
should be working fine lastly let's use
this updating State we're going to go
into the submit function and let's say
is loading is going going to be this
state let's save and cross our fingers
that it should work so let's take a look
at this document I would like to just
update my bio okay I'll go here and I'll
say hey this is new bio if I click to
that it loads and profile updated
successfully now we got that immediately
here because we have updated our user
profile State and if we take a look at
the local storage let's go Application
there we go now we got this new bio and
we also updated our oath user State now
let's take a look at the database here
this is the new bio that we get so in
the storage we don't have any images yet
because we didn't updated our image
right right or profile picture let's go
here and I'll just select one so I'll
just select the Bob let's say open that
up and submit
that and it uploads there we go so this
has been updated and let's take a look
here I'll just
refresh so this is going to be the path
that we had so a folder called profile
pics that we had here okay it is going
to uh put the profile pictures into this
folder called profile pcks and then
whatever the ID of the username so let's
take a look if we go inside the ID of
the user and then this is the image
itself okay so this is the name of the
image which is the ID of the user and it
is just created now so I think this is
the edit profile functionality let's
just quickly reiterate what we did so
first let's go into the profile page
right so let's say profile page so we
had this profile header and we are
showing this if there is a user profile
and also I forgot to show you if we just
go here and search for a user that does
not exist in our database so I'll just
search for it and there we go it says
user not found and go home it is because
we are showing that if user not found
then return this template that we have
at the bottom of our page so if there is
not user show that return statement and
if you are loading show this skeleton
and if you have the user profile show
the profile header and inside here we
were fetching this user profile
information so the user profile which we
are storing inside This Global State and
when we click to this edit profile
button we are opening that model so
which is this one and inside that we are
calling this hook which one is that so
use edit profile which in turns update
the user profile for us in the
background so it takes the reference for
the ref I mean storage as well as the
user document it checks if so if user
updates their profile picture if so
upload that into the cloud into the
storage and then update the user profile
with these values if there is any any of
these and then update the document set
the local storage set the authenticated
user State set user profile State and
show a toast that says profile updated
successfully and we are using this is
updating and edit profile return
statements or the variables in our
component so yeah that was it now let's
move on with the next functionality
which is going to be follow and unfollow
users so let's go to page of
John so here we have the follow button
if we click that we would like to follow
this user for this let's go in create a
hook and the reason is we're going to be
using it in multiple places so the first
follow feature will be here and then in
the homepage we can follow users from
this suggested component and then we can
follow and unfollow users from this um
post header that's why if we create a
custom hook that we can use multiple
times that would be pretty helpful and
let's go into our vs code we're going to
create a hook let's call it View follow
user and you can call this as use follow
and unfollow user but I'll just go with
this name so let's get the boiler plate
and delete the return at least for now
so since we are going to be doing some
asynchronous operation we could have a
state called is updating so con is
updating and set is
updating
let's get the use State initially is
going to be false and then we're going
to have one state that checks if we are
currently following this user or not so
let's say is following and set is
following initially it is just going to
be false and now we need to check in the
initial state if we are following this
user or not and that user will be the ID
so let's say user ID that we're going to
be following or unfollowing
so in order to initialize it in the
first render we'll use use
effect let's initialize it like this and
we're going to get the authenticated
user so let's say const um o
user use oath store and then get the
user from the state so inside the use
effect we are going to check if this
user is authenticated okay if oath user
is not empty then we're just going to
say const is
following is going to be a buan oath
user. following array so let's say
following that includes the ID of this
user ID okay if it includes this user ID
then it means we are following that user
so we'll just say set is following to
this state and this user effect will run
whenever the O user value changes or the
user ID changes and at the bottom we'll
just say from this hook return the is
updating is following and we're going to
create a function let's say handle
follow user
so and this is going to be handling the
uh following functionality let's create
that cost handle follow user and async
function we would like to get a couple
of more things so maybe we could just
delete this so that we can import other
things so o user and then maybe set of
user Setter function and then const
we're we're going to need the user
profile set user profile from our store
so use user profile store and then also
let's get the
toast
okay this is going to have a TR
catch and in the catch as always show
the tost with the so this is not correct
the title the
description and then the status and then
even we try to um So Def follow the user
we'll just say set is updaing to be true
and then finally this state is going to
be false now in the try we will would
like to do two things let me just show
you a diagram that I have here um let's
go up here okay so this is John this is
Jane the ID of JN which is one ID of
Jane is two now JN wants to follow the
Jane So when he sent this request what
is going to happen is that the following
array of John now will include the ID of
Jane and followers array of Jane will
include the IDE of John so now if we
just take a look at this picture we see
that John follows the Jane right the IDE
of two and then Jane has a follower
which is John and if it was an
unfollow then we would be removing this
idea of Jane from here now JN doesn't
follow anyone and then followers would
be removed from here and Jane doesn't
have any followers so that was the two
things first updating the follow
following array of the current user and
then followers array of the user to
follow or unfollow so with that in mind
let's get into the coding we are going
to get two references so cons let's say
current user reference and this is going
to be document and at this point I'll
just fast forward this because I already
showed that in multiple times from the
documentation so maybe you could just
take a look at that so fire store from
the users collection get the
authenticated user by passing the ID so
let's get this function and now we're
going to get the other user so I'll just
say con user to follow or let's say
unfollow let's say ref as well then
we're going to get document fire store
users collection this user that we are
getting as an argument and let's delete
this import from here and now we're
going to just update the document both
of the documents so let's say a wait
update document and now this is going to
take the current user reference and then
the object which is going to be the data
that you would like to update so the
following array of the current user
right so if it is following already then
we are just going to be removing the ID
so we can use a function from Firebase
which is called array remove and you can
still see this from the documentation
we are going to remove the ID of this
user ID and then if it is not following
which means that it is going to follow
that so we'll say array Union which is
adding that user ID into this array and
we're going to be doing the kind of
similar thing to the this user okay so
I'll just say await user I mean update
document I'm sorry so update document
pass the reference and then the object
so here we are going to update the
followers array so followers and it is
going to be if it is following then
we're just going to remove that so
array. remove the authenticated users
uid and then in the else case we're
going to be adding the ID of the
authenticated user so now we actually
update this documents in the database
now to to update our user interface we
would like to update these states which
we have have this in the store so set
user profile we'll take the new profile
and set that state with that and in the
oath store we're going to be doing the
same thing where in the set user we're
just taking the new user and set the
state with that object so this is what
we have let's go here and we're going to
have one if check that says if it is
already following so if this is true
which means that now we will like to
unfollow this user and if this is false
in the else case is now we are trying to
follow this user so we're going to go
here and then update the oath user first
let's say set oath user which we're
taking a new object let's say supet the
oath user fields and then we are going
to change the following array by
filtering it so o user. following.
filter so we could just say U ID for
each ID just check if it is not equal to
the user ID so we are removing this ID
from the following array of the
authenticated user and then we're going
to do the same thing for the set user
profile where we're just going to return
an object let me just scroll down a
little bit so we're going to just spread
the user profile and we're going to
update the followers array so user
profile. followers filter and just
extract or remove the ID of the
authenticated user so this is what we
are doing that I showed you in the
diagram and lastly let's update the
local storage so that we have our
applications state in sync with with
each other so let's say local storage
set item which was the user info and
then this is going to take the
Json stringify and then a new object so
since we are keeping the authenticated
user in the local storage we are just
going to take take this exact same thing
and then just paste it so in the local
storage we're going to have the previous
values of the authenticated user and
just new updated following array and
lastly the
set is following will be false now let's
handle the follow case it is going to be
looking pretty similar but instead of
removing or filtering we would be adding
them so let's go set oops set o user we
are going to just sprad all the fields
and inside the following array we're
going to add the new user ready and
let's do the same thing for the um set
user profile so set user profile and we
are going to maybe I would just accept
that okay we'll just sprad the user
profile and in the followers array we're
going to add the ID of the authenticated
user and lastly let's just update the
local storage so after here we just say
local storage set item the user info
take this object um close off close it
like this and then let's go here and we
would be just copying and pasting this
thing because again in the local storage
we are holding the authenticated user
which is current user right which is us
so let's go here and then now let's say
set is following to be true because now
we just handled that operation and
finally we said set updating is going to
be false we have that use effect that
checks if it is following or not and
yeah basically this is the entire
function so let's just save and quickly
reiterate what we did so we have state
for updating and for the following and
we are updating this following state by
checking if the current user following
array includes that user that we would
like to follow or unfollow so if we
already following that so which is here
we are updating the state to be unfollow
by removing it from the both arrays and
we also did that in the background for
the fire store database and then if it
is unfollow I mean if it is follow then
we are just adding those user IDs into
the both States as well as the local
storage to keep our application in in
sync so now now when we use this
function I think it'll be just clear so
for this let's go into the user profile
and let's just take this and then put it
here okay I think this looks a little
bit better so let's get the other hook
which is going to be let's say it is
going to return us const is
following is
updating as well as the function name I
think it was handle follow user and then
use follow user hook call it with the
user ID and what is that going to be so
in this case we are in the user profile
page so this is the user that you would
like to follow or unfollow so let's say
user profile.
uid and then maybe we could just put a
question mark in case it is null so now
when we clict to this follow
button on click call that function and
then it is going to have is loading to
show that spinner and now instead of
just follow this is going to be dynamic
so if it is following which means that
it is going to say now unfollow and if
it is not following then it's going to
say follow okay let's save and test it
out we're going to go into the
application so let's see okay this is
our profile let's go to the profile of
John okay so this user doesn't have any
followers and now we would like to
follow this user let's take a look at in
the database so this is us and I think
we removed this but maybe I added that
in the background so I'll just delete
that and let's go here in our profile
okay we don't have any followers or any
following and John also doesn't have so
let's see joho okay there we go so
followers following empty for this user
and then for the John it is okay this is
John it is also the same thing now if I
try to follow this user okay it says
cannot read properties of of of
undefined reading U ID let's go
here okay so the error is coming from
here we are destructuring destructuring
it from this use o store but it is not
called user profile but it is instead
called as user so we need to fix this
and I think I'll just delete this line
and just call it one by one so con o
user give me the use o store give me the
user and then the seter function so now
that should be working fine let's go
here and let's
refresh okay now that should be working
let's try to follow the chn I will click
to this it is updating and there we go
now it says one followers and the button
is unfollow let's go here now John has
one followers which is the ID of that
user and this user is following this ID
which is John so it is working fine even
if we refresh this page it is still
going to say unfollow because in the
initial render we are checking that and
setting that state so I hope it makes
sense now we can use this hook in any
component by only calling this line This
hook and getting these function and then
these two states and then just bind it
to any button or anything like that and
we're going to be adding this follow
functionality to the homepage later to
this component and then this one it is
because we haven't created them for now
and once we created the suggested user
in the pulse component we will add that
functionality but for now let's go into
the sidebar and try to add this search
user functionality first off we need to
go and update the sidebar component
because currently it is not really
readable because because we have the
sidebar items and we can't really put
all this logic into this component but
instead we're just going to create one
component for each of these items so
that each component has only one
responsibility so I'll just delete this
delete this icon and maybe search logo
notification logo create post and the
Avatar because we we are never going to
use that in this component so instead of
this sidebar items what we can do
um so let's copy this thing okay we're
going to go here let's say sidebar
items. jsx and then get that boiler
plate as always so here we are going to
create one component for each of these
so the home component search component
notifications create and profile link so
let's go here start with the home so
sidebar home. jsx
and the content is just going to be the
same thing that we just copied so I'll
just paste so it is going to be wrapped
with a tool tip and then it is going to
have a link so I think I can just copy
and paste that home component okay so it
doesn't have any logic at all you can
grab that from the GitHub link it is
going to be inside this home. jsx it has
a tool tip that is going to be shown in
the mobile
uh Dimensions or mobile phones in the
link we are going to take this user so
that should be coming from Chakra and
then let's import the router
link from react router D and when we
collected this link it is just going to
take us to the homepage that we can see
here get the icon get the box that says
go to go to the home so if we just save
this we're going to go here let's say an
empty react
fragment and then the first item we're
going to have is going to be the
home and let's import it okay so we're
just going to be adding all those
components one by one so we just added
the home and let's add the search or we
could just add that later and then we're
going to go and add that notifications
create and profile so let's go
here notifications. jsx get the boiler
plate and I think I'll just copy and
paste it and don't get angry with me
just copy and paste it it is because 30
lines of HTML CSS no logic at all and
this even has a link okay so it just
says notifications with the icon so
we'll just save and let's get it so
we're going to have a search here and
below that we're going to have the
notifications import
that um okay okay we already have and
after the notifications what we had to
have the create as well as the profile
so let's go here say create and it's
going to be the create post. jsx
actually and then the profile a link
that takes us to the profile page so
let's say get that rafc and maybe let's
copy and paste all of these again same
thing 30 lines of code no logic at all
that only takes you to the O page okay
so this is coming from use o store okay
and for the Avatar Source it just checks
if this user has a profile picture if
not just have it as an blank uh profile
picture so we're going to save and let's
go here by the way you can take all
these components from the GitHub so I
just need to mention that again we're
going to have the create post here so
create post and below that we're going
to have a profile
link so now I will provide you this
create post link I mean create post
component as well and let me just copy
and paste it okay so I copied that and
now I'm just going to paste it and I
will paste it again and comment this out
at the very bottom of the page okay it
starts from the line 36 you can grab
that and I'll just put a comment copy
and paste as the starter code for the
create post component okay so you can
get that from the GitHub uh repo if we
just save let's go here get the create
post and lastly we're just going to get
the search component and I'll do the
same thing so let's say
search
jsx and then I'll copy and paste it so I
copied that and I'll just paste it and I
will paste it again to here so that you
can have
it as the starter
code let's say which component we did
that okay I'll just type it down copy
and paste
as
okay copy and paste as the started code
for the search component and now we're
going to add the search functionality
into this component but before that
let's save this let's save
this import the
search save this file and then just
delete everything here put these sidebar
items
here okay do we have have any errors no
we don't let's save and the output
should be exactly the same as before but
now we see the profile picture of
ourselves which is coming from the oath
user state so now let's add this
functionality where when we click to
this button we're going to see a model
that fetches the user for us so first
let's create the model or let's first
create the hook and then we're going to
integrate it with the model so let's go
here inside the hooks that says use
search user. jsx or JS and then boiler
plat delete the return for
now let's have a loading
State initially it's going to be false
and once we call the function it is
going to be true so let's go here we're
going to fetch a user so let's say user
set user this is going to be the
searched user initially it could be null
and then for the
errors get the
toast so now we're going to have a
function let as C get user profile or
let's say search
user but since that will just return us
the user profile we could just say
get user profile sorry for for any
confusion so async function this is
going to take the username so Arrow
function the argument will be the
username and it's going to search it by
the username of the user so for this
what we can use as we did before we're
going to be using a query so let's say
try
catch and
finally set is loading to be false and
then in the catch let say show toast to
be uh
um like this where we'll just put the
error title description and then the
status and let's say set user to be
null because this is an error State and
then in the try we'll just say con query
and which was calling this query
function we're taking a
collection fire store the inside users
collection where let's import the fire
store
so where the
username field is equal to this username
that we are getting as an argument so
equals to the this username so let's
import that I think this is too much so
let's um okay it should be like this
we're going to import the we clause and
then now we can call this with the get
doc function which is going to return as
a query snapshot so call it this is
going to be the result if query snapshot
is empty which means that user not found
so if this is the case let's just return
out of this function by showing a toast
that says user not found oops so let's
get this and then what are we going to
do but if this is not the case we are
just going to set the user with the user
document so even though this is a for
for each there is only going to be one
user and it'll be set to this state
finally we are going to go and say
return these three values from this hook
and delete this react import save it and
we can go into the search so here when
we collected this search box or so this
entire thing we would like to see a
model so first let's build the UI and
then we're going to integrate that hook
with it so as we know so far the first
thing that we need for a model is this
three values on open function is open
State and on close function so let's
import this from Chakra and then when we
collect this entire flag we are just
going to call the unopen function that
is going to open the model for us and
after this tool tip we can just put the
model and at this point I don't know if
I should copy and paste it but let's try
to write it at least a little bit so
we're going to get the model where it is
going to have the is open so maybe I'll
just say is open and then it's going to
have the on
close and there is one more thing that
we can add which is optional SL motion
preset and if you just say slide and
left this will make the model to come
from the left side and we're going to
see that and a model is going to have a
model model overlay okay inside the
model paste it let's import the model
overlay from Chakra and then it is going
to have a model content so I'll just say
model content import that and let's give
a little bit styling so background of
black and border of one pixel solid gray
and Max width of 400 pixels and then it
just going to have a model header as as
well as a close button so model header
is just going to say search user and
then the close button will be that
button to close the model and then
inside we're just going to have a model
body which can have let's import that
padding bottom of six and then we're
going to have one form that has the
input field so form not going to have
any actions inside we are going to have
one form control okay I will maybe let's
just type it down so let's go
here form
control and then it's is going to have
the form
label let's say it's going to be the
username and then after this label so
let's
just so it's going to have one input we
should import that and it is going to
have the
placeholder let's just say something
like as a
programmer and then to get the state
from it we could use a reference okay
you could use a use State as well but
I'll just go with the reference which
are we are going to create and then at
the very bottom it is going to have a
flex let's go here after the form
control that says the button that says
search Okay import the
button and let's go here for the input
import it and onsubmit
we're just going to call that handle
search user so con onsubmit handle
search user now let's just create all of
these okay but first um okay let's do so
con handle search user we're going to
have which are taking the event because
it is a form submission so we just say
event. prevent
default and then we're just going to
call that function from our hook so
let's get that con it is going to give
us the user is loading as well as the
get user profile
function if we just call it like this
then we'll just say let's get the
reference as
well const search reference from react
user
ref and we're just going to call this
get user profile so let's say get user
profile with the input value which is
that reference we have here so if we
just save and then let's say console log
the
user so I hope it wasn't any confusing
we just created a model and have a for
that has an input and then a button when
we submit the form it is going to call
this function which internally call this
other function that we have created in
our hook which returns us the user is
loading in user profile function these
are the states and this is the function
and for the button we have is loading to
be that is loading state so that we see
that spinner so yeah we are keeping
track of this input value by using a
reference instead of US state I just
wanted to show you how you can use that
instead of a use state so you can grab
that value from search draft. current.
Val and once we call this function we
would like to see the user let's save
and let's go here if I click to this
model will show up from the left because
we added that motion preset and I'll
just open up the console now user is
null let's search for someone like Jane
though which we have in our database so
if I click that it is going to have that
loading state
okay it doesn't for some reason we'll
just take a look and this is the profile
of Jane that we are getting so which
means that this function works if we
search a user that does not exist so it
is going to give us an error that says
user not found so let's go here why this
doesn't have that loading
State
um so is loading we put that into the
button okay so maybe it is in the hook
let's go here okay okay before we try
we'll just say set is loading to be true
and finally it's going to be false now
let's search it again now it has that
spinner for one second and if the if it
was correct it's still going to has that
loading so now that we got the user we
would like to render it here and we can
use a component where we had like this
so this is the suggested user component
we see the profile picture full name
number of followers and then the follow
button to follow that user so we're
going to be using that exact same
component so after so inside the search
after this form I believe we're just
going to say that if there is user if
this is found then we'll just say render
the suggested user component which are
taking a
user and let's close that off import the
suggested
user
so it doesn't gives us so let's go and
import it manually so suggested user it
is not from here we should go one up
from the suggested users and then just
get the suggested user component so
let's go here so it doesn't take the
user it takes this because that was in
the design part so let's get the
user um if we do it like this we're
going to get a couple of Errors so let's
say user for the source user
profile pick URL we could just delete
the name and for the followers we'll
just say
user.
followers. length and for the name user.
full name we are fetching these data
from this object so we have all these
which is coming from the database so
let's say full name uh number of
followers username all this thing that
you can see here so we're going to go
here and let's take a look and for this
state we would be also taking that from
the hook but for now let's just save and
let's see what are we going to see I
think we are going to have an error that
is coming from the homepage so if we go
into the
homepage for now I will just remove the
suggested users so that we don't have
any
errors okay so we don't see that because
we remove that but let's go search Jan
do and let's search
it okay this is the profile of chain if
we search for someone like jando which
is
us uh okay it is not us right okay this
is our profile I forgot sorry if we just
search for jandoo it has one followers
and we are following that user now let's
handle this follow functionality it is
going to be pretty simple because we
already have that logic in place
so inside the suggested user component
we are going to delete this but instead
let's delete the use State as well we
are going to call that hook so const it
is going to return us is following
State um is updating State and then the
handle follow user function so use
follow user and then pass the user ID
into that it will was accepting a user
ID that we would like to follow or
unfollow and it's going to be this
suggested users ID and then we can have
the con oath user we're going to be
using that so I'll say use oath
store give me the user from this state
so let's give a bit space and when we
call when we click to this follow button
all we want to do is just call this
handle follow user function so Hand
handle follow user and it is going to
handle the following and unfollowing for
us and let's say is following then show
the unfollow text in that button in the
else case show the follow and the reason
that we are getting this o user is
because if we search for our own profile
so let's say this user we don't really
want to see that follow button for this
user it is because we cannot follow
ourselves so we're going to go here and
cut this button for a second and we'll
just say that if the oath users uid is
equal to this user ID which means that I
mean if it is not equal to this then we
would like to show that button so if it
is if this returns false then this is
not going to run it is because we would
be checking our own profile so if I save
now we are not going to see that follow
button because this is our own own
profile so let's go here lastly for the
button we just say is loading to be this
is updating State and let's save and
let's test it out so I'll just go and
follow the Jan so let's search for him
there we go so if I clicked
that now this user has one follower even
though it didn't update we're going to
handle that let's go the profile of Jane
Jane has one follower which is this user
and now this user following these two
users which is Jane and John so the
reason that number didn't increment when
we follow that user is because we didn't
update this state so we are going to go
here uh it is going to be this user
state which is the searched user right
this is where we set that document and
from this hook let's just export the set
user um Setter function we are going to
use this let's go here um we are going
to get this let's say set user function
and then we are going to send it to the
suggested users I mean suggested user
component let's say set user is going to
be this Setter function save this file
and then we're going to go into the
suggested user which is going to be
coming as a prop so when we clict to
this follow button instead of
immediately calling this handle follow
user function what we can do is just to
create another function so let's say on
follow user so I'm going to copy this
and just come here let's say const this
is going to be an async function so now
when we call this function internally we
would like to call this function that is
coming from the hook so that it handles
the follow for us in the background so
we are just going to say await handle
follow user and now we would like to
update this St state where either we are
going to increment the number of
followers by one or just decremented so
we can just come here and let's say set
user and the new state is just going to
be spreading the user and then the is
following I mean the followers array is
going to be changing so let's just go
here and format this
maybe okay we are going to spread the
user and then we'll just say followers
array so either we're going to filter
this or we're going to add the
authenticated users ID so we'll just say
followers if it is already following
which means that now we're going to
filter the O users ID it is because uh
we are unfollowing so user followers.
filter and we're just going to remove
the O users ID and if it is the else
case then this user got a new sub I mean
new follower which is going to be the
oath user and if we just save this save
it like this and maybe we should just
put the ID let's say U ID and let's test
it out so we're going to go here and
maybe I'll just refresh to have a clean
state so now we are following Jano so
let's say Jan though and we're going to
search so if we just unfollow that that
number should decrement it is because is
following is now true so which means
that this filter function will run and
remove this o users ID and the followers
length will be minus one which we are
showing it here so let's go and unfollow
and okay it did not work so let's see
why that is um so we send the set user
right let's take a look okay this is the
set user which is coming from user user
and this is the setter State or the
function and let's go here and maybe let
just say o user that shouldn't really
make any difference but let's test it
out so I'll just
refresh so let's see we are going to go
here let's say Jan do and then if we
just search Okay zero followers let's
follow and now okay it has been updated
we have one followers and if we unfollow
that that should decrement and this is
zero followers so this search user
functionality is also working fine in
future just try to take a look at that
in the so let's close that in the mobile
Dimensions it should also work fine
let's open that up there we go this is
the search user and let's just search
for
ourselves and we don't see that follow
button and the next thing that we can
build um could be that suggested user
component so let's build that first
let's just create a custom hook that
fetches the suggested users so let's
create this use get
suggested users.
JS oops we have one problem okay not KS
but that should be
JS okay so let just say rce delete the
return and let's have a loading State as
always so this could be true initially
because this function or this hook will
immediately run whenever we call it and
then let's get the suggested users so
let's say suggested users State and
initially it could be an empty array and
then we're going to fill that and let's
get the oath user you're going to see
why so use oath store and then get the
user lastly get the show toast
function so we would like to call a use
effect to fetch that users so let's say
use
effect so inside we're going to have a
function that says get
suggested users an Asing function and
we're going to be using collect I mean
query for this so let's say try catch in
the catch show the toast with the error
message and then in the try we're going
to do the query so first let's get the
reference so users ref this is how we
use uh queries so
collection fire store and then the users
so inside the users collection we are
going to create our query so let's say
query and this is going to be a kind of
long one so I will open up parenthesis
and then just go below so I'll just say
users rep and it is going to take a work
class where the U ID so we can use
something called not in which is from
documentation that I showed you
previously and the third argument should
be an array so uid shouldn't be inside
here so it is the oath user. uid it is
because we don't want to suggest
ourselves in the suggested user
component and also we want we don't want
to suggest the users that we already
follow so we are just going to say oath
user do following and this is an array
so it is going to be a n array for that
reason we are just going to put this
three dots to to get the following items
one by one so that it is not necessary
and then we'll just say order
by order
by with u ID and then lastly we want
only three uh pre users to uh suggest so
it's going to be limited by number of
three and then this is going to give us
a query Snapchat so let say cost query
Snapchat aate get docs past a query in
it and we're going to have a users we
say const users
array and then we'll just map through or
for each to push the user to this array
and we want to have the ID so I'll just
cut this so users start push and object
three dots document data so this is
going to spread that and we'll just say
the ID should be document. ID so this is
a really really common usage with
Firebase when you get a query snapshot
you for each that and for each document
if you are pushing into an array then
you create an object with spreading the
document. data and then creating an ID
getting that ID from this document so
that in react when you use map method so
you don't get any key errors so lastly
we'll just say set suggested users
should be this users array and finally
let's say is loading should be false and
here let's just say set is loading to be
true and then we are going to call this
suggested user functions only if the
oath user exists okay if user is
authenticated then just call this
function and the thing that we need to
add here is going to be the oath user as
well as the show toost function and at
the end let's just give a little bit
space we're going to return the is
loading as well as the suggested users
component so this is the entire function
let's quickly reiterate what we did
let's Del this react okay so we have a
loading State suggested user State and
this is initially true and this is an M
array so we got the oath user show toast
and we are calling this use effect which
has a function and this function is only
being executed it if the user is
authenticated and inside this function
we are getting the suggested users which
uses a query and we are making a query
to the users's collection where the uid
is not in this array so we don't want to
suggest ourselves so the O user uid and
then we don't want to suggest users that
we already follow and we put three dots
to get the elements one by one instead
of having a necess array so order by uid
and only give us three users and execute
this query with this get doc function
which will give us a snapshot and for
each that snapshot get the document as
well as an ID set suggested users to
this user array so this users array I
hope it makes sense now we're going to
be calling this uh custom Hook by
getting this is loading and suggested
users function I mean state so let's go
into the suggested users component so it
is going to be this one and here we are
just going to call that function or the
hook so let's say use or before that
let's say const we are going to get the
is loading State as well as the
suggested users array and then we're
going to say call this hook we're
getting it from here and let's say if it
is loading you could return something
like uh a skeleton or spinner in in my
case I'll just null but you can add that
so I'll just put a comment optional so
optional render
skeleton okay so we have this suggested
user component one by one which is only
for design part that we created so I'll
just uh Delete all of these and instead
I'll just say suggested users. map for
each
user call this or return this suggested
user component where it was taking the
user and as well as just set a key so
we'll just say user. ID okay so we have
a warning let's just delete this one and
map close that
off so okay if we just save we can't see
that because in the homepage we don't
show the suggested users component let's
comment this OD and then we're going to
go and let's take a look I'll just
refresh
okay we only see the Jano here because
this is the only user that we don't
follow and let's go and for the jle you
would like to unfollow that user as
well okay so oh we have one error what
that says so we are getting this error
it is because it is related to this use
follow hook so let's go here use follow
user and the reason is we have created
this fun function in a way that it
always update the set user profile and
we are only having this state if we are
in a profile page so now we have this
set user profile to be this user but
when we are in the homepage there is no
user profile that we are visiting and
when we do a follow or unfollow from
this homepage this is still trying to
set this state and in this case we don't
have anything inside the state so this
followers thing just gives gives us an
error so we are calling the set user
profile here as well as here now we need
to just um s say put a if check before
that so we'll just say if the there is a
user profile then just call this set
user profile and update it but if there
isn't only update the oath user and this
is completely fine let's say if there is
user profile and then just then call it
okay we we could save and let's test it
out again I'll just refresh to have a
clean State and we're going to go let's
say John do from here that hopefully
shouldn't give us any errors I'll just
say
unfollow okay now we don't have let's
refresh again so in the suggested users
we have jando as well as Jano because
these are the users that we don't follow
if we go here and follow one of them
so the suggested users component has
been updated and we only see the J now
because John is been followed by us
let's follow this user as well and this
has been updated again we don't see that
and if there is not any suggested users
we should remove this header as well so
let's go into the suggested user
component or the suggested users I'll
just say suggested users so here we only
want to see this header if there is a
length in this state so I am going to
actually cut this for a second and I'll
just say suggested
users. length if it is not equal to zero
and only then render this portion so if
we save that should be working
fine okay we don't even see that
suggested for you thing or the title
let's unfollow one of those users I'll
just say
call the jendle and unfollow that and
let's take a look now this is the
suggested user that we can see in this
component so with that we have created
the suggested users component so far we
don't really have any uh so we don't
have too much accounts so that it just
doesn't look any nice but if you add
other accounts so if you create and add
profile pictures maybe some followers
this section would look really great So
currently it just fun functions really
well it's because so let's go here we
only have three users so imagine you had
like 10 20 30 users here then on every
every refresh maybe these users would be
different so you would follow them
unfollow them and that would be changing
in like continuously so let's add one
more optimization to this search
functionality it is because whenever we
search for a user let's just say joh do
if we search that while it search this
state should be null so let's go here
and before we try to call this query
we'll just say set user to be null and
this will just reset the state and I
think we could save and here we have the
set user okay so we're going to go and
test it out if I just search that again
so it is null and then we are getting
that user and this is this slight
optimization that we just made now let's
continue with the create post
functionality so when we click to this
uh create post button we would like to
have a model to put our caption as well
as to select the image we're going to go
into the create post component and at
this point I will just provide you a
model so this is the first thing that
you would copy and paste to create this
component and then the second thing is
I'll just say two and and again copy and
paste for the model and I will just
paste it to here and comment this out so
that so that you guys can copy and paste
it from this file in the GitHub repo and
below this tool tip we're just going to
paste it and the reason that I'm just
pasting it is because we see that models
multiple times and I don't want to waste
any time to writing this components so
let's import all of these overlay
content header close
button
body text area input so this is going to
be an icon coming from react icons get
the footer as well as the button let's
get the is open and un close before that
let's get the icon and then
const get these from this hook so when
we collected this FL let's say onclick
call the onop function let's save and
let's take a look I will click to this
and let's see there we go this is the
model that we see so it has this Tex
area the icon and then the post um
button so this is exactly the output
that you can see maybe just uh 20 many
lines of code so now let's just store
this caption in a in a state so for this
I will create one state say
const
caption and set caption I'll just say
use state of an empty string and then
we're going to go here value is going to
be the caption on change we're going to
set the caption to the E target. value
and for the input so this is hidden okay
if we just delete that we would see this
choose file button so let's see where
that is okay it is here now we're going
to hide that and when we clict to this
we would like to open that window to
select images we're going to go we're
going to goad head and say hidden and
let's create a ref con file ref or let's
just say image
ref call the user it could be null and
when we click to this so we say on click
image R current. click and we just say
ref this is the image ref and that
should be working fine and what are we
going to do next now we also want to
render the selected image for this we
are going to go ahead and call our hook
which was the use
preview image I believe let's say let's
see so use preview image okay we are
going to call this it doesn't gives us
so let's import
manually it is coming from here is this
correct yes use preview image let's say
const three values the handle liit
change function select file as well as
the set selected file we are going to go
below the um this icon and it is going
to be here so below this we would like
to so we would like to render the image
here so let's go and say if there is a
selected file then render this right
hand side so we are going to have a one
Flags let's get it and this is going to
have a couple of props margin top of
five with full position
relative so
position and then justify content to be
Center and then inside it is going to
have the selected image so I'll just say
image as the source to
be so let's import that first from the
chakra Source will be selected file and
for the alt let's just
say
selected image and below the image we
would like to have a close button which
will just say position absolute and just
put it at the top so top two right to
onclick um remove the selected image
let's import this so I just copyed and
paste it maybe you could just uh do the
same or type it down from scratch and
let's save but we have one okay we have
one warning that says you're not using
this function and we're going to add
that into here so on change whenever a
user changes or selects an image we're
just going to call this function let's
save and let's see okay we're going to
go here and click to that
icon we got all of these images and
let's just select the chain and it has
been rendered here if we click to this
it is going to make the selected state
to be null where we just see that here
or MP string or null it is just the
exact same thing so let's try to do
again we're going to go here select an
image it has been rendered we can close
that or delete that now that we have
added the design for this create post
model the only thing left is to add the
functionality let's go into the profile
page and let's just think about it so
when when we create a post in this page
we would like to see that latest post in
this so like as being here and then we
would like to uh increment this number
of posts so for this we can use a global
state to store the posts we are going to
go ahead and create another store object
so let's say post
store.js and get the create function
from
zent and then we are going to have let's
say const use post store that was taking
the create function call it and the
Callback was taking the set function as
the first argument and then we are going
to return an object so parentheses Cur
braces and then we're going to have our
post store which is going to be an empty
uh array initially and then we're going
to have the create post function that
will take the newly created post and add
it into the array so I'll say say create
post which is taking the post calling
the setter function which takes the
previous state and then returns an
object updates the posts by getting the
first post at the top so that we can see
that post being here the latest one and
then just sprad the other posts so
state. posts and we're going to add a
couple of more functions such as the
delete post it is going to filter that
we are going to add let's say add
comment so that it'll update the UI and
then we're going to have set posts okay
let's say set posts and it is going to
be so that we can update this state as
well but we are going to be adding those
later so for now let's export default
this use post store and we're going to
be using this and then also in the user
profile store we said that we're going
to have a add post function and we're
going to use this so that we can
increment this number of posts when we
create the post so for this we are going
to add that function it is going to look
a little bit complicated but bear with
me so we're going to get the post and
this is going to call the setter
function um maybe I should accept this
so okay I'll just call the set function
and it is going to take the state as the
previous value or the first value so
this is going to be the state which is
going to be this user profile and then
we are going to return an object so
let's go here the user profile state is
going to be just uh spreading all the
previous
state and then for the posts we'll just
add the newly created posts ID so posts
get the post. ID and then just have the
previous posts so dot dot dot state DOT
user profile.
posts so this looks really really
complicated but basically let me just
put a comment here um okay not like that
okay this is used to
update the number of posts in the
profile page so when you create the post
now we have zero posts it'll be one post
and then it will be incremented as you
create posts so how how achieve this so
it takes the newly created post call the
setter function by taking the previous
state and in the posts array it only
adds one more ID so that when you say
posts. length this will be incremented
by one so I hope it makes sense we can
save this file and maybe close this
we're going to go into the create post
we can create a hook to create the post
or we can put our custom hook at the
very bottom of our file and in this case
this will be this is going to be what I
will be doing and let's go here let's
say function use create post so this is
going to be our hook so let's say const
show toast the boiler plate as
always it's going to have a loading
State initially it'll be false and we're
going to set that so let's get the oath
user use oath store give me the user
we're going to get the create post
function so let's say use post store
give me let's say just call it like this
and we could just take const create post
function so I think we have created it
yes it is this one and below this we're
going to get the add post function so
maybe we should say State state. create
post and remove this Cur Braes it is the
exact same thing so we're going to say
const
add const add
post from the use post store I mean use
user profile store because this is where
we added it and we'll just say add post
call that function and lastly we're
going to get the path
name and you'll see why for now just get
the path name from use look
so now we would like to create the
function to create the post let's say
con handle create post which is going to
be an async function it'll take the
selected file or the image and then it's
going to take the caption of the post as
arguments so we're going to go here and
let's first say if there is not selected
file uh we'll just return or let's throw
an error so let's say Throw new error
please select an image so since this is
an Instagram colone you can't really
post without having an image and then
let's say set is loading to be true and
then we're going to have to create the
new post so let's say new post which is
going to be an object so it the caption
will be the caption that we are getting
as an argument zero likes so likes and
empty array uh comments zero comments
and then we're going to have the created
at as well as the created by so created
at let's just say date. now and then
lastly create by which will be oath
user. uid now this should also have the
image URL which will'll add in a second
so let's get the TR catch in the catch
show toast um let's say error error.
message and then the status of error
finally we'll just say set is loading to
be false and in the try we're going to
do a couple of things so first we need
to create the post document and then add
the post image to our storage so let's
say const post
document
R await add document Quality Function
from Firebase pass the collection
from fir store the posts collection and
we don't have any posts if there is not
post collection it is going to create it
and add the document so the uh second
argument here will be the new post and
then this is our reference so let's say
const user document ref and then we also
add the post ID into the user document
so we'll just say document so let let's
import
that fire store users collection and
then ID which is going to be oath user.
uid and then let's get the image ref so
let's say
const image ref from let's say rev
storage and then get this rev function
and the path let's say um maybe back Tex
and then we'll just say posts slash and
then dollar sign cra says post document
rev. ID we could just say and that
should be nice if you I mean that should
work fine if you wanted to you can
change this path as you wanted to but
I'll just put all the posts under this
post folder and then whatever the IDE of
the post and then we'll just say await
update the document we're going to pass
the user document reference and we're
going to update the posts array so
object oops so post posts and we'll just
say array Union add the ID of the post
so that should be fine and then we'll
just say AIT
upload string so we did this previously
as well the image R the selected file
and in the type of being data URL so
this is going to upload the image now
let's get the down URL so just say con
download URL which will be let's say
await
get download URL and pass the image
reference now this post don't have any
image URL we would like to update that
both in the database and in the front
end so I'll just say await update
document and then it is going to be the
post document R and image URL will just
be this download URL we could accept it
like this and that should be working
fine and let's say new post this is the
object that we would like to update we
are going to add the image URL field
being this download URL and now we want
to update our user interface so we'll
just say create post oops not the create
function but the create post and then
we're just going to pass the pass an
object so new post and we would like to
add an ID so that we don't have any
errors when we render the posts so post
document r. ID and lastly let's just
show a toast that says post created
successfully let's export these uh
variables so not con but return is
loading State and handle create post
function so we are not using these so
this one and this one let's add them as
well um after we create the post so this
is going to add the image to this user
interface now you would like to update
this number of posts we're going to go
ahead and call this add post function so
it is going to be something like this
add post and then we'll just put the new
post so spread
that and ID is going to be post document
r. ID so let's give a bit space
maybe something like this so we have
this
references and updating this document
now we could save this file and let's go
above where we'll just call this
function use create post hook and then
this is going to give us two different
states so is loading in the
function handle create post so when we
clict to this post uh button let's say
on click call the handle post creation
so there going to be another function
that will create creation okay this is
going to have the is loading state to be
that is loading now the reason that
we're creating this function is going to
be so you're going to see so let's say
cost we're just going to put it async
where it is going to have a TR catch and
in the catch we are just going to show a
toast so let's import
that okay and in the try we are going to
call that call this function by passing
the selected file as well as the caption
so let's say selected file I mean just
call the function handle create post
pass the selected file and then the
caption so once this has been uh the
post has been created we would like to
close the
model say on close and then we would
like to set the caption to be empty and
then set selected file to be null if we
save I think that should be working fine
we're going to go ahead and create a
post so I'll select an
image let say
this is Jane and if we post that this is
going to have a loading
State and let's see okay post has been
created successfully the number of post
has been incremented we cannot see the
post here because we didn't fetch the
posts which will do but let's take a
look at in the our database so here this
is the account now this has one post
right the ID of the post let's
refresh so now we have the posts
collection if you click to that we have
one post which is created by this user
and that post has this image URL as well
as this caption let's take a look in the
storage it should have one folder called
posts and inside it it has that Jane
image right this is the post that we
just created so let's quickly reiterate
what we did so when we click to that
post button this function runs which
internally calls this function and it
takes the selected image as well as the
caption and here that function checks if
there is no selected file no selected
image then throws an error that says
please select an image and then if there
is then we create the post and then in
the fire store we are adding that posts
into the post collection update the
users document and then we are creating
an image ra to create the image itself
and adding that post into the post array
as well as updating the document with
the image URL and then we are adding
that post so that this number increments
that we can see in the post header and
lastly we have this create post that
adds that adds the post into the post
state so for now we cannot see this uh
working because we are not fetching any
posts but once we do that this will be
working and then we just show a tost
that says post created successfully so
now let's try to create an error so I'll
just create this and without any image
if I post this it is going to say please
select an image but if we just put some
uh caption it is still going to say
select an image because image is
mandatory one more optimization that we
can make is to when we are creating this
post we will just say if it is loading
and user still tries to click to that
post button we'll just say return out of
this function so that it doesn't
overload our servers so we are going to
save this and now it is time to go ahead
and fetch this user posts and we didn't
use this path name so far and once we
get there we're going to use that and
I'll explain so let's create one more
hook that says use maybe
get user hosts. JS so we'll say
rfca and then we are going to delete the
return statement that's going to have
con is loading
State initially it'll just be maybe
let's say true because it is going to
run immediately within a use effect so
we're going to take the posts so say
const so posts as well as the set posts
function it is coming from the use post
store okay this set post function is
something that we haven't created so
let's go ahead and add that so let's say
set posts it is going to take the new
post and update our state with it we're
going to save and then we are getting
the set posts and then show tost we're
going to get the user profile
because we're going to be updating it so
let's say user
profile from the use user profile store
and pass this so that it gives us user
profile and then we're going to have one
use
effect so we're going to go inside let's
create a function const get
posts async Arrow function that just
first check if there is not user profile
then we cannot fetch this posts because
user not found so that should be user
profile and then we are going to say set
is loading to be true and set posts to
be false I mean an empty array initially
and then try catch we are going to in
the finally let's say is loading to be
false in the catch we'll just say show
toast with the error message and the
then maybe we'll just say set posts to
be an empty array and then in the try we
are going to just do a query so we'll
just say const
query call the query function call The
Collection call the fire store inside
the posts so we're going to get the
posts
where so where the created by so let's
say created by is equal to the user
profile uid so it is going to get the
post of this user and then we need to
call this so await get
docs not doc but docs it should be
plural and then pass the query it is
going to give us a query
Snapchat Snapchat okay and then we're
just going to create an array in for
each so const posts query snapchat. for
each for each. document or for each post
we are going to push it into that posts
aray so posts. push and object with the
document data as well as the ID so again
this ID is when we use something like
posts. map and we were taking that post
and just returning some jsx if you
remember so something like let's say div
and this is the post. title and re wants
us to have a key here so we'll just say
key it's going to be post. ID so that's
why we're adding this ID so that we
don't get this key error so yeah this is
the reason that's why we're adding the
ID let's delete this two lines and then
so now we would like to set the posts
but before that let's uh sort this so
that the latest post is going to be in
the very top so I'll just say posts do
sort with the created ad so we're going
to get the A and B and this is how we do
it in JavaScript so the second one is
coming from the first one which will
just make it in the so to say like the
latest post is going to be here and then
it'll be going in descending order
lastly let's just say set posts to be
this posts and here we have let's say
set posts user profile as well as as the
show toast and oops and then here I
don't know why we are getting this error
okay so we just say return and is
loading as well as the post state so we
have some warnings Let's see we are
never calling this function let's say
get posts and then maybe give a little
bit
spacing okay we can save let's go ahead
delete this delete the get dock now
let's go ahead and use this post that we
are fetching so we're going to go into
the profile posts component and then
let's delete this we're going to delete
this is loading use effect use State and
for the is loading instead of showing
six let's just show three
skeletons and instead of these we're
going to delete that let's call the hook
so use um uh what was the name use get
user posts okay we are going to call
that let's say const is going to give us
the is loading as well as the posts so
now let's check if there is no posts
found so const no
posts
found if it is not loading and the post.
length is equal to zero then we will
just say if no post posts found then
just return a component that says no
posts
found okay it should be something like
this where I will just copy and paste it
five lines of HTML CSS at the bottom of
our file with
flex and
text okay it says no post found with
this Emoji we're going to save let's go
ahead
and here if it is not if it is loading
we're going to show this skeletons which
is the post skeleton and then if it is
not loading we're just going to map the
posts and show a component so let's say
post. map get each post and we're going
to return a jsx so here let's say okay
this is so annoying we're going to show
a
profile post which is going to take the
post as well as the key so now we are
using that ID where we added when we
were using for each
so I think this is going to be our
component we can go into the profile
post and we're going to take the post
and we're just going to render these
things so image is going to be the post.
image URL and let's see this is also
going to be the same let's say
post. image oops image URL okay if we
save hopefully it should be working now
we're going to go ahead and this is not
working let's see what is the reason
maybe we should console log the
post console. log
post okay let's see open up the
console um
refresh oh okay it is imagei not IMG so
it is kind of long version let's say
select these two and say image URL let's
save and there we go this is the image
that we have if we click to that we
still get that image in our model so
let's close that off let's visit a
profile that don't have any posts so
we'll just go to jle so zero post and it
says no posts found if you go to our own
profile one post and we see that now
let's fix this number of likes and posts
we're going to go into here and this is
where we'll be updating it so this is
the number of likes it says heart so
just say post. likes. length and same
thing for the comments let's save now
this post has zero likes and zero
comments and what we can improve else
would be the user profile name so let's
get that this is the beauty of using
zotin with global state so user profile
you can use this state in any component
by only calling this function use user
profile store and give me the user
profile where I'll just go down here
I'll just say user profile. full name or
let's just say the username and this is
inside the model if I save let's go here
this is the user username of this user
that posted and we'll just change the
profile picture um it is going to be
here let's delete that user
profile
do profile pick URL if we save we're
going to get that as well which is the
profile of this user and let's see if we
have anything else so for now let's just
delete every comment that we have here
we're going to add that once we get
there so for now maybe we could just
hold two comments and this looks good to
me now we are going to go into the model
this Flex where I just want to add a
couple of different styles so maybe only
two one we'll just say maximum height
and maximum width would be changing so
maximum height 90 VH and minimum height
50 VH so that it even looks in smaller
pictures as well and lastly let's take a
look we are going to add a couple of
different styles so that the image is
centered in our model so let's make this
a flex which is inside the model that
holds the image we are going to add two
more things justify content to be Center
as well as the Align items to be Center
so that the image is being centered if
we just save let's take a look now image
is in the center and in the previous
case was it not so let's take a look
okay so do you see it is not in the
center if we just added that two lines
so justify
content align items
Center and now it has been centered also
we would like to show this delete button
only if we are the owner of this post we
are going to go ahead and where is that
delete button so let's see it should be
before the divider okay it is going to
be this where we could just say this
should be a button and let's add a
couple of different styles import the
button and let say size should be small
and BG
transparent and then hover effect what
do we say Okay white Alpha red and then
border radius ping and on click to this
we are going to delete the post but more
on that later for now let's delete the
button and we'll just say if the oath
user. uid is equal to the user profile.
uid if this is the case which means that
this is the owner of the post we can
show that delete button let's get the
oath
user so delete this get const oath user
from use o store oops which is going to
give us the
user and we need to add one optional
chaining to that so where is it um here
in case user is not authenticated so
let's save and let's take a
look okay we can see this here but if
another user was posted this we
shouldn't be see that delete icon now
let's go ahead and add this delete
functionality for this we are going to
first go into the store which is the
post store and we're going to create
this delete post function so that it can
update our UI so let's say delete post
which is going to be taking the idea of
the post and it calls the setter
function so I'll just give a bit spacing
like this maybe it should be something
like this we're going to get the state
and we are going to return an object it
is going to take the posts but it is
going to filter the post that we are
just deleting okay it is going to check
where the post ID is not equal to this
ID okay it's let's say maybe we don't
even need to add a comment because the
name is delete post
we can save and let's go into the
profile post when we click to this
onclick let's say handle delete post and
this is going to be the function that
we'll just create at the very bot uh at
the very top of our file so const handle
delete post Asing
function it's going to have TR catch
let's get the show
toast
let's first add a confirmation to this
user we just say if pulse window.
confirm are you sure you want to delete
this post if they say cancel then we'll
just return out of this function but if
I if they say okay delete that then we
are just going to delete it so let's
have a loading state so const is
deleting set is deleting initially it's
going to be false and you could create a
custom hook for this as well but let's
just keep it simple and we'll just say
const so first we're going to delete the
image from the storage and then we're
going to delete the post from the post
collection and then from the users
collection okay so in the users
collection let's go
here so inside users collection we had
this posts array we're going to remove
that ID from here so let's go here const
image
R maybe we could just copy and paste it
at this point we're going to get the
reference we're going to get the storage
from the posts and posted ID so this is
the post that you like the delete so
await delete
object just pass the image R and then
const user R so document file store
inside users collection
let's just
paste this is the user reference that we
like to update we're just going to say
first AIT delete document and we're
going to delete the post document so
let's say document fire store and then
the posts delete this
post and then we're going to update the
user reference so await update document
pass user ref yeah user ref and then
array.
remove from the post array so we should
import these
functions and then in the catch show
toast finally set is loading to be false
I mean set is deleting to be
false and basically that's it we also
need to upate the user interface so
let's call the delete post function so
let's get that from our store const
delete
post use post store and we're going to
get this delete post
function and then this was taking the ID
of the post so I'll just say post. ID
and maybe lastly we could just show a
toast that says post deleted post
deleted successfully let's save and
let's test it out we are going to show a
spinner to this button where is it um
delete button let's say is loading to be
this is deleting and one more
optimization you're just going to say if
we are
deleting at that point just return if
user clicks to that button again let's
save remove this
box and test it out we're going to go
ahead
refresh so we'll select the post and
let's delete that it says are you sure
you want to delete this post if if we
say cancel it is not and if we say
okay and there we go post deleted
successfully and this number of post
hasn't been decremented we forgot to do
that but at least the post not found we
updated this portion so now let's take a
look at the database let's go into the
storage so we don't even have any posts
okay that folder has been deleted
because we only have had one post if you
go into the storage I mean fire store we
have no posts and this user had that
post but now posts is zero so we're
going to go ahead and update here as
well we forgot to do that so it was
related to this store where we just call
it user profile store and we would like
to decrement the number of posts for
this maybe we could add a delete post
function let say delete post and I'll is
how to accept this so it gets the post
ID and it is it is going to call the set
function with the previous state it is
going to return an object with the user
profile being as exactly was before but
it's only going to update the posts
array and it is going to remove or the
filter the post that we just deleted so
I hope it makes sense basically it just
delete the post from this state now
let's refresh and I'll just create
create one post and then delete it again
so let's select the picture of bath I'll
just
say this is bath and let's go ahead and
post
this post created successfully let's
create another post we just say this is
John and select the picture of the
John and post
it okay post has been created and it
says this user has has two posts let's
delete the
bth
okay and there we go this didn't work so
why it is not working let's see it is
because we didn't call this function
sorry it's my bad I forgot to do that so
we're going to go ahead and let's say
const delete post but we have the same
name so let's say delete post from
profile and we'll just say use user
profile store get the delete post
function now we're just going to call
this and delete post from profile pass
the post ID if we save we might want to
refresh this page and if we just delete
this now it should hopefully decrement
this by one let's go ahead delete the
John
and there we go it has been updated so
yeah success so this is how we create
posts and delete posts now let's go
ahead and try to comment to a post for
that let's just create a post so that we
can see what we're going to be doing
let's say um this is Bob and post
it okay let's
wait post created successfully and there
we go this is the post now let's delete
the comments so that we uh have a clean
State and also I want to change uh
something here which is going to be this
delete post from uh profile F I think
the name is really bad so when you read
the code it feels like as if we are
deleting the post from here but instead
we are just decrementing it from uh the
profile header so I'll go here and I'll
just rename this as I'll say controll d
uh
decrement posts count okay if we just
save okay now this is more readable and
this deletes the post from the profile
file so when you deleted it delete the
post it'll be removed from here this is
what this function does and also when
you delete the post this number will be
decremented and this is the function
that does that so when you read the code
now it makes sense so it is not going to
be uh confusing when you come back to
this code maybe one or two months later
okay with that in mind let's go ahead
make this a bit bigger and create
another hook that will post the comment
so let's say use post
comment.
JS oops it doesn't gives us for some
reason okay delete the return and let's
just get the boiler plate as always
we're going to have a loading state but
I'll just call it as is commenting
instead of is loading so is commenting
just preference and initially it is
going to be false let's import the use
State and then we are going to show
toast in case there is any errors so use
show toast and then we are going to get
the oath
user so use oath store and then just
give me the user and let's go ahead and
create the function const handle post
comment this is going to be the Asing
function that takes the post ID that
we're going to be commenting to and then
the comment text itself so so let's say
try catch finally and before we even try
we'll say set is commenting to be true
and in the finally set is commenting to
be false now in the try and maybe before
that let's
say if is commenting so this is
something that we always do so I will
not even explain this and then we're
just going to say if not o user so user
is not authenticated and for some reason
user still tries to comment this we just
say um let's open the
title we could just say you must be
logged into to comment so and just put
the um status which is the error and
then we say set is commenting is going
to be true and then let's create the
comment so con it's going to be an
object and as I showed you in the
diagram so let's go here here um okay
this is what we had so the comment
document is going to have the comment
field created by post ID and then the
created that so this is going to be the
things that we'll be adding so it is
going to be have the comment which is
coming as a prop or I mean an argument
so comment we're going to have the
created ad created ads we are using
date. now for this and then we're going
to go ahead say created by
which is going to be the O user. uid and
then we're going to have the post ID
again it comes as an argument so if the
left and right hand side is equal we
could just only have it like this so it
looks a bit more elegant and then in the
try I mean after this maybe we could
just take this put it right here and
then in the try we'll just say a wait so
we'll be updating the document so update
document which document is just going to
be let's get the function from the fire
store and then the posts and then the
post ID so this is the post that You'
like to update and the field that we're
going to update is just going to be the
comments array so we'll say array Union
to add the new comment so this just just
like you can read it as an English
sentence and then after this now this
has been updated in our database and we
would like to update our user interface
so let's say I go here and then I just
write something okay if I post that the
comment will be added into the database
but now we would like to also see that
here so for this we are going to create
a function in our store so it is going
to be called as ADD comment so let's say
const add comment and we're going to
create this so let's say use uh post
store and then give us the add comment
function delete this react import and
then here we would be calling it let's
say add comment with the post ID as well
as the new comment and in the catch
we'll just say show toast the error with
the message and lastly in this function
we are going to return is commenting as
well as the handle post comment function
so now let's go ahead and create this
function save this file um it is going
to be inside the post store that we have
here um to be honest this is going to
look a little bit complicated but if you
if your JavaScript background is strong
that shouldn't be a problem at all so
add
comment um so this is going to take the
post ID as we uh write so we just say
comment it is going to take the post ID
and then the comment so it is going to
call the setter function so let's open
that up Setter function and this is
going to take the previous state and
then just return an object where it is
going to be only updating the posts
array so we'll just say posts so this is
going to be colon so basically I'll just
accept this and then let me just explain
that um so we have some errors here
let's
see we are missing some parentheses
let's get that and then up here
okay okay that should be looking like
this so basically we are sending the
post ID and then the comment so we are
setting our state which is the posts and
we are mapping all posts and once we
find the post that we are commenting we
are updating the comments array with
that new comment and that should be at
the very end instead of putting to the
uh in the top so here I'll just add it
at the very bottom and then if this is
not that post we're just going to return
the other post as they were so and the
reason that we're adding the this
comment to the very end it is because
let's say we're going to go up here and
if you um put a comment here and once we
post it we would like to see that new
comment at the bottom of the latest one
so we don't want to take this comment
and put it up here so that's why we are
just having it having it at the very end
of the array so again I hope this makes
sense this was kind of complicated I I
admit but this is nothing else than a
JavaScript code so we can close this and
we're going to go into our hook we are
even adding the comment so we can go
into the profile post where we had that
comments so we want to delete this
comments and then instead we'll just get
the post. comments so post. comments in
this post we are getting it as a prop if
you remember okay this uh component
takes it as a prop so let's go here
post. comments. map get each comment
and then just render the comment
component so comment pass the key as
well as the comment itself we can save
this and let's go into this component
and then this is not taking any of these
that was for the design part that I need
to mention and then we'll just get the
comment we could for now um just comment
these out and then this one but here
we'll just say comment. comment which
was the comment text itself so now we
have created it but we didn't actually
Implement I mean we didn't call this
function in any place which is going to
be inside the post footer I believe
because this is the component uh that
has that uh input field that we can post
so we're going to go inside post
footer so let's go up here and then we
might want to add that uh custom hook so
use post comment and on the left hand
side we are going to get two things
which is is commenting and then handle
post comment function so when we go
click to this button we would like to
call another function so on click handle
submit comment let's say and again this
is for one reason that we'll see so we
could create that function up here so
const handle submit comment which is
going to be an async function so it's
going to be an arrow function so let's
implement it like this and let's see if
this was inside the for so it is not we
could just make it um so we don't need
to take the event and make prevent
default because this is not a form so
just say await call the handle post
comment with the post ID so let's say
post. ID but now how are we going to get
that post it is going to be coming from
here as a prop so let's say post and put
the post ID as well as the comment which
is going to be a state so const comment
set
comment and in the it's going to be use
State let's say an empty string so we're
going to go here into this input let's
say on
change take the event set the comment
and then the value will be that comment
now how are we going to get that post
where are we calling this it is going to
be inside the profile post where we had
this post footer so let's say um so this
is the profile post component right
which had that model when we clicked to
that it shows us this um it shows us
that model so we are just going to say
post and send it to here so post just
like this we could save this file into
here and now since we handled the post
comment we just want to set the comment
to be an empty string so let's save and
let's use this state as well when we are
commenting we will like to have a
loading state that shows us a spinner
and do we have any errors here okay it's
just a warning so let's go ahead and
test it out hey this is my first comment
and if I post
this let's see there we go we got the
comment and we had that loading State
let's take a look at our database so
these are the posts and we have one
comment that says hey this is my first
comment and it is created just now
created by this user and post ID so it
is working nice but the thing is this
comment doesn't have the profile Avatar
of that user right the only thing we
know about the user who posted this is
the ID so we are going to get the user
ID from
uh I mean we're going to get the user
profile information by this ID so we
need another hook to fetch user profile
from the ID we are just going to create
that in a second but this is how it
works we just put some comment storing
that in our state and we when we click
to that post button we are calling this
function so let's go here we are calling
this handle submit comment which
internally calls this function that
takes the post ID as well as the comment
and this function creates the comment in
our database as well as updating our
state and it is happening because it
calls this function called add comment
and it just takes our post array and at
the comment at the very end so that we
can see that so if I just put another
comment another comment of mine so since
it is going to be added into the very
end of our array we are going to see
that after this comment so let's pause
this we have loading State there we go
this is the latest comment that we have
and one more thing that we only want to
see this add comment input in this
button if the user is authenticated so
just imagine if a user is not logged in
then they shouldn't see this input that
just doesn't make any sense so let's go
into the post footer where we'll just
take the authenticated user so let's
just give a bit space const oath user
let's say use oath store get the user
from the state and then this is the
thing that we don't want to see if user
is not authenticated so cut this for a
second and if there is oath user so it
should be like this then render this
okay so if you logged out you will not
see this entire thing and now let's imp
Implement that hook that actually gets
us the user profile picture as well as
their um maybe username and just every
information that this user has and we
said that we're going to be creating a
custom hook and it is going to be called
as use get user profile by id. JS and we
had another one called get user profile
by username and this is going to be
different than this hook so we are going
to go inside let's say
rfca it is going to have a loading state
so let's say const is loading you can
call it as is fetching as well doesn't
really matter so you state initially it
could be true because we're going to be
calling this within a use I mean use
effect so it is going to be an immediate
call so let's say cost this is going to
return us a user profile right this
could be empty initially so I'll just
say null and and then we're going to get
the show
toast to show some
errors and then use
effect which is going to have a function
called con get user profile if I can
type profile oops okay it's going to be
an asnc function and we are just going
to call it it is not going to take the
user EP it is because this hook will
take the user ID okay so here let's just
say get user profiled and then this is
going to have a TR catch as
always try catch and maybe that could be
a challenge for you that you could
Implement and just pause the video at
this point so finally loading SE will be
false and when we start to do this
operation loading will be true set user
profile will be null because we didn't
fet it yet so const we are going to get
the user ref
so get so let's say a wait get doc call
the function and then the document is
going to be from fire fire store within
the users collection and it is going to
be this user that we want to fetch and
we are going to say if user ref. exists
which is a function that we can call
then just can you please set the user
profile with the data and in the catch
where they'll say show the toast with
the error message and this is going to
take the show
toast set user profile and most
importantly the user ID whenever this
user ID changes it is going to run this
user effect to fetch the user profile so
let's say return is loading user profile
and maybe set user profile as well in
case we use it and there is a typo here
that you can see user
profile that it should be okay we are
going to delete the react import as
always and it is getting a bit annoying
but let's just save and we're going to
be calling this inside the comment. jsx
so we got the comment now we would like
to fetch the profile of this user
depending on the ID which we can call it
as use get user profile by ID and then
the ID will be comment. created
by okay this is the field that we have
inside the comment so let's say const
give us the user profile as well as the
is loading State and we could say if it
is loading then just return the
comment skelet 10 which I will provide
you in a second again just 10 lines of
code literally nothing else skeleton
Circle UT the
skeleton so this is a flex on the left
it shows a Circle skeleton and then two
skeletons with this width and height so
we'll just get that and what we can do
so now that we got the user profile we
would like to show it so let's just
delete the name it doesn't really need
it but we will say user
profile. profile pick URL and that
should be uppercase size could be small
and then we are going to get the
username so user profile f. username and
what should we add else so this is the
comment that we are already getting and
then at the end we're going to show the
created that and more than that in a
little bit so if we save hopefully that
should be working fine we're going to go
here okay this is the user that has the
comment the username as well as the
comment itself now this doesn't look
really correct to me so it is not
aligned Center so we'll just go into
this and I'll just say align items to be
Center and hopefully it should fix um
okay so it looks like they are in the uh
so they are centered in vertical
Direction and now when we click to this
I would like to go to the profile of
this user so let's add a link so into
the Avatar I'll just say link import
that from react rou D to not the profile
but slash the oops so we have some
errors let's just delete that back text
close that and close this as well and
we're just going to wrap this Avatar
with this link so two slash uh dollar
sign and then Char Braes user profile.
username so it's is going to Tak us to
this page and let's copy this also wrap
it with our text that says the username
okay we'll just close that link oops o
not the Avatar but that should be slash
link um okay so this looks good to me
and if I click to this profile picture
it'll take me to my to this profile
which I already in so it just didn't and
if I click to this it'll also take me to
that profile so if those were another
profiles it would take me so let's add
another comment my
third comment and if I post that it has
been added here and it even had that
skeleton so let's just add something
else for a second you will see that
loading skeletons one Circle and then
those
texts there we go now we would also like
to add this created at time here for
this I will provide you a function
called time ago and it just takes the
Tim stamp and convert it it something
like 2 days ago two weeks ago 2 hours
ago and stuff like that we're going to
go and into the source create a uh
folder called utils and I'll just add
that so time ago. JS you can copy this
function and paste it which is to many
lines of code and I didn't write this by
myself I just get that from the chat GPT
so it basically takes a time stamp which
is dat. now and it converts it something
it converts the time stamp to something
like seconds ago minutes ago hours ago
days ago and eventually weeks ago so it
is not going to say like one year ago
but instead it will just say 52 weeks
ago this is how Instagram implements and
this is how we will be doing so let's
save and we're going to go into here
delete this import the time ago function
and we'll just say comment. created at
if we save this it should be working and
it just says 1 minute ago 12 minutes ago
and 30 minutes ago so everything looks
fine but there is still one problem
which is that we don't see the caption
of this post which actually have one so
let's go here this is the post the
caption that we said that this is Bob so
how are we going to get this which is
going to be creating another component
so profile post we are going to go
before the comments right inside the
vertical stack so let's just put a
comment that says these are the comments
maybe we would make it uppercase
so comments and then here we'll just put
the caption so we will just say that if
this post has a caption and then render
a caption component with the
post okay we're going to now create this
component so let's go maybe we should
put it into the comment you could create
another um folder but I think just to
make it simple I'll just go and say
caption. jsx because it is kind of
related to comment component so RFC and
the content is going to be looking
really really similar to the comment
component so I'm going to be copying
this and just paste it into here so
let's get the flex the link the
Avatar the
text um the text from
Chakra and then the time go we're going
to get this was taking a prop called
post and we'll just say post. created
add and then post. caption we're going
to show it so post. caption and then the
pro username of the user profile but
this is going to be coming from the
authenticated user or the user that
posted actually okay so if we are in a
in a profile and we are looking to their
post then the caption will be written by
by this user which is the profile of the
user so we had a state for this I hope I
make it clear so we just say user
profile which was the use user profile
store and give me that state so with
this I think that should be working fine
and um okay so let's save and we're
going to go here uh get this component
save it as well and if you open that up
this is the caption that we see it says
this is Bob and it has been created 24
minutes ago also what I want to add is
when I collected this icon I would like
to have this focused so we can use a ref
for this let's go into the post footer
and I'll just create a ra by the way we
can just delete this handle like
functionality but for now let's just
keep it so that it doesn't gives us any
errors so say const um maybe comment
ref use ref should be null initially and
then we're going to take this ref and
put it into this input okay let's say
ref comment ref and when we click to
that icon so the comment icon which one
is that um comment logo which is inside
this box I'll just say on clict to this
call this Anonymous function which Focus
the common TR so let's save
um okay so no warning at all we're going
to go up here if we click to that this
has been focused and we can just comment
something like this now that we have
handled the comments let's go ahead and
add a like and unlike functionality so
as always let's just create a hook for
this we're going to go into hooks maybe
we could just call it as use like post.
JS and then this is going to have the
everything
that we have in our boiler plate
basically const is loading you could
call it as is liking or I'll just call
it as is
updating okay set is updating initially
it is going to be
false um okay like this import the use
State and then let's get the oath user
so const oath user from the store and
then let's see what are we going to have
number of likes so const
likes set likes which is going to be us
State and how are we going to get this
is because is via the post so use State
and we're going to get the post as an
argument so this is the post that we are
liking or unliking so
post.
likes. length this is going to give us
the number of likes and then if we
already like this or or not so is liked
and set is
liked and initially it is going to be so
let's say use state so if the post that
likes includes the ID of the
authenticated user so includes Au oops
so this is really annoying includes the
oath user. uid and we need to just put a
question mark here so that we will check
if this user is authenticated and lastly
let's get the show
toast use show toast we have the
function and let's create it so con
handle like poost which is going to be
the async arrow function if is updating
it will just return and if there is not
oath fer we just going to return a show
toast that says You must be logged in to
like a post and if this is not the case
then we just pass these if checks then
we'll just say set is updating to be
true and here we go try catch and
finally set is loading to be so set is
updating to be false and then what are
we going to have in the catch show
toast um error message and then in the
try you'll basically update the
documents uh likes count which is going
to be the post now let's get the post
reference obviously con post rep
document fire store import that um posts
and then this is the post that we would
like to update which we pass the ID and
then a wait update document has the post
graph and then the object which is going
to be the data that we'll take to update
with so update document and then likes
array and we'll just say if it is light
then array. remove function so which
means that this user already liked it
right and if he still tries to call this
function which means that it is unliking
it so it is in this state so he already
liked it and now he clicks that one
again so now is like is true and if it
clicks that it is going to run this
portion I hope it makes sense array
remove um get it from the Firebase pass
the oath user. uid and if it is not the
case so it is liking so array oops array
Union let's get that and pass the oath
user ID so we are going to go here and
whatever the liked state is negate and
we'll just say if it is oops if it is
liked then number of likes will be
decremented and if it is not liked it is
going to be incremented by one and
finally at the end of the this hook
we'll just say return is updating is
liked so let's say okay is liked likes
handle like post and then is updating if
we save we delete this and now we're
going to go ahead and implement this
function or call this function so we're
going to go into the post putter this is
where we add that logic so let's delete
the likes liked handle like function and
instead we're going to be getting that
from our hook so use like post which
we're taking the post if we remember
right it takes the post and this is
going to return us four values so let's
say con give us the handle like post
function is likeed is updating in number
of likes so on click to this like button
we'll just say handle like post and if
it is liked I mean if it is not liked
show this notifications logo and which
is this logo okay the naming could be a
bit bad it is because we're using that
icon as well up here so let's go okay
and if it in the else case just show
this unlik logo and we're going to use
the updating State as well or maybe we
don't so I don't really want to show a
loading spinner when I click this like
button instead I would love to just have
it immediately this red color so I don't
really want to show a spinner so that's
why I'll just delete this if you wanted
to you can keep it and add your logic so
if we save this we need to test it out
so this has zero likes as we can see if
I click to that it is going to update in
the background now this post have one
like let's check it out um this is the
post and in the likes array let's go
ahead so these are the comments let's
close that up off and likes okay it has
one like which is been liked by this
user which is let's see it's start with
ik okay it is this user that just liked
so let's go into that post likes array
shrink this it has one like if we just
click that again it is going to have
zero likes it is because it has been
updated in the database as well so with
that now we have even our like comment
functionality as well so I think this is
pretty much everything that we need for
the profile page let's refresh so we can
create posts and we can edit our profile
edit profile picture we can see the
posts with the model so we can delete
that we can add comments like it unlike
it and I think that's it for the profile
page if there is anything else that I
for forgot I will be adding that in the
incoming sections but now we can go into
the homepage and actually fetch the feed
posts but now we have an error let's see
um okay it is related to this likes
because we didn't implemented in the
homepage so with that now let's get
started with the feed posts and fetch
them as always let's get started with
the hook that actually gets us the feed
posts into the hook hooks folder another
hook use get feed posts.
JS get the B plate and then we are going
to have a loading
State set is loading react state to be
initial value I think that could be true
because again we're going to using a use
State use effect and then here we're
going to have the let's say posts and
set posts and this time they will be
equal to the feed posts right we are
going to fetch that and these are coming
from the use post store and if we just
call it like this then we can get these
values and const oath user so let's get
that as well from our oath
store and then what do we need else show
toast get that from our hook and then
lastly we're going to have the
const set user profile and you're going
to see why once we use that not the o o
store but use user profile store and
State uh okay we don't need that because
we are destructuring it and then we are
going to call a use
effect so inside the use effect we are
going to have a function that gets us
the feed posts so feed post Asing
function and then it is going to have
try catch finally in the finally set is
loading to be false in the catch show
the toast with the error message so
let's say error with the error message
and in the try we're actually going to
try to fetch the posts but before that
let's say is loading will be true and if
the user let's say if oath user.
following
do length so dot length is equal to zero
which means that this user doesn't
follow anyone so we'll just reset our
state set is loading to be false and set
posts let's say to be empty array and
then just return out of this function
and if this is not the case then we are
going to do our query so let's say const
query which is going to be this query it
was taking the
collection P store and then it is going
to take the posts collection
where function okay the created by is in
oops so where created by field is in the
oath user. following array so this query
will gives us the posts of the user that
we follow and inside the try let's uh
execute this so const query
snapshot await get dogs so get dogs pass
the query in it and then we are going to
for each this so let's say const feed
posts and empty array and then we'll
just push it into here so query
snapchat. for each get the document
where we'll just return an object so
feed post. push the object
with the oops not so it should be Cur
Braes the ID of the document and then
all of the values just spread that so
document. data and we would like to sort
this posts with the created at field so
that they are going in descending order
so the latest created one at the above
so feed posts. sort depending on the
created at field and we'll just say set
posts to be feed posts and as the
dependency array we are going to add the
oath user so whenever that changes show
tost as well as set post and set user
profile and we are going to call this
function only if the oath user exists so
if user is authenticated then get the
feed posts so with that this function
should be completed let's save maybe
give a bit space and at the end we'll
just say return is loading as well as
the
posts okay so we could save let's go
ahead into the homepage so what do we
have let's take a look we have feed
posts so inside there we will try to
actually get those feed posts so delete
is loading delete this thing we're going
to be say con we're going to be saying
that is loading
and then the posts get them from the use
get feed posts custom hook which is
going to give us the loading State maybe
we could have only three skeletons and
then what are we going to have else is
so let's say this is going to be 400
pixels delete these use effect and use
States and let's render the feed posts
so I can delete all of these and we'll
just say if it is not loading in the
posts. length is greater than zero and
we'll just say posts. map so I think I
could delete this for now we say post.
map give me the each post and return a
feed post component for them and just
pass the post as an as a prop so we
could close that off and that should be
working fine for us we're going to go
into the feed post let's see it is is
going to be only taking the post comp I
mean post prop so let's say
post and inside the post header okay
inside the post header we'll just say
that send the post and nothing else so
let's go into the post header we are
taking the
post so we'll just say
post. um so the Avatar of the user
profile so for now we don't have that
value so instead I will just contrl Z I
don't want to make it any complicated I
will just remove this okay and let's see
I will remove the post footer as well
and I just want to show the post image
for now so we'll just go step by step so
that you guys don't get confused so
post. image URL this is going to show
the post and let's say uh feed post
image and let's save we are going to go
into the post header save this as well
let's take a look now um so if we just
save it like this and we have an error
so let's take it
back now what is going to say in the
console Let's see we
refresh um so we don't have any any
posts okay we don't have any errors and
we don't see any post it is because none
of the users that we follow has any any
posts so let's go ahead and create some
we're going to go and login so this is
the login I'll just say
Jano 1 2 3 4 5 6 and then
login um okay J at
gmail.com let's log in we are going to
create post as being Jane or if we just
follow this user we should see their
Post in our profile and there we go we
see the post in our homepage not the
profile page and if we go into our
profile we can see that we are following
one user which is this one and he had
this post now we can add the post header
as well as the post footer so let's go
ahead and render the post header but the
thing is in the post header we would
like to see the profile picture the
username that has posted this and we
don't really get that it is because in a
post document the only information we
have about the user is their ID which is
they created by and this is okay because
that's why we have created one hook that
is called use get user profile by ID
okay get user profile by ID sorry about
that we're going to go into the feed
post and just call it so let's say use
get user profile by ID and the ID is
just going to be post. created by so
this is going to give us the profile of
that user so let's get that const user
profile there we go we're going to get
the post header where we are sending the
post as well as the let's say Creator
profile which is going to be the user
profile this is the user that created
this post and we are getting that data
which we will render in a second so
let's go here we're going to take the
post as well as the Creator so what was
it uh Creator
profile so from the post header we can
also follow follow and unfollow which
will come back in a second so let's say
in the Avatar we'll just say that Source
will be Creator
profile. profile
pick URL and then the username is just
going to be the exact same thing
Creator profile. username and if we just
save this that should hopefully work
fine let's go here there we go we see
this user profile picture
username and then this follow button
which will just change in a second but
now we would like to go to the profile
of this user when we clict this image or
the username so what should we do is
going to be just wrapping this thing
with a link so before the Avatar I'll
just copy one line which is this link
component that takes us to the profile
of this user and I will close that off
down here so slash link import the link
and we're going to be doing the exact
same thing for this uh usern name field
so I will copy this line and paste it
here then just close it maybe down here
if we save Let's test it out we're going
to go here if we click that it should
take us to this profile and let's go to
the homepage and we have one error which
we'll check in a second that is coming
from post header the reason that we are
getting this error is because in the
homepage we are trying to get user
profile and while it gets that there is
a loading state so for that we can show
a skeleton instead of showing these
avatars and this username so let's go
before the link we'll just say Creator
profile if it exists render this or if
it is not then render this so so in the
uh exist place we're going to put that
link so I'll just cut it paste it and if
it is not exist we will just show a
skeleton so I could just say skeleton
circle with the size of 10 and import
the skeleton Circle and we'll just do
the exact same thing so let's go here
instead of copying and pasting I'll just
say if Creator Creator profile exists
question mark render this else render
this and in the else case we're going to
show a skeleton in the correct case we
are going to let's say we'll just show
this thing I'll cut that paste it and
for the skeleton we could have width of
100 pixels and height of 10 pixels and I
think this should have um okay we'll
just take this box out of this place get
the skeleton save it and now sorry if
that look looked any confusing but this
is what we have for the loading State we
just show a skeleton and skeleton Circle
so that we don't get any errors so
hopefully let's refresh and we don't
have any errors but instead we have that
loading state so I will
refresh do you see like we have that
loading skeleton and now we would like
to add this um follow and unfollow
functionality to here and you might
think that it is really hard how are we
going to type that functionality again
but this is not the case we already
created that so use follow hook right
we're going to go into the post header
and we'll just say use follow user so
just call it with the user that you
would like to follow so just say post.
created by so if you remember this hook
we're taking the user ID that you would
like to follow or unfollow that's why we
are passing the ID of this user which in
turn will return us so handle follow
user function is following state so
either true or false and the loading
state which is updating so let's save
and how are we going to handle that will
be from this button for now it says text
but I think we should change it with a
button so that it actually makes sense
and font size 12 let's say say size is
just going to be XM small and then
background of
transparent and lastly after all these
styling we will just add that onclick
function handle follow user and for the
updating state is loading will be is
updating so let's save and do we have
any errors is following okay the text
that says follow or unfollow will be
depending on that state so if it is
following then it is just going to say
unfollow so un follow and in the El case
it's going to say follow and that's it
this is the beauty of custom Hooks and I
just set that 100 times but I'll just
say it again and again that's why this
is what makes your code clear so let's
save and with only one line we are able
to follow and unfollow a user so let's
go ahead if we refresh we are going to
get a clean State now we are following
this user that's why it says unfollow if
I click that now I am unfollowing that
and now this user is inside the
suggested user component and I don't see
any post in my Prof I mean in my
homepage and in this case user might say
hey why I don't see anything so let's go
into the feed posts component and show
something like hey man you don't uh
follow anyone just go ahead and make
some friends so after this feed post we
are just going to check for one
condition so if it is not loading so
let's say not is loading and post.
length is equal to zero which means that
this user don't have any friends so it
is not following anyone so we are just
going to create a text so I think I'll
just copy and paste
it so it says damn looks like you don't
have any friends stop cutting and go
make some so we could save and let's
take a look this is the output that we
got and if we follow this user let's see
there we go it has been updated in our
feed and we see this post and let's
follow this user as well but it doesn't
have any posts so we will not be able to
see that in our feet but let's just
follow him as well and there we go now
we would like to add the post footer as
well so let's go here here we'll go into
the feed post where we have the post
putter instead of rendering the username
that was for the design part I need to
say that again so that you remember so
we're going to have the post send that
and also the Creator profile which is
the user profile so that we can show
some information about the user I will
save this I'll go into the post foter
and then let's see what are we going to
be adding so this will also take the
Creator
profile okay that was this prop and we
are going to go down below and where we
have this if it is not in the profile
page so which means that now we are in
the homepage and we are rendering the
post footer instead of showing the
username we are going to say Creator
profile. username and we should put a
question mark so that uh we don't get
any errors if it is in the Lo loing
State and then we would like to see the
post post. caption so post. caption and
then what do we want to see instead of
this uh so 1,000 hardcoded value we'll
just say post. comments.
length and we are only going to show
this if this post has any comments so we
don't want to say like we all zero
comments if this post any post I mean if
this post doesn't have any comments then
we are not going to even render this so
I'll cut that for a second I'll say
post. comments. length is greater than
zero then render this thing that I just
copied or I cut it and let's see font
size of small color gray and let's say
cursor will be pointer and we're going
to be adding another functionality so
that when we click to that we will see
all of the comments um we'll just delete
this let's save and hopefully it should
be wor working okay we see the post
footer where we have view all five
comments it is because this post has
five comments and if you don't want to
believe me let's go to the profile page
we're going to
wait so if we hover over this this post
has five comments so 1 2 3 4 five and
this is the caption so let's go to the
home so after this likes count we would
like to show when this post has been
created it but we don't really want to
see that here it is because so let me
just add that and you will understand so
below the likes I will go ahead and I'll
say if it is in the profile page so not
in the homepage because we are using
this component both in the homepage and
in the profile page so I'll say give me
a text that has the font size of 12 not
family font
size 12 and then let's say color will be
gray and inside this text you'll just
say post it time ago and then post that
created at so import the timeo function
scoop this thing in and save it I think
we're going to go ahead and save it like
that so if we go into the homepage we
don't see that but let's go into the
profile page of this user and if we
click this post now it says posted 1
hour ago after this likes so it is
because we have that after the likes we
say post it our ago and then we only see
that if we are in the profile page so at
this point I feel like I am explaining a
bit too much but hopefully we are
understanding everything as we go also
Let's test it out if we can like the
post from the homepage and that should
be working I'll click to that now this
post has one like let's take a look this
this post um let's see cancel it has one
like if I say unlike and it is updated
now this doesn't have any likes so we
can just like unlike and let's add one
more comment one more comment from the
homepage and let's post it and it
immediately says view all six comments
because we have built our application in
a way that every state is in sync with
each other so this is absolutely
fantastic and yeah I'm just proud of the
application that we have built so far
with that Flex out of the way let's go
ahead and add this functionality where
when we click to this view all six
comments button it is going to open up a
model that shows all of the comments and
we are going to be doing that I think if
we are only in the
homepage um it is because in the profile
page if we click the post we already see
all of these and in fact we don't even
see that we all six comments in this
component it is because all of the
comments are here so here we have a
little bit of styling error but I just
let that as a challenge for you so you
would just fix that but in this case
it's okay and I don't really want to
waste any time so let's go ahead and
build it in this component where when we
click this we are going to open up a
model so I'll just give a break and then
come back to this functionality okay
let's go ahead and build that model so
when we collected this text we would
like to open up that model so we are
going to be using the model component
from Chakra when we click to this text
inside the post footer so before that
let's create that component you can
create it into this comment folder
because it is related to comments but
instead I'll just create another folder
called models and I'll just put my
comment model here
jsx and at this point I will copy and
paste it about 30 lines of code and I
will copy and paste it again so that you
can copy and paste this it is nothing
than just a model so let me just put it
here copy and paste as the starter
code for the
comment comments model
component okay we should rename this
let's say
comments and it is called as comments
model so what it has is just a basic
model which is taking is open and on
close as props so we're going to go
ahead inside the post footer and we're
going to call it right here so since we
are using a model we'll just say use
disclosure hook it is going to give us
three values is open let's say const is
open on open and on close so we are
going to go and say when we collected
this VI all comments unclick open up the
model so onop and we only want to see
this model if we are in the homepage so
if it is not profile page so we're going
to go ahead and let's say comments model
only in the home page let's say if it is
open then just render the
comments model and we're going to pass
the is open and on close oops so that
should be here on close it's going to
take on close as well as the post so
that we can fetch the comments from this
post let's close that off and maybe it
is just better if we use it like this
I'm going say
null okay so that should be working
hopefully let's save and let's take a
look we're going to go here if you click
that it is going to call the onop
function where we just get this model
and when we post a comment we're going
to see that comment here and currently
we are not fetching any comments because
this comment has I mean this post has
six comments we would like to see all of
these so we don't really need to fetch
it because post already have it and we
already fetch that in other components
so we are going to go ahead into the
comments model into this Flex we're just
going to render that so this component
will be taking a post as a prop that we
sent right here okay this is taking the
post itself so we'll just go ahead and
inside this Flex we'll just map that so
post. comments. map give me each comment
and then render this jsx which is going
to be the the comment component itself
it is going to have the key as well as
the comment so we don't have this
comment component so let's import that
um it is coming from from the comment
folder um and then get the comment so if
we use it like this then we have an
error before that let's comment this out
it is because we don't have this ID
inside the comment object so I'll just
say console.log the poost save it let's
take a
look
if we open this up there we go this is
the post and comments array but each
comment don't have an ID in this object
at least in the database so let's go
here posts so these are the comments
array that we have but we didn't really
put an ID maybe we should um in at this
point it is not really a problem so we
can use uh the index as the key but I
would suggest you to just add a comment
when you create that so it is going to
be here so you would somehow add an ID
into this comment and there are other uh
functions that Firebase actually handles
that for you so just check out the
documentation and add that so let's not
waste any time I'll just delete this and
let's go here comment this out and then
we'll just say key is going to be the
index let's get that so adx we're just
going to say key will be idx starting
from zero let's save and hopefully that
should be working we are going to go
ahead and there we go these are the all
of the comments that this post has so
when we click to that it has the All
loing State and it shows up so we can
even comment from here if we wanted to
let's add that functionality we're going
to go into this comments model and when
we collected this or when we submit this
form we would like to uh post the
comment so you might think that we need
to create this functionality all over
again but not really we have a hook that
post the comment so we're actually going
to be calling it so let's say use post
comment this hook will give us two
values so the function let's say const
um so the function was handle post
comment as well as the loading state
which was the is commenting so we're
going to go ahead and let's say when we
submit this form on submit call a
function called handle submit
comment and you'll see why we're using
this function we'll just say const it is
going to be an async function e. prevent
default so this is the first reason we
don't really want to refresh our page so
do not refresh the
page prevent it and then after
preventing this we'll just say a wait
call this handle post common function
and if you remember it was taking the
post ID as well as the comment itself
and we can get this comment's value by
using a ref so let's say const comment
ref you can use a use State as well but
I'll just go with a comment ref and then
this is going to be into the input let's
say ref comment ref so when you type it
into this input you can get the final
value by saying comment r current. value
and this is going to post the comment
for you so let's import this one and use
the loading State for the button is
loading will be equal to is commenting
and once we post the comment we would
like to clear that input so just say
comment R current value is going to be
an empty string so that should be handle
for us actually let's save and again be
of custom hooks where we just call it in
on line get the function call it have
the loading State and everything works
flawlessly um let's go ahead and test it
out I'll just refresh in case we have
any errors um so yeah so this the
question mark we have it is because I
submitted off camera so let's take a
look um one more comment
from the comment model so let's say
comment from comments model and if you
just post okay it says n. index of is
not a function so what this problem is
okay that was taking the post ID and I
just sent the post if we save let's test
it out again one more
comment let's say uh let's post this it
it has the loading State and there we go
so now we can scroll and this is the
comment that has just been posted one
second ago and here it also updates the
state where it just says view all seven
comments so let's add one more I'll just
say one more and that should be
eight okay it has been updated and here
we go the new comment is here but when I
comment so if I just put something here
I want to this scroll bar to scroll for
me and we can use a use effect for this
we're going to implement that inside
this commments model jsx component you
will just say get a ref initially so
const
comments container ref and it's going to
be null and we'll just put it into the
commments Container which is this Flex
that holds all of the commments so let's
say ref and the reason that we're
putting this we are just going to scroll
to the very bottom in this container so
max site is 250 and once there is a new
comment we'll just scroll to the Bott
bottom and also on the mount when this
component so when we first open that up
we will like to just scroll to the very
end so let's add that we'll just say use
effect for this now we're going to go
inside and create a function that
actually scroll to the bottom okay so
it's going to be only one line so let's
say
comments container ref. current. scroll
Toop is going to be equal to this uh
scroll height so that will just scroll
to the very end for this uh container
and then we'll just say if this is open
so on the on Mount we'll just say scroll
to bottom and this should run whenever
the is open changes as well as the post
comments. length so whenever a new post
comment I mean new comment post it it is
going to scroll to bottom so if if we
save it like this then we're going to
get an error so let's see I will click
to this and it says that um so it cannot
read properties of null which is scroll
height so it is because when this use
effect runs for the first time so on the
on Mount this uh thing is empty the
container. current is null and this is
because I think how react renders things
so we could maybe just delay this I'll
cut that set
time out and just delay it for 100
milliseconds not 1,000 but 100 so if you
just call it like this then it should
fix the problem let's go here um close
here let's say we all 11 comments and
there we go it's scroll to the very end
for us I'll just say hey scroll for me
and post it there we go it scroll for us
to the very last comment so this is
going to be it for this component and
function fun ality in the homepage where
we can see all comments and even comment
from this component and I think this is
the entire application that we have just
built in the homepage we see the posts
of the users that we follow we can like
that or unlike that we can see all the
comments or even we can comment
ourselves as well so we can follow these
users or unfollow them and it is going
to update our user interface depending
on that we have that suggested user
component where we can also follow users
from there we can visit our own profile
and edit our profile by adding editing
profile picture as well as these inputs
so we could create a post that will
update our user interface as well as the
post State and we were even handling the
error States so if you just post without
an picture or image it'll just say
please select an image file and then we
could search for users if we search for
ourselves so let's say jandoo it is not
going to show show that follow button or
if you just search for someone like
jandoo it is going to actually show that
follow or unfollow button and besides
all these we have authentication going
on where we can log out create an
account with email and password log in
with that or we can basically sign up or
sign in with our Google account so let's
see if there is any optimizations that
we can add and then we're going to get
into the fire store add our security
rules and then just deploy the
application
the first optimization or fix that we
can add will be this uh posted time so
we're going to go ahead instead of
having this hardcoded value inside the
post header we'll just say call our
function maybe I'll just give a bit
space time ago function call it with the
post do created at timestamp so let's
save and you'll just see that it has
been updated to the actual value another
optimization that we could add will be
inside the create post component so so I
said that we are going to create this
path name and we're going to use it
later so it is now time to use it so the
thing is when we are creating a post we
are updating this state and it is
because let's go here it is inside the
user profile sore that is used to update
the number of posts in the profile page
so if I create a post in this page which
is my profile then it is going to update
the number of posts but I only want to
increment this if I am in this page so
if I create a post in the homepage I
don't really want to update this state
because this is null when I am in the
homepage so I'll just go ahead and say
that if the path name is not equal to
the home so I'll just say not equal then
actually call this function so we could
make it on line and save it now this is
that optimization that we just added but
now I think we have another problem so
if I am in the profile page of this user
which is not me so I'll just create
another post so I will just select the
image of Bob and maybe not Bob so let's
go ahead and say John okay I'll just say
this is John now if I post this this is
not the profile that this is not our
profile okay if we post then now it is
going to look like if if this user has
two posts which is not correct so we are
going to add if this is not the homepage
and we're going to say if user profile
do we have that
value no we need to get that so we'll
just say duplicate this give us the user
profile
State okay we'll say user profile. uid
is equal to the oath
user. uid so if this is our profile then
update that number of posts so let's
save and I'll just create another post
by refreshing this so this user has one
post now I'll just create another
one so I'll just just say this is B and
if we post that hopefully it shouldn't
increment and there we go but we have
another problem that it adds this post
into this profile and it is because we
are updating this state whatever happens
so I will just copy this maybe or
actually cut this I'll just say
if this thing okay if user profile. uid
is equal to oath
user. uid then actually update this
state by creating the post function so
let's go ahead refresh and test it
out
so I'll just say please work let's post
so it shouldn't update anything in this
page and there we go post created
successfully number of posts didn't
increment the posts um so to say the
post hasn't been added into this field
and if we go into our own profile page
there we go we have three post and they
are all posted just now so 1 minute ago
and 2 minutes ago so even test out
further I'll just create another post
but in my own profile page so I'll just
select it maybe
John not the John so let's say
Bob I'll just say this is Bob or even I
don't have to say anything in the
caption if I post that now it should add
it into this component and there we go
number of posts has been incremented by
one which means that it works as
expected now one more thing that we like
to add is that when we click to the
suggested users profile picture or the
name we would like to get into his
profile so for this we can go into the
suggested user. jsx and we're going to
wrap our Avatar with a link so I'll just
paste this line where it just uh links
to the user. username it's going to take
us to his page and let's close that off
and we're going to import the link from
react router D which I already had okay
and for the uh full name we're going to
just do the exact same thing I'm going
to copy this line and then wrap this box
with it so let's paste the link closing
tag and now if we click to their profile
that should take us to their page so
these were the fixes and optimizations
that we could make into our application
and now I'll just pause the video here
and I will add a couple of more users
into this application and then I'll just
add a couple of more posts so that our
homepage looks a little bit cooler
okay so I have added three more accounts
the first one being is Jesse Pinkman
which we are logged in as Jesse so let's
go to homepage we don't have any friends
so let's just make some we're going to
follow the Walter as well as the Skyler
so let's wait for that okay it's been
updated and let's follow this girl as
well there we go now we have all of our
posts in our feet the users that we
actually follow so we could
like the this looks insane let's just uh
post a
comment and there we go we have one
comment let's see that Jesse says this
looks insane so we could follow other
users and the feed posts will be sorted
from the latest created one to the very
first one so this is the entire
application now let's go ahead and add
our security rules into our Firebase
console so now I am in the fire store
database and I click to this rules tab
so here we can see our security rules
and this is not secure at all it's
because it always allows to read and
write operations as long as we are
within this Tim stamp which we are so we
don't really want this so we're going to
delete that and inside this statement
we're going to go ahead and write our
rules so we will allow every user to
read users collection so even if they
are logged out they are not
authenticated they can still come to to
this page the Jessi Pigman page and they
can see this informations such as
biography of Jesse username number of
posts followers uh number of following
and that kind of stuff so we're going to
go ahead and we'll just T and match the
users collection and then a placeholder
so this value could be anything I'll
just say user ID because this is what
that is and then Cur races we're going
to write our rules so we would like to
allow read operations always so even if
you are logged in or you are logged out
it doesn't really matter but we only
want to allow to write operations so
Colin and your rules so or the
conditions if
request. oath is not null so if user is
authenticated this is what it says and a
user can only wrun write into their own
document so they cannot go and update or
write into another user's document so
let's say request. oath which is the
which is the user that actually sends
the request. uid is equal to this user
ID document if this is the case we are
going to allow the write operation and
now let's go ahead and write the post
security rules so we are going to allow
everyone to read posts so such as post
info maybe like the post text right the
caption the post image number of likes
and maybe also the comments so let's
just write it down and then we'll just
write a couple of more so I'll say match
the posts collection and then post ID
again this is a placeholder that could
be anything but it should be meaningful
right so let's say allow read operations
in any case so always and then you're
going to say allow they should be able
to create posts only if they are
authenticated so I'll just say if
request. oath is not
null so same goes for the update so
allow update operations if request is
request. O is not null so if user is
authenticated and so we have an end here
it is that a user can only update a post
if he is the creator right so we'll just
say request. oath. uid is equal to now
how are we going to get the posts um so
like post created by field if you
remember we had that so this is how we
get that so we just say resource in this
case it is going to be the
post. data not date data and created by
so that was the field that we had if you
remember and it's going to the same
thing for delete operation so maybe I
will just copy this
line and paste it so allow delete
operations if user is authenticated and
user is the owner of this post and
that's it now if you wanted to you could
add more uh rules so you would just
think of it what can I add to here just
to make it more secure so I'll just
publish this rules and let's see
so okay it says publish changes can take
some time so you should just readit a
little bit so while it is being done in
the background so maybe I'll just zoom
in a little bit so that you guys can see
that in a better way okay like this I
think it is better and let's go ahead
and just add our environment variables
in case you push this repo to your
GitHub and we're going to go into the
Let's see we had this inside the
Firebase these are going to be our
environment variable that we're going to
put into aemv file the first thing that
we need is to create an EMV file so I'll
just go into the rout and I'll just say
EMV and now in V if you want to create
EMV I mean environment variables you
need to prefix it with vcore so
something like so this is the API key
let's say and I'll just say
vcore Firebase uncore API uncore key and
it is going to be equal to this value
I'll just copy and paste
it and now I'll just do the same thing
for all of these values okay maybe I'll
just spit up this part or maybe I'll
just cut it okay so I just put them side
by side there you can see we have the
API key Vore Firebase uncore API uncore
key and then just put the value and I
just uh do the same thing for this
remaining six ones so the O domain uh
the project ID storage bucket messing
and ID app ID measurement ID so just do
the same thing copy and paste that now
instead of putting this string we'll
just use that value from that EMV file
so I'm going to save this file from here
and then the way to do this or to use
this will be with import so we'll just
say
import. meta do EMV do and you just get
the each value one by one so in our case
Vore Firebase API key and I'll just do
the same thing thing for each of these
so here I just basically did the exact
same thing I got the O domain project ID
storage bucket all of them from The Meta
EMV and now I think we could save this
and let's take a look if our application
still functions but maybe we need to
just kill our terminal terminal and open
that up um I think that might be
required some cases when you update the
EMV file so let's say contrl B to open
up this panel and inside the get ignore
we will to add this EMV file so we are
going to go ahead let's see maybe at the
very bottom we'll just say EMV just
ignore this file uh this file in our
GitHub repo so let's see if our
application has been initialized or
started yes it is in this port let's go
ahead and we'll just say and let's see
if that still
works okay it is loading and it's been
loaded actually say hey Jesse nice car
and if you just send that and hopefully
it is still working so it is still
connected to our Firebase account and
one thing so in the terminal you see
this as um so this IP address instead of
Local Host address right if you put that
you might get an error while while you
are logging in or signing up with your
Google account and for this you need to
go into the Authentication
as far as I believe so into the settings
let's see so authorize domains you need
to go here and add one more domain and
it should be this so let's
see okay we need to take this and just
paste it so you could either do it in
that way or you would just use something
like just like me just Local Host
517 uh 73 this port address and you'll
not get any errors when you login or
sign up with your Google account so just
keep that in mind if you if any of you
get that error and I think with that our
application is ready to go so we can
even search for other users let's say
Walt or maybe
Heisenberg that was the username that I
created so let's search this is the
Walter White that we are following we
could go into his profile and there we
go this is all of his post we can
like um okay so missing or insufficient
permissions so I think we did something
wrong in the Firebase rules so let's
take a look um this is not our error
okay we cannot like maybe it is so it is
definitely related to security rules and
it is nice that we see this error so
let's check that so I think it is
related to this line I haven't tested
out so I'll just delete this so we here
we are just saying that if we are the
owner of this post then we can update it
but this is not the case so this post
has been posted from this user but we
are the Jesse right so when we like that
we are actually updating this post likes
count so we should delete this line and
let's publish this and let's see if that
will solve our errors now I will go into
this application maybe I'll just do a
quick
refresh and now let's try to like a
post and there we go now we can like and
unlike and I am really happy that we got
that error while doing some live coding
or live checking so now we can like or
unlike so let's just put a comment hey
dude let's post that and there we go
post has been posted if we refresh we
going to still see that post and and
yeah I mean we can still see that
comment and we can like that post again
so this is going to be it for the
Firebase rules and implementations now
the only thing that we left should be to
actually push this repo into our GitHub
account so this is a git repo if yours
is not you should just say git in it and
press enter that will initialize it as a
git repo but mine is already a git repo
so I even have I think two comets so
I'll just say git log d-1
line and there we go I have one commit
that I have committed when I uh
completed the design part and then one
more to update the read me file and now
it is time to add another commit and I
think this is going to be the last one
hopefully so I'll just say get add all
but before that let's check if there is
anything that we don't want to push um
so EMV is ignored and okay that should
be it I think there is nothing important
other than that EMV file in our case
right so we are even storing them and
yeah so get add all and we'll just say
get commit maybe we should say um as the
message completed the entire application
so you never so you actually never
complete a project so I'll just say
addit or maybe something
like
connected design to the back
end and let's just commit
this now we are basically going to just
push that to the GitHub so to say get
push and that should handle that for us
okay so we're just going to go into the
versal and import that git repo and then
just deploy it okay so now I am at
ver.com slne if you don't have an
account create one for free and then get
into this route so we're going to import
this Instagram clone uh project so I'll
just import that and we need to add our
environment variables for this we're
going to go into here and just copy all
these and let's go here environment
variables just click to this and paste
it is going to paste all of them for you
and you'll just deploy that so let's
wait while it deploys and there we go it
says congratulations you just deployed a
new Pro to ourself so let's continue to
dashboard so here it gives us two uh or
maybe yeah two domains so let's just
click to
this and here we have three domains
actually so let's click to this one and
it's going to take us to this page we
could go to this one okay so we got in
security error it is because uh Google
thinks that you're actually doing some
really bad operations because Instagram
is a very well-known application so it
just thinks that you are trying to cheat
people so for this we can go and just
change our domain so that was the so
let's go into the settings this is our
project so we're going to go into I
think maybe advance or
deployment so let's see what we have
environment
nope um so we okay we have domains so
we're going to click that and we'll just
edit this so here I'll just change it I
don't know what to say so I don't want
to think about it I'll just say social
app as a programmer and you could just
put really anything that you want and
I'll just save so this is the new domain
we have if we click that we are never
going to get that security error so
because Google doesn't think now this is
it we are cheating someone okay so we're
going to go ahead and try to log in so
maybe I'll just say Skyler at
gmail.com from 1 to 6 that should be 1 2
3 4 5 6 let's log in and hopefully it
should log Us in and there we go Skyler
doesn't follow anyone so let's go ahead
and follow the husband and we have again
unsufficient permissions we're going to
go into the Firebase rules so I am sorry
that we are getting these errors and
again we are trying to update the users
do collection it is because when we
follow someone we are incrementing the
number of followers and we are trying to
update that but this rule doesn't allow
us so we could just delete this and save
and maybe there would be a better way to
write this rules but you get the point
and after this video maybe you could
just improve this and yeah so we just
published that so let's go ahead and
test it out so now we are here I'll just
refresh this page and let's see so this
user has one follower now let's try to
follow it again
and there we go now we can follow that
and update that user document and we can
just see any post we can like it hey
nice post we can even comment and we
have comments we can see that and just
everything there is one more thing that
we are missing so if we go to the
homepage in this application it works
but if we try to go let's go to here
inside the application we can go to this
page but let's
um just press enter to directly go to
this page so we're going to get an error
because routing is not handled for us so
we cannot just copy this and open up a
new tab and just paste it so it doesn't
work it is related to V and we need to
go and create a file called versal Json
so into the root of the
project so we'll just say unal do Json
and then just just paste this line which
you can grab from the preo so basically
with this above code we are telling your
cell to map incoming roads to the file
that points to the index HTML so we're
going to save this and let's get add all
kit commit
DM uh ver cell. adjon file
addit and we'll just get push
that so once we push this the versel is
going to take a look at so let's go into
our versel account so versel is going to
take a look at the project and it's
going to see there is a new commit so
it's going to try to redeploy this so if
we go into the deployments here we
should see that okay it has just been
deployed and it just says just now so
we're going to click to that or let's
just refresh this page and hopefully it
should work now so we can copy this row
other than homepage and just paste it
into a new tab and it is going to
immediately work so that was kind of
like a trick that you need to know when
you're building a VAB in versal in
viral.com so I just realized there is
one more problem or error if we try to
log in with our Google account currently
we cannot and it says unauthorized
domain so we just need to copy this
domain and we're going to go into the
authentication settings and authorize
domains so we'll just say add domain and
paste that we're going to just delete
this only have the root domain up until
this veral do app and let's just add
that and hopefully it should work now so
I'll just do
refresh and now if you just click to
that it is going to use our Google
account and then just log Us in so I
think it is the end of the project we
just built our own Instagram clone I
hope you enjoy it as much as I do and
learn something new from it and now you
should be able to add all kinds of
features to this app because now you
know how to work with authentication
fire store and storage Services of
Firebase and if you add more features to
this app let me know in the comments and
with that I wrap up the video here don't
forget to like And subscribe and thanks
for watching